COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
COMMITTEE AND EDUCATION
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE- IF YOU BEAR
WITH ME FOR A COUPLE OF MINUTES
THERE'S AN EIGHTY LANGUAGE THAT
WE HAVE TO READ. AND THEY WILL
GET IN THE FORMAL COMMENTS AND
ASK FROM COMMENTS BRIEF
COMMENTS MANY OF THE MEMBERS
ARE HERE WHO WISH TO SPEAK. ON
THE ISSUE. I DON'T HAVE A GAVEL
SO I'LL BEGIN THE HEARING. BY
FIFTEEN DOWN. I COULD MORNING
WE LIKE TO WOULD LIKE TO
CONVENE THE JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATIONS
ACCOUNT VANCE AND ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. TO THE
CONTINUED STAY HOME ORDER WERE
PRACTICING SOCIAL DISTANCING
HERE N THE ROOM IN THE ROOM-
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE- WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRED THAT MASS BE WORN
AND PHYSICALLY DISTANCE BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WHETHER
THEY'RE HERE IN THE ROOM OR THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THOSE INTHE BOOK- FOR THE- FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. TODAY
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND LIMIT
THE NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
DISTANCING. THERE'S ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
IT TO THE PUBLIC AT TO ENTER
AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND FOR
THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
DURING PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND- AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I
WOULD ALSO ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
DO NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU. ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN YOUR SEAT.
BE SURE THAT YOUR OBSERVE THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. AT ALL TIMES.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM.
HOW FOR DAHLE AND WITNESSES. WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATOR
TELEPHONE SERVICE. TO WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IN A REPEAT
SEVERAL TIMES IT WILL BE ON THE
SCREEN AS WELL. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE TO
REPEAT SEVERAL TIMES AND SHOULD
ALSO BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN.
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FORTY
THREE SEVEN. A FELLOW SIMPLER
THIRTEEN. 284-037-1315 FORTY
THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER OF BOTH ON THE
ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE AND THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITES
AND I REPEAT AGAIN ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AS WE BEGIN THE FINAL
PANEL OF THE AGENDA. THE
OPERATE ONLINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED. ON HOLD. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE LIMIT ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND.
ALTHOUGH NOT INCLUDING THE
TALKING POINTS I WILL TELL YOU
FROM SPEAKING TO MANY WHO HAVE
CALLED IN A PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE IS A DELAY- IN VIDEOING
TO WHEN YOU COME ON SO IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT YOU PAY
ATTENTION TO YOUR PHONE. AND
NOT TO THE SCREEN OR THE
WORDING COMING UP ON YOUR
SCREEN PLEASE PROTECT YOUR
PHONE FROM. PLEASE BE ALSO
ADVISED OF THE MAIN WITNESSES
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. THAT IF
YOU ARE THE MAIN WITNESSES
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED UPON TO SPEAK. FOR A
W. V. R. WITNESSES. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY INSIDE
THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME
WITNESSES THEY'LL BE MAKING USE
OF ONE OF OUR VIDEO SITE ONE OF
ARE WITNESSING VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
THOSE WITNESSES APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN TO THE MEMBERS CAN WATCH
HER TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE
OF THE HEARING ROOM AND ALSO
ASK QUESTIONS THESE WITNESSES
SUCH AS THE MONITORS THAT YOU
SEE BEFORE YOU. THERE ALSO BE A
SLIGHT DELAY IN THE STREAM FROM
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
SO PLEASE BE PATIENT THEY WILL
HEAR A LITTLE BIT LATE AND WE
WILL HEAR THEM A LITTLE BIT
LATE. IF YOU ARE HAVING ANY.
PROBLEMS WITH ANY OF OUR
WITNESS TESTIMONY OPTIONS YOU
CAN ALSO CALL THE COMMITTEE ACT
AND I REPEAT THIS NUMBER TWICE.
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
SIX THREE SEVEN. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
OUR WITNESS TESTIMONY OPTIONS
YOU CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE
NUMBER AT. NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO SIX THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WILL
FACE. I THANK YOU. AND I WANT
TO BEGIN OPENING REMARKS ON AND
MAKE SOME BRIEF REMARKS AND
THEN HANDED OFF TO MISTER
DONALD AND IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
SOME REMARKS- ALL CALL UPON YOU
AS A BECAUSE ROLL. UP THE
LIFTER MIKE IF I CAN'T HEAR MY
KILLA REYES HANDS OKAY. AND
BEFORE I DO THAT I WANT TO READ
SOME COMMENTS- THAT MISS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE MISTER
MURATSUCHI HAS SENT TO ME. VERY
BRIEF AND IN HIS ABSENCE I LIKE
THE CAN ECHO WHAT HE WAS
WEARING CITING THEM YESTERDAY
AND HE ASKED THAT I HAVE TO THE
SAME THING BACK. THAT AS A
LEGISLATORS EXPLORING A SEVERAL
MESSAGE SEVERAL MEASURES- I TO
EXPLORE FUNDING TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE INCLUDING- A
POTENTIAL BROADBAND GENERAL
BOND. OBLIGATION BOND AS HE IS
PROPOSING- ALONG WITH OURSELVES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR THE
INPUT MISTER MURATSUCHI AND
I'LL CONTINUE. I THANK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO IS
WHO IS- HERE WITH US TODAY OR
IS LISTENING TO US- VIDEO
CONFERENCING. THIS ISSUE THIS
ISSUE IS ONE OF MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING. TODAY
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT DIGITAL DIVIDES
ABOUT TECHNOLOGY AND THE
ABILITY TO EDUCATE OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE I SAY THIS UP TO KIDS. A
FOUR YEAR OLD AND A SEVEN YEAR
OLD AND WHILE WE ARE. WHILE WE
ARE BLESSED ENOUGH TO HAVE.
INTERNET CONNECTION AND THE
TECHNOLOGICAL SUPPORT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S STILL
SOME LIMITATIONS WHEN YOU PUT
ONE OR TWO KIDS ON THERE AND
WHEN YOU DO GET WHEN YOU DO
ZOOM CALLS. EDUCATE ONE GETS
KNOCKED OFF WITH THE GETS
KNOCKED OFF AND- WHILE
EXPLORING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
AND THE TECHNOLOGICAL ISSUES
THAT ARISE THERE'S ALSO THAT
ISSUE- OF INSTRUCTIONAL OF
INSTRUCTION AND HOW A KID
LEARNS. AND WHAT THEY RETAIN
AND HOW TO TEST SO IT'S KIND OF
A MULTIPLICITY OF PROBLEMS. AND
EVEN EVEN TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT QUIET SPACE FOR A KID
TO LEARN IN A COMPUTER DOESN'T
BECOMING UP BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE HEADSETS. IT'S A NUMBER
IT'S A NUMBER OF ISSUES HAVE
BECOME VERY VERY DIFFICULT
TOUGH. TO NAVIGATE. AND THEN
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT INCOME
CALL INCOME INEQUALITY ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT DISTRICTS I
REPRESENT- LIKE THE ONES
REPRESENT WHO I KNOW MANY OF
YOU REPRESENT COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE THE LIKE- THEY'RE SERIOUS.
INCOME INEQUALITY ISSUES THAT
WERE THAT THAT HAVE BEEN.
EXACERBATED DURING COLDER THE
ATTAINMENT LEVEL THE ABILITY TO
EDUCATE KIDS AND GENERATIONS OF
THE POTENTIALLY BIT LEFT BEHIND
OTHER RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE
BEAR NOW. I SAY THIS BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T TAKE A REPORT AND TAKE A
STUDY DIDN'T TAKE A NEWS
ARTICLE- TO TELL US WHAT WE
HEAR EVERY SINGLE DAY WHEN
WE'RE WALKING AROUND OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE WILL RIDE AT
FOOD BANKS. IF YOU WERE POOR IN
THE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HIT.
YOU ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE IT
ANOTHER TO PANDEMICS HIT. ALL
THE WORSE SCENARIOS OF CAVED IN
PEOPLE. WHO ARE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING BEFORE. AND WHILE
WE'RE DOING OUR VERY BEST I
THINK IT'S TAKE IT AT LEAST FOR
ME IT'S IMPORTANT KNOWLEDGE-
THAT EVERYTHING IS NOT ROSY.
EVERYTHING'S NOT PERFECT BUT
THERE ARE SERIOUS PROBLEMS-
THERE ARE SERIOUS PROBLEMS IN
OUR IT IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
AND IN THE DISTANCE LEARNING.
AND WE'VE GOT TO BEGIN TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE PRESENT PROBLEMS
IMMEDIATELY AND BEGIN TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE DO- ONCE RATHER
THIS PANDEMIC SOME PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT GO BACK TO THE NORM. BUT
THE BUT THE THAN THE NORMAL IS
NOT WORKING FOR PEOPLE. AND
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE POOR AN
INCREASE IN INCOME INEQUALITY
HIT YOU THE HARDEST. THE TICKET
IS PANDEMIC AN ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ARE STILL GOING OUT TO
WORK. NOT UNIQUE TO MY DISTRICT.
IT'S SURPRISING TO SOME THAT
FOLKS WILL HAVE TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMES TO GO TO WORK AND THAT
THE BUSES ARE STILL BEING USED
AT THE METRO STILL BEING USED
BECAUSE OF YOUR POOREST
CHILDREN YOU DIDN'T HAVE A CAR
BEFORE YOU CAN GET A CAR DURING
THE PANDEMIC. A STRUGGLE BEFORE
YOU STILL HAVE TO STRUGGLE YOU
STILL HAVE TO WORK. SO I THINK.
THOSE WHO HAVE COME HERE TODAY
I TELL TO ENGAGE ON THIS VERY
NARAL- THE SENATE NARAL ISSUE
BUT INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AS IT RELATES TO EDUCATE OUR
KIDS EDUCATING OUR KIDS- AND
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE NO ONE HAND
OFF THE MISTER O'DONNELL WILL
TAKE IT BACK AND THEN- ALLOW
MEMBERS IF THEY CHOOSE TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
SANTIAGO AND THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE LEAD ON THIS HEARING
IN CALLING ME UP AND SAY HEY
COULD WE- WE HAVE A JOINT
HEARING ON THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. WE'RE HERE
TODAY WITH A NARROW FOCUS. TO
EXAMINE STUDENTS ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET. IN THIS NEW ERA OF
DISTANCE LEARNING. NOT
NECESSARILY TO DISCUSS THE
EFFICACY OF DISTANCE LEARNING
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S LIMITED. I
HAVE TWO KIDS I'M A TEACHER.
DISTANCE LEARNING IS NOT. IN
CLASSROOM LEARNING I THINK WE
ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE WANT
OUR KIDS BACK IN THE CLASSROOM
BUT TO I THINK THAT THIS MAY
ALTER THE WAY KIDS LEARN GOING
FORWARD TO SOME EXTENT TO WHERE
THEY WILL DO DISTANCE LEARNING
AND IN CLASSROOM LEARNING
MEANING. YOU KNOW POST
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE WILL BE
MORE LEARNING TAKING PLACE ON
ON THE COMPUTER AFTER THE
STANDARD SCHOOL THEY IN THE
FUTURE. AND I REPRESENT A
DISTRICT THAT'S VERY URBAN IN
NATURE BUT ALSO A VERY RURAL
HAVE CATALINA ISLAND THEY HAVE
UNLIMITED INTERNET ACCESS ON
CATALINA ISLAND. THERE'S KIDS
THAT LIVE ON CATALINA. GIVES
THE NEED TO LEARN AND- SO THIS
IS VERY IMPACTFUL TO MY
DISTRICT AND I HOPE OUR HEARING
TODAY WILL FOCUS ON SOLUTIONS
NOT JUST RE IDENTIFYING THE
PROBLEM. ARE RE EXPLAINING THE
PROBLEM IS I THINK WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE. THERE IS A PROBLEM
AND IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
ACCORDING NUMEROUS PUBLICATIONS
INCLUDING EDUCATION WEEK REMOTE
LEARNING CONTINUES TO BE OUT OF
REACH FOR MILLIONS OF STUDENTS
NATIONWIDE. WHO LACK A RELIABLE
INTERNET CONNECTION AT HOME
THUS THE TOPIC TODAY. TODAY WE
WILL HEAR ABOUT MEASURES
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND AGENCIES
HAVE TAKEN TO ENSURE RELIABLE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET WE ALSO
HEAR FROM TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS ON THE GROUND
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES FACED TO
DISTANCE LEARNING. WHEN ACCESS
IS LIMITED OR NON EXISTENT AS
WE NEED TO REMEMBER. THAT SOME
KIDS MIGHT LIVE IN AN AREA-WHERE THERE IS ACCESS OR
POTENTIAL ACCESS SOME KIDS
LIVING AREA WHERE THEY CANNOT
EVEN ACCESS THE INTERNET. FINE
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER COMMUNITY AND
A COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
MAKING STRIDES TO EXPAND ACCESS
FOR THE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
WITH THE GREATEST NEED. DUE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
MOST LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
ARE PROVIDING INSTRUCTION
THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING OR
HYBRID MODEL WAS STUDENTS
ATTENDING SUNDAY'S IN PERSON
AND OTHER DAYS DISTANCE
LEARNING OR JUST STROLLING.
DISTANCE LEARNING IN THE CASE
OF MY OWN HOME SITUATION. AND
AGAIN YOU KNOW I DO NEED TO
APPLAUD THAT A LOT OF SCHOOLS
WILL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE RESPONDED HANDLING OF
THIS CRISIS THEY DIDN'T EVEN
HAVE ENOUGH LAPTOPS. I CAN TELL
YOU I. WENT BY ONE OF MY HIGH
SCHOOL SERVICE TWELVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN LINE TO GET. TO GET
TO GET A COMPUTER LA UNIFIED'S
THE DONE A GREAT JOB WITH THE
TOOLS THAT THEY HAD TO SERVE
THEIR STUDENTS EVERYBODY'S
TRYING IT'S JUST NOT ENOUGH.
THUS AGAIN THE TOPIC OF TODAY'S
CONVERSATION. SB NINETY EIGHT
THE EDUCATION TRAILER BILL OF
THE SESSION PROVIDED
DEFINITIONS AND GUARDRAILS FOR
OUR NEW NORMAL DISTANCE
LEARNING. LOCAL AGENT EDUCATION
AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE DISTANCE
LEARNING. ARE REQUIRED TO
CONFIRM OR PROVIDE ACCESS FOR
CONNECTIVITY. AND DEVICES
ADEQUATE. TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM AND
COMPLETE ASSIGNED WORK.
ENSURING ACCESS TO DISTANCE
LEARNING THROUGH INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY. IS MORE THAN A
REQUIREMENT IT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. BUT THE SOLUTIONS
TO CONNECTIVITY ARE NOT ALWAYS
SIMPLE OR STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THERE ARE MANY ISSUES TO
GRAPPLE WITH BUT FUNDAMENTALLY
OUR QUESTION TODAY IS HOW CAN
WE WORK THROUGH THE BARRIER
STERN INTERNET CONNECTIVITY. IN
ORDER FOR SCHOOLS TO SET UP OUR
STUDENTS. FOR SUCCESS IN A
DISTANCE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
WHICH AGAIN WE ACKNOWLEDGE. IS
NOT THE PERFECT ENVIRONMENT TO
LEARN. THERE'LL BE MANY
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS TODAY I
LOOK FORWARD TO. TO HEARING
THEM I KNOW THE LAST YEAR THERE
WERE TWO KEY BILLS. SENATOR
GONZALEZ HAD ONE- IT'S SPOKE
MOSTLY TO SPEED I THINK THERE
ORIGINALLY WAS MONEY IN IT. BUT
THEN WAS PULLED OUT FOR SOME
REASON SIMILAR AGAR CURRY HAD
ANOTHER BILL THAT SPOKE TO
MONEY AND ACCESS. AND IN ONE
NIGHT. FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT MONEY HAS TO BE
AN ONGOING SOURCE. EVEN UPON
QUITE FRANKLY IS REALLY A YOU
KNOW FOR ONE TIME EXPENDITURES
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS. BUT WE
NEED TO IDENTIFY AN ONGOING
SOURCE TO SUPPORT CONNECTIVITY
ACROSS OUR STATE SUPPORTER
STUDENTS AND ULTIMATELY OUR
ECONOMY THIS MAN IS COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE CONNECTIVITY AT
ALL. IT'S NOT GOING TO MUCH
ISSUE AS MUCH AS IT IS AN
EDUCATIONAL ISSUE WITH THAT
I'LL TURN IT BACK TO YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU. I'LL JUST ASK
MONEY OUT FIRST OF FIRST PERSON
REQUESTED I'LL DO IT THAT WAY
RIGHT TO. THE FIRST ONE I SAW
WAS MISSING MISTER SMITH PLEASE.
HERE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M
THANK YOU TO BOTH CHAIRMAN
TODAY AS WELL AS YOUR STAFF FOR
BRINGING THIS DATA TOGETHER FOR
THIS BRIEFING AT HIGHER I
COULDN'T BE MORE PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY THIS IS LITERALLY
THE WORK THAT LAUNCHED MY
CAREER IN PUBLIC POLICY AND MY
OWN CHILDREN SCHOOL DISTRICT
TWELVE YEARS AGO WE REALIZED WE
HAD A SIGNIFICANT FUNDING GAP
NOT ONLY IN THE ACCESS BUT
SIMPLY THE HARDWARE IN ORDER TO
INVEST TO MAKE OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT IT NEEDED JUST TO MEET
STATE STANDARDS AT THE TIME AND
THAT WAS FIBER OPTICS FROM THE
STREET INTO THE CLASSROOM. THAT
WAS ENOUGH EQUIPMENT FOR EVERY
CHILD TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
ACCESS DURING THEIR SCHOOL DAY
AND DURING THEIR SCHOOL WEEK
AND AS WE HAVE FOUND SADLY
DURING THIS CRISIS THAT THOSE
FRACTURES IN THE HAVES AND THE
HAVE NOTS IN OUR SYSTEM HAVE
BEEN LAID STARKLY BARE AND AS
E GO THROUGH THIS- TO GERMINAL
DONALD'S POINT WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT THERE WERE DISTRICTS
ALREADY IN THIS STATE THAT
DIDN'T HAVE EVEN ACCESS PERIOD
TO THE INTERNET WE STILL HAD
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE WITH NO INTERNET
ACCESS LET ALONE THOSE STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES HAVING ACCESS. IN
THEIR HOMES SO THE URGENCY
GIVEN THE MOMENT OF THE CODE
CRISIS IS VERY REAL BUT I HOPE
THAT AS WE ARE PROBLEM SOLVING
HERE WE THINK VERY EXTENSIVELY
VERY EXPANSIVELY AND LOOK TO
THE REAL NEED FOR ON GOING
FUNDING FOR TECHNOLOGICAL
INVESTMENT FOR ALL OF OUR KIDS
AND OUR SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
THIS CAN'T BE A ONE TIME ONE
AND DONE THOUGHT PROCESS IT IS
NOW INTEGRAL TO EVERYTHING THAT
OUR STUDENTS NEED TO THEIR
DAILY LEARNING AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING THE
COMMITMENT FINANCIALLY TO
ENSURE THAT THIS HAPPENS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. THEY JUST
SIMPLIFY RATHER THAN TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHO PUT IT THERE
MIKE'S FIRST GIVE IF I GO THIS
WAY. SECRETARY FIFTH
UNDERSTANDING THIS ONE WITH. A
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS WELL AS
A ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
FRINGE THEN YOU JOIN TODAY. TO
DISCUSS ONE. IF NOT THE MOST
RELEVANT ISSUES CALIFORNIANS
ARE FACING TODAY. ACROSS OUR
STATE ESPECIALLY THROUGHOUT
RURAL CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN
THE WORKING FAMILIES STILL
REMAIN WITHOUT ACCESS TO
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY AT
SPEEDS. ABLE TO FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING CONNECTOR WORKFORCE TO
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT HARNESS THE
LIFESAVING TECHNOLOGY OF
TELEMEDICINE. ENABLE FOR
PRECISION AGRICULTURE AND
SUSTAIN ECONOMIC TRANSITIONS IN
TIMES OF EMERGENCIES. WE HAVE
ALL SEEN FIRST HAND HOW
CRITICAL CONNECTIVITY KATE
CAPACITY IS THE TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES. INCLUDING DURING
THE STATE'S RECENT DEVASTATING
FIRES. XCELERATED AN ONGOING
NEED FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
CONNECT OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES CANNOT BE IGNORED. SO
AS WE KNOW THIS PAST SESSION
OFFERED SB FIVE SEVENTY THAT
WOULD HAVE PROVIDED THE
NECESSARY FUNDING FOR
DEPLOYMENT ABROAD GRANT
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED RURAL
AND URBAN AREAS AND AS MANY OF
YOU REMEMBER THE PRESSING NEED
FOR PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING IS NOT NEW TO ME.
REMEMBER I AUTHORED A CA ONE
THAT WOULD HAVE HELPED SECURE
FUNDING FOR BROADBAND EXPANSION
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS. BOTH
SENATOR LE GONZALEZ ALINA
GONZALEZ WHO AUTHORED IF YOU
WANT THE ELEVEN THIRTY AND I
AGREE. THAT WE MUST PROVIDE
INTERNET SPEEDS TO ACCOMMODATE
NEEDS FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
TELEHEALTH SUCCESSFUL
OPERATIONS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
INTO THE FUTURE. AND AT THE END
OF THE SESSION THE SENATOR AND
MINISTRATION CAME AROUND ON THE
CRITICAL NEED TO SECURE FUNDING
AS PART OF A BILL PACKAGE SO
THAT HIGH PROPERTY UNDERSERVED
UNSERVED COMMUNITIES ARE FIRST
IN LINE TO THE RESOURCES VITAL
TO STAY SAFE. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND RECOVER FROM THE
ECONOMIC RECESSION. I ALSO. THE
SUPPORT FOR MISTER SPEAKER ON
OUR BROADBAND EFFORTS THIS YEAR
AND I AM HOPEFUL THAT MY
COLLEAGUES LEADERSHIP IN BOTH
HOUSES. AND THE ADMINISTRATION
CAN JOIN ME IN RESOLVING ANY
REMAINING DIFFERENCES THAT WE
MAY. THAT WE CAN PASS
LEGISLATION FAST IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE NEXT SESSION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE OUR
COLLABORATION WITH ALL MEMBERS
INTERESTED IN BEING A PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION SO WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER AND GET SOMETHING
DONE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I WANT TO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES BUT I WANT
TO KIND OF PAINT THE PICTURE
AND BACK UP FOR A MOMENT. AND
THAT WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IS.
OVER A DECADE AGO TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO SOME SCHOOL STARTED
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS STARTED
INVESTING. AND NOT ONLY
INTERNET BUT DEVICES IPADS SO
FOR. IT WAS VERY CLEAR TO ME AS
A CLASSROOM TEACHER EVEN WITHIN
A DISTRICT. THAT WAS INVESTING
THERE ARE THERE WERE
INEQUITIES. MEANING THAT SOME
KIDS NOT ONLY HAD ACCESS TO
IPADS- ALL TYPES OF DEVICES IN
THE CLASSROOM BUT ALSO AT HOME.
IF YOU JUMP AHEAD NOW TO WHERE
WE ARE THAT STILL EXISTS SO
THIS HAS JUST MADE IT VERY
CLEAR WHAT WE CAN ALREADY SEE
WHICH DEPENDING ON THE DISTRICT
YOU WERE SENDING YOUR CHILD TO
OR THE SCHOOL. THAT YOUR CHILD
ATTENDED A COULD BE THE SAME A
SCHOOL WITHIN A DISTRICT YOU
COULD HAVE VERY DIFFERENT.
EXPERIENCES WITH NOT ONLY-
USING COMPUTERS UP BEING TRAIN
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS WERE
GIVING ACCESS TO A FOUR YEAR
OLD PRE K. NOT ONLY ON
KEYBOARDING BUT ALL THE
EXPERIENCES- THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE YOUR CHILD. AND
THEN A VERY SUCCINCT PROGRAM
FROM KINDERGARTEN ALL THE WAY
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE OTHERS
AHEAD NO DEVICES IN HIGH SCHOOL
MAYBE A FEW OF THE COURSES OR
EXPERIENCES. BUT WE SAW THE
INEQUITIES WITH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA-
BASICALLY OVER THE LAST DECADE
SO NOW AS WE SEE OUR CRISIS
THAT GOES EVEN DEEPER AND WE
SEE- IT ISN'T EVEN IF A CHILD
HAS A DEVICE OR A FAMILY
HOUSING HOT SPOT. IT ISN'T EVEN
IF THERE'S TWO OR THREE DEVICES
WHAT'S EVEN DEEPER THAN THAT IS
WHAT KIND OF EXPERIENCE ARE
THESE CHILDREN ARE FAMILIES.
HAVING AT HOME SOME FAMILIES
HAVE A PARENT THAT IS HOME THAT
CAN KIND OF INTERFACE WITH THE
LEARNING WELL THEY'RE DOING
THEIR OWN JOB. SOME OF FAMILIES
I HAVE NO ONE AT HOME MAYBE AN
OLDER BROTHER OR SISTER- THAT
IS TRYING TO DO THEIR OWN WORK.
ALONG WITH ALSO HELPING YOUNGER
SIBLINGS AND THEN AS WE SEEN
THE PICTURE THAT WENT VIRAL OF
THE TWO YOUNG GIRLS WHO WERE
SITTING OUTSIDE. TACO BELL
TRYING TO CONNECT SO THESE ARE
SERIOUS ISSUES THEIR ISSUES
ABOUT EQUITY THEIR ISSUES ABOUT
INVESTMENT AND THEIR ISSUES ARE
REALLY ABOUT THE FUTURE OF OUR
NATION- SO I'M PROUD TO BE HERE
AND I'M GONNA BE LISTENING
CAREFUL. LEE FOR DETAILS ON NOT
JUST ABOUT DO THEY HAVE A
DEVICE. BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THAT DEVICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRED THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND ALL
THE COMMENTS BEING MADE BY OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY CLEARLY.
I THINK THAT'S BEEN SAID DO WE
DISAGREE WITH I JUST WANTED TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMUNICATIONS OF
CONVEYANCE AND I. BEEN
FACILITATING WITH SOME OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS AS A FOLLOW UP TO
LAST YEAR'S LEGISLATIVE.
ATTEMPTS TO MOVE. THIS
CONVERSATION FORWARD- THE GOAL
OUGHT TO BE THAT. WE BEGIN. ARE
THESE TYPE OF STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS- NOW- WITH- YOU KNOW
THE INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
THE- SCHOOL DISTRICTS-
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. AND
THE MANY OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
BE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE- IN
JANUARY THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
LEAD TO THE ON GOING FUNDING.
AND CLEARLY THE POLICY- REFORMS
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO ALTER THE
MEET THE OBJECTIVES- THAT WILL
BE DISCUSSING TODAY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH
EVERYONE HERE ON THESE MATTERS
AND- AND LASTLY YOU KNOW- I'M
GLAD THAT- MISTER MATTEUCCI-
WAS ABLE TO SUBMIT HIS NOTES
CLEARLY HE'S TAKING AS A- FLAG
IN THE GROUND THAT YOU'LL BE
WORKING ON THE BOND AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING. ON THAT
MATTER AS WELL THAT ONE TIME
FUNDING COULD BE VERY THE
CENTRAL. TO HELPING US CLOSE
THE GAP IN MANY PARTS OF A
RURAL CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
URBAN. AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE ISSUE OF SPEED.
INTERNET SPEEDS- ARE MUCH
NEEDED WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICES- BUSINESS-
DEVELOPMENT I TELL HEALTH
SERVICES AND ALSO THE ISSUE OF
EDUCATION THAT MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE FACING TODAY SO-
WIDE RANGE OF NEED. LOOKING
FORWARD TO REALLY TAKING A
LEADERSHIP ROLE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE- AND THE
DISCUSSION TODAY WILL HEAR SOME
THINGS THAT WE- ARE PROBABLY
KNOW ABOUT ALREADY. BUT WE'LL
HOPEFULLY- BEGIN. GUIDING WHAT
THE POLICY WILL LOCAL MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP MISTER CHAIR OF YOU.
AND I LOOK TO WORKING ON THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU CAN. VISIT
MISTER KILEY AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING PATIENT FOR ME INSTEAD OF
JUST GOING THIS WAY RATHER TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHO PUT UP THEIR
MIKE FIRST. NUMBER GIVE YOU IN
TIME MISTER CHAIR. I WANNA SAY
I FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR.
CONVENING THIS- THIS YEAR. YOU
KNOW AS A VICE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
I'M GRATEFUL TO FINALLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS IN A
PUBLIC FORUM. THESE ISSUES THAT
ARE. IMPACTING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES RIGHT NOW
ALSO EXPRESSED MY AGREEMENT
WITH TWO THINGS MR O'DONNELL
SAID DOESN'T HAPPEN ALL THAT
OFTEN SO CELEBRATE OR CAN.
NUMBER ONE HIS EMPHASIS ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF RETURNING THE IN
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION AND
NUMBER TWO. HIS POINT THAT. THE
TOOLS OF DISTANCE LEARNING CAN
BE VALUABLE NOT ONLY IN
REPLACING IN CLASSROOM LEARNING
BUT ALSO IN COMPLEMENTING AND
SUPPLEMENTING IT WE'VE SEEN
EVEN BEFORE COVERED NINETEEN
MODELS OF BLENDED LEARNING THAT
HAVE PROVEN VERY EFFECTIVE AND
SO THE WORK THAT IS BEING DONE
TO ASSURE UNIVERSAL ACCESS. AND
TO IMPROVE THE TOOLS OF
DISTANCE LEARNING TO FROM PROVE
OUR COLLECTIVE CAPACITY IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO PAY DIVIDENDS. IN
THE LONG TERM. AND ALSO THE
WORK THAT IS BEING DONE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR ABOUT TODAY
BASED UPON THE MATERIALS IS
GENUINELY GOOD WORK. THAT IS
HELPING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
INEQUITIES- THE SITUATION IS
CREATED BUT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. THAT IT IS THE ONLY
SMOOTHING OUT THE EDGES OF THE
OUTER EDGES OF THE PROBLEM. AND
THAT A SCHOOL SHUTDOWN IS
INHERENTLY INEQUITABLE IT
INHERENTLY WHY DIDN'T THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT EXIST IN
OUR- PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AND IT'S DOING ENORMOUS HARM TO
ALL CALIFORNIA KIDS AND ALL
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. THE
EVIDENCE IS PELLUCIDA THE
CLEAR. BEYOND ANY REASONABLE
DEBATE. THE HARMS BEING DONE BY
KEEPING KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL FAR
EXCEED THE RISKS OF CONTRACTING
THIS VIRUS. MOREOVER DOCTOR
GALLEY RECENTLY SAID THAT THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE OF ANY LINK
BETWEEN INCREASED TRANSMISSION
AND SCHOOL RE OPENINGS WHERE
THEY HAVE OCCURRED. AND THAT IS
WHAT THE EVIDENCE HAS SHOWN ALL
ALONG AS WELL. THE STATE SHOULD
BE DOING EVERYTHING IT CAN. TO
GET EVERY SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA
BACK OPEN AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE BUT INSTEAD WE'RE
SEEING QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
WE'RE SEEING THE STATE AID IN
THE BED THOSE WOULD USE SCHOOL
CLOSURES FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES
WE'RE SEEING NEW REASONS
INVENTED. TO KEEP SCHOOLS
CLOSED. JUST YESTERDAY A LETTER
FROM THREE UNION SAID THAT EVEN
SCHOOLS THAT CAN SAFELY REOPEN
SHOULD NOT. BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT ANYONE TO GET A HEAD START.
THAT IS A MONSTROUS SENTIMENT
AND IT'S DOING INCALCULABLE
HARM. TO MILLIONS OF KIDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED TO GET
OUR SCHOOLS OPEN FOR FULL IN
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION. WITHOUT
ANY FURTHER DELAY. THANK YOU MR
COLOR NOT SURE IF MISTER
O'DONNELL LAMENTS OR OR
CELEBRATE. HAVING FAME
VIEWPOINT ENTRY CAN APPRECIATE
THAT WE WANT FROM LEFT TO RIGHT.
THANK YOU HAVING SAID THAT IS
THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS WHO
WANT TO MAKE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. IF NOT I'M GONNA HAND
OVER MISTER DONALD OTHER TO
POINT OUT ONE THING MS CARTEL
THAT THAT THAT PICTURE OF THE
TWO KIDS OUTSIDE OF TACO BELL.
IF IT'S THE SAME WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- ONE OF THOSE
WELL IT WAS FILMED IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. SO IT'S BEEN A
ONE OF THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES
THERE. THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO
OUR FIRST PANEL. AGAIN OUR
FIRST PANEL. AND I JUST
REMINDER WE WILL HOLD OUR
QUESTIONS TO THE END OF THE
PANEL TO THE END OF THE PANEL.
OUR FIRST PANEL- WILL FOCUS ON-
AND PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
DISTANCE LEARNING AND THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE.A REMINDER
AGAIN THAT WE HOLDING QUESTIONS
TO THE AND OUR FIRST SPEAKERS
AT EDGAR CABRAL FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE MR
ROMERO IS JOINING US FROM A
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM. AT THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE- ARE YOU-
WHEN YOU'RE READY MISTER
MORALITY MAYES PROCEED. GREAT
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER THE MEMBERS- AFTER THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S TO. THEM
I WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
BROADBAND INTERNET ACCESS AND
ADOPTION- TO CONFIRM SOME OF
THE CONVERSATIONS- REGARDING
THE FACT THAT THE DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND I'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE FEW THINGS
THAT WE DO KNOW ABOUT. ISSUES
RELATED TO MORE SPECIFICALLY
STUDENT CONNECTIVITY- WE DID
HAVE A HAND OUT THAT ALL USE A
VERY VERY KIND OF IT REALLY
WASN'T. IF I COULD. WITH BUT
ALL BUT I'LL BE WHAT THROUGH SO
GOD WANTED TO SPLIT UP THE
COVERS THE ENDING MANY OF THE
MEMBERS OUR TO TALK ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT ISSUES WHY IS.
WHETHER THERE'S A PHYSICAL IN.
BUT FOR A PROPERTY INTERNET
ACCESS AND IN FACT WHETHER OR
NOT A BEING A IN THE HOUSE. ON
TOPICS WE FOR TALK ABOUT.
ACTORS WERE AVAILABILITY CAL.
I'M IN SEASON THREE WITH THAT
THE TABLE HAVE HERE STATEWIDE
97% OF CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS
HOW BROADBAND OF THE TO THE
THAT'S THE- I THINK MEGABIT PER
SUCH DOWNLOADS. I THE SENATOR
THE STATE OF QATAR CORRECT CAL
PROBABLY COMMISSION USES AND WE
DO HAVE SOME INFORMATION ON A
HIGHER SPEED THERE YOU CAN SEE
IN TERMS STATEWIDE ACCESS IT
DOESN'T CHANGE MUCH WOULD BE.
97% VERSUS NINETY SIX PERCENT-
ACTOR- YOU COULD SEE IN URBAN
AREAS THAT THE- LOCAL PHARMACY
WHATEVER IT NINETY EIGHT. POINT
1% ACCESS- I'M USING THAT SIX
MEGABITS PER SECOND STANDARD
NINETY SEVEN POINT NINE- IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A HIGHER
STANDARD. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
I THINK WE BOTH THE NUMBERS
HERE BECAUSE THIS IS AN AREA
THAT IS INVOLVING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE WITHIN THE- OR
ARE GIVEN THE TWO YEARS. A THE
HIGH TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS PER
SECOND STANDARD AND- AND SO
THAT THEY ARE DIFFERENT IN KIND
OF A WE SEE FROM NUMBERS FOR
AREA CAL THAT WHETHER OR NOT
YOU USE ONE. BRING FROM THE
MATTER BUT THE ROLE IN THAT
DOES CHANGE ARE SOME THEM HOW
MANY HEALTHY TO GO BACK SO IF
YOU'RE LOOKING THE LOWER EAST.
WE'LL BE DOING SECRETIVE
CONSTRUCTION- YOU KNOW ON A
VIDEO CONFERENCING AND MAYBE
HAVING SOME WEBSITES OPEN TO
LOOK UP INFORMATION. BUT IF
YOU'RE STARTING TO TALK ABOUT
THE TWO OR THREE. ACTIVISM
HOUSEHOLD TRYING TO ACCESS THIS
IS RUNNING AN ADULT WORKING
FROM HOME THAT IS NO LONGER
ENOUGH AND NOW YOU'RE YOU NEED
SOMETHING MORE LIKE THE TWENTY
FIVE MEGABITS PER SECOND
FOUNDER ABOUT. ONE THING WE
POINT OUT TO IT- ALTHOUGH THE
ACCESS. OR GROUP AVAILABILITY
IS A BIGGER ISSUE CAN IN ON THE
WEB. IN RURAL AREAS IF YOU JUST
GET TOLD. THAT ARE UNCERTAIN
CAL DAMAGE OF THE ARE ACTUALLY
URBAN AREAS AND- I MENTIONED IS
NOT TO SAY THAT. WE SHOULD BUT
THERE ARE. ISSUES IN OUR AREA
FOR MORE PRODUCTIVE FOR MEMBERS
WHO ARE IN PLACES THAT ARE
PRIMARILY URBAN. YOU MIGHT
STILL HAVE TO. BUMP OF. THAT DO
NOT ACCESS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE. MOVIES
ARE ON. CHU RIVER CEMENT ON NOW.
WHAT WAS THE CALL PRODUCT. AND
SO THIS IS HOW. THAT HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE. BETA A
WIRED CONNECTION OF THE CLASS
WIRED INTERNET AND THEN AROUND.
SIX TO. SO BASED ON THE C. P.
U. BIG BIG. GAP ANALYSIS. BY
YEAH THE RIGHT NUMBER OF THE
PERSON OF HEALTH. 80% OF THE
WHO. CRITICS TO CHOOSE TO DO.
THAT THAT NUMBER. DOES VERY.
ACROSS THE STATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR ALSO PUT THE- UC. THAT
AT A NUMBER OF THEM A- THAT. TO
GET A SENSE OF. WHAT WERE THE
MAIN DRIVERS OF ME FACTORS THE
RESEARCH. WITH HIGHER OR LOWER.
ADOPTION RATES AROUND INTERNET.
AND THE BONUS POINTS. ARE
PROBABLY TOO MANY OF THE
CORRELATION. IS STRONG WITHIN.
SO I IN IN SAN TRACTS WHERE
ABOUT THE AVERAGE ANNUAL INCOME
IS A- EIGHTY. DOLLARS YOU HAVE
IN ADOPTION RATE OF 86% WHEREAS
IN. TRY WHERE. EVERY JANUARY IS
TWENTY DOLLARS DOLLARS OR- YOU
HAVE ENOUGH TO READ UP. THREE
SO SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES
THERE IS TALKING. OR
HOUSEHOLDS- TRACKS WHERE- THERE
WERE. A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WERE LIMITED
ENGLISH SPEAKING WERE ALSO LESS
LIKELY TO THE FRONT AND THEN.
THE DEFINITION OF LIMITED
ENGLISH SPEAKING HERE IS IF
YOU'RE IN A HOUSEHOLD WHERE
NONE OF THE ADULTS WITH THE
THAT THEY SPEAK ENGLISH VERY
WELL. AND SO THEY GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF THAT THE DIFFERENCES
THERE YEAH THERE'S A- INCLUDE A
HIGHER RATE OF. FROM WHICH WERE
NOT ACTUALLY BASED ON THE
NUMBERS. THAT IT'S BECAUSE THEY
CHOSE NOT TO AND THAT MIGHT BE
SIGNIFICANTLY CUTS TO INCOME.
I'M ALSO. YOU KNOW. LOOKING AT
THESE AT THIS INFORMATION
COMPARING WITH OUR- KIDS OVER
THE CASE SYSTEM. COMING FROM UP
THE SPECIFIC THAT THE LAW
CONTENT FUNDING. IS TARGETING.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LEARNERS. BUT BASED ON THE GAP
AND ALL BILLS ALSO THE WHO ARE.
LIKELY TO LIVE IN OUR WHERE
THEY MIGHT HAVE BY INTERNET.
I'M ONE THING THAT WOULD HAVE
GREAT BUT THE GUNS AFTER THERE
WAS ANY OF. WE HAD ON. THEM
ACCESS IN TRIBAL INTER AREA. WE
COULD NOT WE DID NOT FIND
SPECIFIC OF MY ON ADULT RATES
IN IN REGION BUT WE DID. THAT
SOME FEDERAL INFORMATION SHOWS
THAT THIS TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS
PER SECOND. I TRY. TRIBAL AREAS
HOW TO A SIX EIGHT POINT
PERCENT OF THE- HAVE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND INTERNET SO THAT'S-
VERY IN LINE WITH THE ROLE
NUMBER STATEWIDE. FARM WHICH IN
SOME WAYS NOT SURPRISING GIVEN
THAT. MOST OR MANY ACTIONABLE.
AREAS ARE IN RURAL AREAS. SO
NEXT TIME ON PAGE THREE WE HAVE
A LITTLE INFORMATION. SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT GOING ON
FIRST TO AND SCHOOLS OF THE
STATE OF MIND HOW. A LOT OF
GOOD SPECIFIC DATA HERE. THE
DATA BECAUSE THE HAS COLLECTED
HISTORICALLY HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
ON ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AT
THE SCHOOL SITE- AND THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS IN PLACE-
TO EXPAND ACCESS- FOR EXAMPLE
IF YEARS AGO THERE WERE THESE
ARE INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS. QUICKLY TARGETED LOWER
AND ROTARIANS WERE THERE WAS
NO- NO GOOD ACCESS TO HIGH
SPEED INTERNET- IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S GOING ON AT OUR STUDENTS
IS HOW. IT STUDENTS IS A HOMES
WE HAVE NOT. HAD A LOT OF DATA
ON THAT A BIGGER BIT INCREASING
RECOGNITION THAT STUDENTS ARE
DOING HOMEWORK AT HOME AND THAT
BROADBAND INTERNET ACCESS TO BE
HELPFUL. BUT IT'S NOT IN THE
MOOD STATE OF COLLECTIVE. FARM
I KNOW THE SUPERINTENDENT WILL
SPEAK LATER AND- YOU CAN
PROBABLY TALK ABOUT- OKAY CAN
BE TALKED OUT ABOUT SOME OF THE-
THAT WERE. YES OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE GOING ON WE WHEN THE-
THIS. FARM WORDS PERCENT BUT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF A DICK.
INFORMATION AND SPRING OF TWO
TWENTY AND THAT INITIAL. FOR
THAT THERE WAS ABOUT A- EIGHT
HUNDRED BLOCK EDUCATION. THAT
DID PROVIDE SOME SURVEY
RESPONSES THE DEPARTMENT. AND
THEN IDENTIFIED A FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND MOBILE OFF. NEED FOR
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND MOBILE
HOTSPOT SO DON'T BE I. WONDERED
DEVICE THAT YOU COULD GIVE A
STUDENTS WHAT THEY COULD ACT TO
YOU KNOW. FROM HOME THAT
THERE'VE BEEN A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVE TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT INTEREST RIGHT WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THE MEETING BUT- BECAUSE
OF MY TALKING. BIT ABOUT THAT
LATER THE PIECE OF INFORMATION
THAT I CAN SHARE WITH YOU AND
THIS IS JUST OUR- HAVE A PARTY
FOR EXAMPLE. GOING ON. IS THERE
WAS A RAN CORPORATION A SURVEY
OF TEACHERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT THEIR
FIRST. WERE AND- IN THE SURVEY-
WHICH YOU GET NOTHING SURVEY
BUT THEY FOUND THAT. TEACHERS
WHO WERE IN FORTY. IN HIGH.
SCHOOLS ARE ONLY ONLY 30% OF
THOSE TEACHERS THOUGHT THAT ALL
OR NEARLY ALL OF THEIR STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING SO. OUR
SYSTEM TO PORTION OF TEACHERS
WHO THOUGHT THAT. ALL THE TO DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS. THERE COULD BE
A NUMBER OF OTHER REASONS WHY
THAT- THEY MIGHT NOT THAT
PERCEPTION MIGHT BE MIGHT NOT
BE DIRECTLY THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE INTERNET ACCESS BUT THEY
MIGHT BE SHARING A DEVICE. OR
MAYBE ACT THE ACCESS IS NOT
ENOUGH BUT THAT JUST GIVES YOU
A SENSE OF. MAGNITUDE OF THE.
PROBLEM IS WITH ON. SO I WAS.
THEIR BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
FURTHER. AFTER GO POWER. THANK
YOU WILLIAM ON TO A NEXT. AND I
WE MIGHT SEE. IN CONSUL WITH
THE- MISTER SONNY IF ARE IF CAN
SAFELY. SO SOCIAL DISTANCE OF
YOU CAN TAKE YOUR MASK OFF
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WILL HELP
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE
STATEMENTS YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR
TRYING TO CONVEY- AGAIN IF IT'S
IF IT'S IF YOU ARE IN A- SAVE
SITUATION TO DO THAT SO WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM- SUPERINTEND OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION MISTER TONY
THURMAN. WHO IS JOINING US BY
PHONE MISTER CHAIRMAN. GOOD
MORNING I THANK YOU A TERMINAL
DONNELL THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
SANTIAGO I THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND TO
ALL THOSE WHO ARE PRESENTED- I
WOULD ONLY UNDERSCORE THE
URGENCY OF THE REMARKS OF ALL
THE- LEGISLATORS WHO SPOKE IN
THIS MORNING. CLEARLY WE NEED
IN CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY HAVE
BROADBAND AND OUR STUDENTS NEED
TO HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET NOT JUST. DURING
DISTANCE LEARNING BUT WHEN IN
CLASS INSTRUCTION RESUMES OUR
STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THE FASTEST SPEEDS OF INTERNET
BECAUSE WE'RE PREPARING. THE
WORKFORCE OF TOMORROW AND THIS
IS WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE WHEN SCHOOL RESUMES
THIS YEAR. NO 7% OF OUR SCHOOLS
OPENED IN DISTANCE LEARNING AND
YOU KNOW I HAVE TO COMMEND. OUR
EDUCATORS AND STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES FOR WHAT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH REPLACING THE
UNTHINKABLE AND COBIT WITH
FIRES AND AIR QUALITY OF
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BURNED DOWN
BITTERLY LOST LOVED ONES IN
HOMES. WE SEE A CREDIBLE
CHALLENGES AROUND POLICE
BRUTALITY RACISM. AND BIAS IN
IN SO MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT IN
APRIL- I CONVENE A TASK FORCE
ON CLOSING. THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
I ASKED SENATOR LEYVA TO CHERRY
I'M GRATEFUL TO MANY OF YOU WHO
WHO SERVED ON IT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AGUILAR CURRY ALSO YOU
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BURKE AND WOOD- I APPRECIATE
YOU JOINING US. THE PANDEMIC
UNCOVERED- A DIRTY LITTLE
SECRET FOR CALIFORNIA AND FOR
MOST OF THE NATION. THAT WE
HAVE ALLOWED THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
GO ON FOR FAR TOO LONG DESPITE
OUR ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY INTO
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS- BY OUR
MANAGERS ARE INITIAL SURVEY
SHOWED. AND CONTINUE TO SHOW
THAT SOMEWHERE AROUND A MILLION
STUDENTS ARE WITHOUT RESOURCES
THAT THAT THEY NEED THAT CAN BE
A COMPUTING DEVICE THAT IN MANY
CASES THAT ACCESS. TO THE
INTERNET I WANT TO THANK ALL
WHO COME TOGETHER TO- PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND DONATIONS- IN THE
IN THE EARLY. PHASES OF
DISTANCE LEARNING TO HEAR FROM
DR LINDA DARLING HAMMOND OUR
STATE FOR PRESIDENT AS SHE AND
THE GOVERNOR AND THE FIRST
PARTNER MADE THE GOVERNOR'S
STAFF JOINED US AND OUR
PARTNERS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
FOUNDATION- BEEN LITERALLY.
REACHING OUT FOR DONATIONS FOR
COMPUTING DEVICES IN HOT SPOT
IN. IN THOSE EARLY DAYS WE SAW
A LOT OF PROGRESS WE SAW
SOMETHING LIKE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOT SPOTS IN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND COMPUTING DEVICES. NOT
MORE LESS THE CASE AGAIN- TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS BUT MORE
IS IT. AND IT WAS COOL.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS WERE ACCESS AND SO WE
USE THE TAP FOR LOCAL THE
DIGITAL. THIS THAT WE MUST MOVE
BEYOND JUST THE QUESTION. OF
GETTING TO DEAL WITH THE PAIN.
BUT THAT WE MUST MOVE TO A-
WHERE WE CAN THE TO ONE AND
FOR. AND THAT WE CAN BE THAT
INTERNET. HELLO LIKE
ELECTRICITY FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES IN THE
STATE WE IMMEDIATELY CALLED
UPON INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO COMPORT. WE ASKED THEM TO
PROVIDE INTERNET TO SOME OF OUR
NEEDIEST FAMILIES AND THEY DID.
WE TALKED TO THEM AND LET THEM
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
COMMITMENTS FROM THEM TO ENSURE
THAT ANY FAMILY COULD HAVE
ACCESS. TO LOW COST INTERNET IN
OUR INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT PROVIDED THAT IN MANY
CASES THAT ABOUT TEN DOLLARS A
MONTH. FOR MANY OF OUR FAMILIES
WE TOLD THEM THEY HAD TO
PROVIDE THIS ACCESS WITHOUT
BARRIERS WITHOUT HOOPS YOU
COULDN'T ASK FOR SOMEONE TO
CALL SECURITY NUMBER WERE
ASKING DEMOCRATIC. TO MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO THEM WITHOUT SOME
GIMMICK THAT SAID GET TURNED
OFF IN A MONTH OR TWO AFTER
IT'S BEEN TEN DOLLARS A MONTH
BUT THE PRICE WOULD RATCHET UP.
IN THIS IS BEEN HELPFUL BUT
IT'S NOT ENOUGH IN ON TOP OF
THAT WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AKEL PROVIDING UP FIVE POINT
TWO. MILLION DOLLARS IN-
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION FUNDS
TO HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO BE
ABLE TO GET COMPUTING DEVICES
OF. TO THE COURTS TO SUPPORT
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING NEEDS
AS WELL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS I BRING THIS UP
BECAUSE- IT ONE OF THE MANY
THINGS THAT IS OFTEN MESS IS
THAT. IN A PANDEMIC DEPRESSION
FOR OUR STUDENTS DOES NOT AND
THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN BE
CONNECTED TO COUNSELORS AND
HAVE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT.
IT IF THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPUTING DEVICE IN
CONNECTIVITY INTERNET FOR
WORKING WITH OUR CHARACTERS AND
I'VE NAMED ACCOUNTING. STAFF
FORCED TO STILL GET AT ONE OF
IT MAY CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP THEM WERE
THROUGH. IT CREATING
CONNECTIVITY SO THEY PROVIDE
HELLO. AND TELE HELP BUT TO OUR
YOUNG. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE CAN A NUMBER OF.
UTILITIES COME FOR TO MAKE.
DIRECT TO SERVE NEED CRISIS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO SERVE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED. BY FIRE IN WILDFIRE
AND DISASTERS- WE'VE SEEN
DONATIONS FROM PG&E AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON. BOB
TO HELP US IN THE COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS DONATIONS TO HELP.
YOU COUNTY WHERE THEY'RE
LITERALLY TRYING TO BUILD BACK
AFTER FIRES HAVE DAMAGED
SCHOOLS AND DESTROYED SO MUCH
IN THE COMMUNITY- WE WANT STUFF
A GO FUND ME PAGE. THAT ALLOWED
CALIFORNIANS AND OTHERS TO
DONATE TO HELP US PROVIDE
DEVICES IN HOT SPOT TO THOSE.
WHO NEED IT WHAT CLEAR BY MOST
ESTIMATES IS WHAT WE NEED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE BILL
BROADBAND BY MANY ESTIMATES A
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS- IS ONE
NUMBER THAT HAS BEEN KICKED
AROUND BUT WHAT WE NEED IS
INNOVATION. WE NEED TO GO
BEYOND THE WAY THINGS HAVE
BEEN. IN IN THOSE RESPECTS ARE
EXCITED TO BE MAKING SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS IN THE DAYS AND
WEEKS TO COME. ABOUT AN
INNOVATION COMPETITION- THAT WE
ARE WORKING ON TO ROLL OUT I
WANT TO THANK DR GARY MICHELSON
WHO WAS AN INNOVATOR AND
ENTREPRENEUR. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THE PROTESTS OUT TO
WORK WITHOUT TWENTY INNOVATION
COMPETITION. TO CREATE THE NEXT
GREAT SOLUTION IN ADDRESSING
THE LACK OF BROADBAND IN
ADDRESSING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
COULD BE SATELLITE THAT COULD
BE ANY OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT WE
HEARD TALK ABOUT. BUT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO LEAD THIS
NATION AND HOW WE CLOSE THE
BROADBAND GAP UNTIL YOU HEAR
MORE ABOUT OUR INNOVATION
COMPETITION. THANK YOU DR
MICHAEL SAID THE FOUNDATION.
FOR THE INVESTMENT THAT YOU'RE
MAKING AND FOR SAYING WITH
URGENCY THAT WE SHOULD ONCE AND
FOR ALL SO ALL. THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
AND WE SUBMIT. THAT THIS TIME
IN THE FORTY ANY QUESTIONS.
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SILVER AND THURMAN WE WILL NOW
HEAR FOR THE DA LINDA. HAMMOND
SHE PRESS. OF THE- STATE BOARD
OF ED. AND SHE IS JOINING VIA
VIDEO FROM PALO ALTO. DR LINDA
DARLING HAMMOND.
I SEE AN EMPTY
CHAIR. I SEE. HELLO THERE SHE
IS. HE LOOKS HAPPY RECEIVE AN
READY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M GLAD THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS WORKING. SURE
ENOUGH DONALD CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR INVITING EVEN PART OF
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING ON
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND HOW WE
FINALLY CLOSED FOR GOOD. TELL
ME TO TAKE ON AN ACCOMPLISHED.
AS EVERYONE HAS SAID RAPIDLY I
SUBMITTED A RISK WRITTEN
REMARKS THAT OFFERED MORE
DETAILS ABOUT WHAT I WILL
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE AND THESE
NEXT COUPLE OF MINUTES- A FEW
POINTS. WE'VE COME A LONG WAY
IN CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF
FIGURING OUT HOW TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY DISTANCE LEARNING
AND BEING READY TO DO SO-
ACCORDING TO ONE ESTIMATE AT
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC WE
WERE RANKED SECOND IN THE
NATURE. NATION FOR THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
LACKING ADEQUATE ACCESS AND
DEVICES AT HOME ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION STUDENTS ESTIMATED. TO
LACK HIGH SPEED INTERNET
CONNECTION. BUT 25% OF OUR
TOTAL AND JUST OVER A MILLION
MORE ESTIMATED SELECT DEVICES
WE ALSO HAD BUT 8% OF OUR
TEACHERS. BACK IN HIGH SPEED
CONNECTIONS. AND DEVICES
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS STILL LACK
ADEQUATE INTERNET FROM THE
SURVEYS THEY'VE BEEN
CONDUCTING. A WHICH IS A
MOUNTAIN TO CLIMB BUT A SMALLER
ONE THAT WE HAD JUST SIX MONTHS
AGO. AND ITS WORST RECENTLY
JUST THIS PAST MONTH ESTIMATED
THAT ABOUT 11% OF PARENTS SAID
UNRELIABLE INTERNET IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM. THERE ARE. STILL
SUPPLY CHAIN PROBLEMS IN
GETTING DEVICES TO STUDENTS-
EVEN WITH THE RECENT GENEROUS
OFFERING OF A MILLION IPADS
WITH FLYING CITING CONNECTIONS
ARE BUILT INTO THEM A LOT
GETTING THOSE TO THE SCHOOLS IS
GOING TO TAKE A FEW MONTHS AS
WE GET THROUGH THE SUPPLY CHAIN
BUT AT THIS POINT MOST OF THE
PROBLEM HAS TO DO WITH INTERNET
ACCESS COSTS AND AVAILABILITY-
MANY MANY OF ARTISTS INCLUDING
OUR LARGEST ONCE LOS ANGELES
SAN DIEGO LONG BEACH OTHERS
OPEN DOORS THIS FALL WITH A
100% OF THEIR STUDENTS ABLE TO
GET COMPUTERS DEVICES- AND HOT
SPOTS. BUT THERE ARE ISSUES OF
AFFORDABILITY AT TIMES- WHEN
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS
AND LIVELIHOOD SOMETIMES THEY
CAN'T EVEN AFFORD ELECTRICITY
WE HAVE A HOMELESSNESS THAT'S
GROWING WE HAVE LOW RATES
INTERNET OFFERS THAT WE'RE GOOD
FOR THIRTY OR SIXTY DAYS A
SUPERINTENDENT BERMAN NOTED
THAT BECAME UNAFFORDABLE AFTER
THAT PERIOD OF TIME WE HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH BANDWIDTH THAT'S
NOT ADEQUATE TO SUPPORT THE
TASKS ASSOCIATED WITH SCHOOL
WORK ONLINE AND INADEQUATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HIGH SPEED
INTERNET ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES- WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT THE MANY STORIES
THAT WERE. WIDESPREAD IN THE
SPRING OF ABOUT CHILDREN HAVING
A PROBLEMS WITH SHARING YOU
KNOW ONE HOT SPOT AMONG FIVE
SIBLINGS A LOW BAND OF PROBLEMS
EVEN TEACHERS AND PRINCIPALS
TRYING TO TEACH OUR FROM A HOT
SPOT ON THEIR CELL. PHONE AND I
STAYED IN LOCAL. HAVE A TRUST
MANY OF THESE PER. FOR ME STOOD.
OF THE STATE AS- BERMAN
ALLOCATED FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS THAN TWO AS
MUCH AS CAROUSEL REQUIRED TO GO
TO UP TO. PER IN HIGH NEED.
SURE THESE. THE BRIDGE AND THE
JUDGE TOLD FUND THERE WAS
MENTIONED HAS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DEVICES AND HOT
SPOTS TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE- THE STATE'S LARGEST
DISTRICTS AS I NOTED AND MANY
OF ITS SMALL RURAL DISTRICTS
OPENED THE DOORS THIS FALL WITH
ENOUGH. DEVICES AND HOT SPOTS
FOR EVERY STUDENT- WE HAVE
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY PLANS
IN PLACE THE LEGISLATURE BOB
PUT A FRAMEWORK AROUND WHAT.
STUDENTS SHOULD EXPECT AND WHAT
DISTRICTS ARE PROVIDE IN TERMS
OF BOTH A PLANS FOR CURRICULUM
OF FOR IN AND OUT OF SCHOOL AND
THOSE DEVICES NEEDED- HOWEVER-
THE ISSUE OF ACCESS TO RELIABLE
INTERNET GOES BEYOND THE LIST
NEEDS FOR DEVICES AND HOT SPOTS
EVEN WITH THESE TOOLS IN PLACE-
AS WE'VE- NOTED FAMILIES LIVE
IN REGIONS WHERE ACCESS. ISN'T
AN OPTION DUE TO THE LACK OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AREAS BUT
THERE ARE SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES. IN CITIES AS WELL-
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW IF
YOU GO TO RURAL PLUMAS COUNTY
MANY EDUCATORS LIKE INTERNET IN
THEIR HOMES AND HAVE TO USE.
THEIR OWN CELLPHONES MANY
STUDENTS LIKE. INTERNET
CONNECTIONS AND ALL UNIFIED
JUST EVEN THOUGH. HAS BEEN. UP
FOR DEVICE STUDENTS OFTEN COME
TO THE SCHOOL LOT. IN ORDER TO
GET INTERNET SHOULD THE WORK
BUT THEY'RE TRY TO DO.
DISTRICTS ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE VERY WOULD LIKE UNIFIED
SPENT A MILLION DOLLARS PUT UP
TO EXPAND INTERNET. BEYOND THE
SCHOOL. ASSEMBLY THIS IS A PLAN
AB AND C. OKAY GIVEN THE NEW
LIFE AND INTERNET SIR TO EVERY
STUDENT BUT- BECAUSE OF THE
EMERALD. OF SERVICE. IT Y.
PRICE. FAILS KNOW THE BIG INTO
THE CLASS TO TALK THE TEACHER.
THEY HAVE PACK FROM UP WEEK
STAFF MEANS TO OUT HOW TO THE
STUDENTS OR NOT ENGAGED
INCLUDING MAKE SOCIAL. HOUSE
CALLS. THE STATE HAS A PROVIDE
GUY FOR SAFE FOR SMALL OF STE.
I FORCED IN L. SCHOOLS ON.
SCHOOL WAIVERS IN PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT ARE NOT ABLE TO BE
OPEN BECAUSE OF. INFECTION
RATES- BUT WE DO NEED TO SOLVE
MY PROBLEM AND I WILL NOTE.
THAT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
INFECTION RATES IN COMMUNITIES
AND SCHOOL OPENINGS IS WELL
DOCUMENTED AROUND THE WORLD WE
SAW THAT WITH OUTBREAKS IN
ISRAEL AND SOUTH AFRICA AND
FRANCE WE'VE SEEN IT MORE
RECENTLY WITHOUT GRAYSON
GEORGIA TEXAS AND FLORIDA. IN
NEW YORK CITY SCHOOLS OPENED. A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO AND- ABOUT
A WEEK AND A HALF LATER HUNDRED
SCHOOLS HAD TO BE CLOSED.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT. THERE
WERE OUTBREAKS THAT. WERE
GROWING. IN CONTEXT THE SCHOOLS
ARE AT THAT POINT IN TIME SO WE
ARE TO HAVE DEAL WITH THIS FOR
A WHILE WE NEED TO SOLVE.
INTERNET ACCESS PROBLEM IN
ORDER TO DO THAT ULTIMATELY
FEDERAL REGULATION AND
INVESTMENT ALONG WITH CONTINUED
STRAIGHT EFFORTS WILL BE NEEDED
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM. THE
INTERNET IS TODAY WHAT THE
TELEPHONE WAS IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES WHEN THE NATION DECIDED
THAT INCENTIVES AND SUPPORTS
WHERE NEEDED. TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY HOME COULD GET ACCESS. TO
AND AFFORD A TELEPHONE.
CALIFORNIA'S BOTTLES FOR
EXPANDING BROADBAND ACCESS TO
PROVIDE DIRECT PARALLELS TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF RURAL
TELEPHONE LINES. CALIFORNIA
HIGH COST AND BE FUNDS
ADMINISTERED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WE HAVE
MADE SOME HEADWAY HOWEVER- WE
HAVE. JUST ABOUT AND IT'S THOSE
LAST MILES IT'S THAT YOU'RE
REACHING THOSE PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT I HAVE THE GREATEST
NEEDS THAT ARE GOING TO OUR
TENSION- AS A LEARNING STATE WE
HAVE BENEFITTED AND CAN
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT FROM
EXAMINING THE STRATEGIES THAT
OTHERS WHO ARE WORKING TO
CLOSE. THE DIGITAL DIVIDE HAVE
ATTEMPTED AND IN MY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY OF OFFERED EXAMPLES
FROM A NUMBER OF STATES THAT
HAVE INNOVATED IN THIS AREA- IN
CASE ANY OF THOSE- STRATEGIES
PROVE USEFUL HERE THOSE HAVE
INCLUDED USING FEDERAL FUNDING
AND WE MAY SEE ANOTHER RECOVERY
ACT IF NOT NOW. IN JANUARY OR
FEBRUARY OF THAT WILL PROVIDE
SOME RESOURCES FOR ONGOING
ISSUES OF CONNECTIVITY- WE CAN
USE OTHERS TO EXPAND BROADBAND
ROLLED VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
OF WE SEE A LOT OF STATES THAT
ARE DEVELOPING RESULTS MAPS
THAT SHOW ACCESS AND SPEEDS
ACROSS THE STATE IN VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES AND USE THOSE AS
THE BASIS FOR. A DETERMINING
GRANTS AND OTHER STEPS THAT CAN
BE TAKEN- AND TO PRIORITIZE OF
THE NEEDS WHERE THEY ARE
GREATEST MANY STATES HAVE RURAL
COOPERATIVES OF THIS IS VERY
COMMON IN THE MIDWEST- THAT
HAVE MANAGED TO XP. BROADBAND
IN PLACE THAT WOULD NOT ALL. I
HAVE BEEN I TRUST. OBVIOUSLY
PARTNERS WITH MANY.
CORPORATIONS I HE RATE ACTION
ARE AMONG THE STRAY THAT ARE.
WE HAVE MADE. VERY SUBSTANTIAL
STRIDES TOWARD CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. IN TERMS OF
WHAT CAN BE DONE WITH IT NOT
EASILY BUT WITH WHAT SOME
EFFORT UP WITH TO BUY AND HOT
SPOTS AND EXPANDING ACCESS TO
PROGRAM SO THAT IS FREELY
AVAILABLE LIKE A PUBLIC UTILITY.
I WATER LIKE TELL LIKE A LOT IS
THE STATE THE COUNTRY FINDS AND
THAT CALIFORNIA FINDS ITSELF.
AS WE CONTINUE TO ASSESS HOW
THE PANDA IS IMPACTING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS- WE WILL CONTINUE TO
SEEK TO LEARN FROM OUR OWN
EXPERIENCES AND FROM THOSE OF
OTHER STATES TO THE GREATEST
EXTENT WE CAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A DR LINDA DARLING HAMMOND
OF YOUR COMMENTS ALL OF
PRESENTERS FOR THE COMETS WILL
NOT- GO TO QUESTIONS FOR THE
PANEL YOU KNOW JUST START OFF
WITH ONE- FOR DR LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND. IS THERE ONE STATE.
THAT IS DOING THIS IGHT IN
OTHER WORDS THEY'VE GOT THIS
MOSTLY SOLVE FOR BLOCK OF ANY
WAY OF PUTTING IT WHO MIGHT- WE
LOOK TO AS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW TO
TACKLE THIS PROBLEM AGAIN THE
QUESTION IS THERE ONE STATE.
THAT REALLY HAS A GOOD GRASP ON
THIS ISSUE. THERE ARE STATES
THAT HAVE BEEN A LOT OF HEADWAY
BUT CALIFORNIA IS MUCH BIGGER
AND MORE DIVERSE GEOGRAPHICALLY
AND DEMOGRAPHICALLY THAN THAN
OTHER STATES. SO YOU KNOW YOU
COULD LOOK TO WYOMING WHICH
STARTED ON THIS AGENDA. YOU
KNOW MANY YEARS AGO IT WAS KIND
OF LIKE THIS STUFF TOP STATE
THE NATION FOR GETTING ACCESS
TO RURAL BROADBAND. I YOU CAN
LOOK TO SOME OF THE EFFORTS
THAT ARE GOING ON IN. PLACES
LIKE- KENTUCKY AND MAINE. I
THINK OUR- ARE. MORE
SUBSTANTIAL THE SIZE OF OUR
STATE AND THOUGHT DEMOGRAPHY
OUR STATE AND OUR- A GEOGRAPHY
WITH A BOUND AND- OTHER. TO
DEAL WITH BUT THERE ARE SOME
STRATEGIES THAT WE CAN LOOK TO
OTHER STATES. HARPER WHO DO
HAVE WHITES IS OF TERRITORY. A
LOT OF RULES REIN TO COVER THAT
COULD BE POTENTIALLY-
INFORMATIVE TO US. THANK YOU
ARE THERE QUESTIONS FOR MANY OF
THE MEMBERS HERE FOR. MISTER
SMITH. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR MR CABRAL
FROM THE LA OFFICE- YOU KNOW
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT WE
HAVE HERE IS IT IS A TWO PART
PROBLEM WE HAVE THE IMMEDIATE
CHALLENGE OF ADDRESSING- WHAT
HAPPENS IN THIS CRISIS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE GET EVERY
STUDENT WE POSSIBLY CAN'T UP TO
SPEED WITH TECHNOLOGY AND
EQUIPMENT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE INTO THE COMMENTS FROM
LINDA DARLING HAMMOND IN OUR
SUPERINTENDENT WE KNOW THAT ON
MANY FRONTS WE HAVE WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO SOLVE THAT
IMMEDIATE ISSUE. BUT IN THE
LONG TERM WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
AN ONGOING PIECE OF
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION PROCESS
AND OF OUR STATE STANDARDS SO
AT ANY POINT IN ITS ASSESSMENT
HAS THE L. A. CALCULATED WHAT
IT WOULD COST ON AN ANNUAL PER
PUPIL BASIS TO SUPPORT THE
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION STANDARDS
FOR EVERY STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA
FROM K. THROUGH TWELVE
INCLUDING INTERNET ACCESS
SOFTWARE LICENSING. AND
HARDWARE. THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE THAT WE'VE I
CALCULATED BEFORE I THINK THAT.
WILL BE A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO LOOK INTO THAT MAKE
SURE WHAT WHAT- WHAT EXACTLY
THAT WOULD ENTAIL- I GET ONE OF
THE IMPORTANT THAT YOU'RE
MENTIONING. WHAT ARE THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE HOME IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW. BUT
SITUATION MORE LONGER TERM IN
THE FUTURE WHEN WE'RE NOT.
DOING DISTANCE LEARNING AS A AS
AN ENTIRE STATE ESSENTIALLY.
ARGUED THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
SOME CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
EXACTLY WILL SENATOR PLACE BUT-
NO WE HAVE NOT DONE ANYTHING
SPECIFIC WHERE TO GAVE IT WOULD.
REQUIRE A LOT OF KIND MAJOR
DECISION POINTS TO FIGURE OUT
IF. A BALLPARK ESTIMATE OF
ANYTHING. THANK YOU. MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU THIS IS
I THINK THE L. A. O. AS WELL-
YOU MENTIONED THAT A LOT PER OF
HOUSE HAVE AN TO BROUGH. DO YOU
HAVE ANY DATA ON HOW MANY
HOUSEHOLDS ARE EQUIPPED WITH
SPEEDS ADEQUATE FOR MULTIPLE
CHILDREN DISTANCE LEARNING AND
DO YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC DATE
DATA OUTLINING THE CHALLENGES
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE DISTANCE
LEARNING IN RURAL CALIFORNIA-
WE'RE FINDING THE CONVERSATIONS
I'M HAVING IN MY DISTRICT IS
THAT NOT ONE FAMILY CAN ALL BE
ONLINE AT ONE TIME WITH
TEMPORARY HOT SPOTS AND SO- I
JUST WAS ALSO DO YOU HAVE A
PERCENT OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY RELYING ON TEMPORARY
HOT SPOTS FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING. THANK YOU. SO WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE THAT SPECIFIC DATA
THAT THE GAP ANALYSIS THAT I
MENTIONED THAT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION DID. I WAS
LOOKING AT. ACCESS OR ADOPTION
RATES AND USAGE IN IN
HOUSEHOLDS CHRISTIANS IN EMMAUS
HOLD. USING THE LOWER SIX
MEGABIT PER SECOND STANDARD I
THINK UNDER THAT STANDARD I
THINK IT'S PROBABLY ONLY ONE
STUDENT COULD BE DEFIED DOING
DISTANCE LEARNING AT ONE TIME
SO IF YOU HAVE A TWO OR THREE
CHILDREN. ARE TRYING TO ACCESS
A ONE TIME THAT'S NOT TELLING
YOU ENOUGH I DON'T THE
INFORMATION EVERYTHING FROM
THEM. ARE HAD SOME STATEWIDE
NUMBERS I DON'T KNOW TO WHAT
EXTENT THEY HAD INFORMATION-
ARE EASILY AVAILABLE THAT THAT
BREAKS DOWN INDIVIDUAL R. OR
RISK REGIONAL- VARIATION. ARE
WE DO KNOW THE BASED ON THE-
INFORMATION OF THE OTHER THAT
WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THERE
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY- BIGGER
CHALLENGES IN. LOWER INCOME
AREAS IN ERIC AND-
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER ADOPTION
AND- HOUSEHOLDS THAT HAVE
LIMITED ENGLISH THAT HAVE
LIMITED ENGLISH SPEAKING
ADULTS- AND I THINK BASED ON
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT BROADBAND
ACCESS IN. RURAL AREAS THERE'S
ALREADY JUST ONE THIRD OF. ONE
THIRD OF RURAL HOUSEHOLDS EVEN
IF THEY- JOSEPH EVEN IF THEY
WANTED SUBSCRIBE ALL OF THEM
CHOICES. TO THE BROADER ACCESS
TO BE ACCESS TO. THERE'S A LOT
THIRD OF HOUSE WHO DO NOT HAVE.
SUFFICIENT ACCESSIBLE TO
STUDENTS ON AT ONE TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ. YEAH BUT
YOU CHARGE MORE OF A COMMENT
AND THEN A QUESTION ON THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS FOR BEING
HERE THIS MORNING TO TALK ABOUT
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE. ON OUR-
SUPERINTENDENT- MISTER THURMAN.
FOR HIS WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
INTERNET NOT JUST INTERNET
INTERNET BUT HIGH SPEED
INTERNET. AND I LIKE HIS COOPER
SAYS. IT MUST FLOOR LIKE
ELECTRICITY I THINK WE'RE JUST
BEEN A LOT OF WORK DONE. BUT
OFFICER FROM OVER HERE NOW
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK IN
FRONT OF US. I LIKE THAT WE
NEED TO BE CREATIVE IN FINDING.
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM I KNOW YOU TALKED
ABOUT- PUTTING SOME FOLKS. TO A
TEST TO SEE HOW WE CAN. CLOSE
THAT GAP I THINK NOW MORE THAN
EVER. WE ALL NEED TO COME
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY STUDENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAS ACCESS TO HIGH
SPEED INTERNET. IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHERE IN THE INNER CITY.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY ON THE
ROLE COMMUNITIES MORE THAN EVER
WE NEED IT. AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN START MOVING FOR TO CLOSE
THAT GAP. SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR STATE MINISTER RODRIGUEZ
MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO THE OF
PRESENTERS I THINK THAT AS MANY
MY COLLEAGUES AND EVEN THE
PRESENTATIONS INDICATE- YOU
KNOW THAT THIS. REPRESENTS
INEQUITIES AS COVERT HAS DONE
THAT HAVE BEEN LOGGING SO LONG
EXISTING- IN OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM. AND IT'S IS ABSOLUTELY
IN THE SHORT TERM ABOUT HAVING
ADEQUATE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TECHNOLOGY TO ALL STUDENTS FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING BUT EVEN POST
PANDEMIC I THINK THAT- THE LACK
OF ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
DISADVANTAGES SO MANY STUDENTS.
AND HAS INDICATED- IN URBAN
AREAS- JUST AS MUCH AS A RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND SPEED IS AN
ISSUE IN BOTH PUBLICLY RURAL
COMMUNITIES BUT EVEN AS IN THE
CASE THAT YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
LEARNERS AND US AND- HOUSEHOLD
THE SPEEDERS. HAVE BROWN AND I
HAD A ME WITH. OUR COUNTY. OF
SCHOOLS A SUNBURST BOARD AND
AREA AND- I THINK THAT THE- ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT ARISES. IS
THE FACT THAT THERE CERTAINLY
ARE SO MANY DISTRICTS OF SO
MANY COMPANIES YEAH THE
GOVERNMENT YOU HAVE THE STATE
YET- THE DISTRICTS AND IF
THERE'S NOT A UNIFORM SYSTEM I
THINK THIS SPEAKS. TO THE
QUESTION FROM THE SUMMER SMITH
AND SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE A
OF THAT- REALLY THE IT IS
BECOMING UTILITY THAT THEY NEED
TO HAVE NOT JUST INTERNET
ACCESS BUT HIGH SPEED
ESPECIALLY FOR CHILDREN AND SO
IN ADDITION TO WHAT THE COST
WOULD BE. WHAT OF WHAT WOULD BE
THE NECESSARY MAJESTIC'S TO
CREATE A UNIFORM SYSTEM WORSE
PARENTS STUDENTS ONLY THE
HARAPPAN ORDER ONE- PLATFORM
ONE PLACE TO GO- THAT IS
IDEALLY EITHER STATE RUNNER
LEAST COORDINATED WITH THE
STATE BECAUSE WHAT I'M HEARING
IS THAT IT'S JUST TOO CONFUSING
AND TOO MANY STUDENTS ARE BEING
LEFT OUT THE ONES THAT KNOW.
THE PROGRAMS EXIST ARE GOING TO
GO TO THE PROGRAMS AS THE ONES
THAT DON'T KNOW THE FAMILIES I
DON'T KNOW- THAT ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE HARDER TO REACH
ESPECIALLY BY ON THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T ACTUALLY
KNOW WHERE THEY AE EITHER AND
SO YOU KNOW ANY COMMENT ON THAT
OR YOU KNOW JUST YOU CAN ACCEPT
A COMMON AND WE CAN- OF MOBILE
FOLLOW UP LATER. BUT I THINK
THAT IT'S ABOUT THE MONEY BUT
IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAVING ONE
PLACE TO GO TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR FAMILIES AND STUDENTS ARE
NOT HAVING THEM TO HAVE TO GO
TO TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS COMPANIES
AND WHAT HAVE YOU- BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THE INEQUITIES ARE.
JUST ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS CORK
SILVA. THANK YOU THIS IS. THIS
QUESTION IS FOR LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND AND- I WANTED TO SAY A
FEW THINGS BEFORE I ASKED
QUESTION BUT AS SHE WAS THE
NOTING IS YOU KNOW YOU NOT ONLY
HAVE THE RURAL CONNECTION- JUST
WITH SAID YOU ALSO HAVE AN
INNER CITY CONNECTION ISSUES
FAMILY ISSUES BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS WE HAVEN'T ADDRESSED
TODAY IT ISN'T JUST OUR
CHILDREN THAT ARE HAVING ISSUES
IT'S ALSO OUR WORKERS AND
EMPLOYEES MANY EMPLOYEES- NOT
ONLY WERE ASKED BUT- BUT HAD TO
MAKE A CHOICE TO WORK REMOTELY
SO THEY HAVE THOSE VERY SAME
ISSUE. BUT WE ALSO HAVE SOME
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT AS I MENTIONED
MY EARLIER COMMENTS INVESTED
AND WERE ABLE TO BRING SOME OF
THAT BROADBAND THROUGH A CITY
SCHOOL DISTRICT PARTNERSHIPS-
WE CAN CLEARLY SEE THAT NOT ALL
HAVE DONE THAT BUT NOW WHEN YOU
LOOK AT ADULT WORKERS WORKING
REMOTELY FOR A LOOK AT OUR
STUDENTS THAT NEED TO HAVE
ACCESS AND CITIES THAT NEED TO
PARTICIPATE. THIS DEFINITELY
COULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PARTNERSHIPS THAT UP WHETHER
THEY'RE STRONGLY ENCOURAGED
WHETHER- THERE'S NO OTHER
ALTERNATIVE BUT PEOPLE TO JOIN
FORCES AS FAR AS FUNDING SO MY
QUESTION TO. MISS HAMMOND IS
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SEEING MODELS
OF SOME STUDENTS RETURNING AND
A HYBRID MODEL- MATTER OF FACT
MY HUSBAND TEACHES JUNIOR HIGH
JUST STARTED YESTERDAY WITH
STUDENTS IN THE CLASS BUT ALSO
DOING DISTANCE LEARNING NOW
THEM THE SCHOOLS THAT OPEN SHE
MENTIONED THAT THERE WERE
OUTBREAKS AND HAD TO CLOSE-
THAT TO ME SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE
THAT WITH EVERYBODY JOINING
WERE COMING TO SCHOOL AT ONE.
AT DOES SHE HAVE ANY EXAMPLES
AND IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE JUST
IN CALIFORNIA OF WHERE THE
HYBRID MODEL KIND OF- ADDING
STUDENTS LITTLE BY LITTLE IS
WORKING AND IF SHE DOES WHAT
WHAT'S THE RESPONSE AND SHE'S
BACK ON. I HEAR I DON'T KNOW.
YEAH YOU KNOW MY HAIR YES. OKAY
BOB YEAH THERE ARE PLACES WHERE
THE HIGH MODEL WORKING AND
WE'RE IN CLASS WITH EVERYONE IS
THOSE ARE PLAY WHERE THE IN
FACT RATES LOW AND WHERE
EVERYONE IN THE SCHOOL IS
FOLLOWING ALL THE RULES YOU
KNOW EVERYONE'S USING FACE
COVERINGS SANITATION HAND
WASHING. YEAH DEVELOPED
FEDERATION SYSTEM AND WHY THAT
WERE. AND ARE ATTENTION TO
FISCAL DISINCENTIVES SO THEIR
NUMBER OF PLACES- MANY ON THE
EAST COAST WHERE YOU CAN SEE-
SCHOOLS IN OPERATING. IN WAYS
THAT ARE WORKING AND WHERE USE
THAT USE THE HYBRID MODEL IN
CLASS PART OF THE TIME IT AT
HOME AND SEVEN PART OF
SOMETIMES GET CLEANING TIME
DISINFECTING TIME IN BETWEEN
THE- BATCHES OF STUDENTS AS
WELL AS TO ALLOW. FOR THE
PHYSICAL JUST. A LOT SHE IS DO
THOSE STRATEGIES SAYS CAL. HAS
TRYING TO CREATE A FOR. A
THOUGHTFULLY I PLACE IN FACT
RATES ARE OVER. LOW AND WHERE
YOU CAN DO THAT WITH STRONG
COHORT IN SOMEONE SOMETHING IF
I AYE CASE DOES COME UP YOU CAN
IMMEDIATELY ATTEND TO IT. YOU
KNOW SEND A SMALL NUMBER OF
FOLKS. TO QUARANTINE. TO BE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
GOING TO SPUR ANY OF. AND SO ON
UP MY ABOUT WHERE IT'S BEEN
SAFE AND- PLACES WHERE
INSPECTION ARE. IT ALSO IN SOME
CASES WHERE. PEOPLE HAVE
FOLLOWED ALL THE RULES. EVEN
WITH THE SIGN ACTION THEN THE
YOU HAVE TO BE MUCH CUTS AND WE
CAN'T GET OVER THE DIVIDE ABOUT
THESE PROBLEMS WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING. HELLO BY JUST
EVERYONE BACK TO SCHOOL WE'VE
GOT TO DO IS SAFELY AND YOU
KNOW CARE FOR WAYS LIKE YOU'RE
DISTRICT IS TAKING ALL OF THE-
A CONCERN INTO ACCOUNT AND-
HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE A SIX.
EXPERIENCE. THANK OUR NEXT
QUESTION IS FOR MR GARCIA THANK
YOU TAKE CARE IN THE QUESTION
WOULD BE FOR PRESIDENT THAT
DARLING HAMMOND OR
SUPERINTENDENT. RECONSTRUCTION
IN THE BEST PRACTICES OUTSIDE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
YOU SEEN. WHERE PERHAPS IT'S
THE LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES-
HAVING THE ABILITY TO DELIVER
THE INTERNET- SERVICES- TO THE
STUDENTS FOR EXAMPLE I'VE BEEN
READING A LOT ABOUT- SHOWN WITH
TENNESSEE MUNICIPAL INTERNET
DISTRICT THAT'S- BEEN ABLE TO
CONNECT OVER THIRTY TWO.
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET AND ROUTERS. AND
DEVICES AND SO AS YOU MENTIONED
YOU KNOW THERE ARE PLACES WHERE
THEY'VE DONE IT RIGHT- I KNOW
THAT FOR US THAT ME. NEED SOME
PUBLIC POLICY REFORM ABLE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT HERE BUT I'M
WONDERING. IF THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE SEEN HAPPENING
OUTSIDE. AT AND FOR US TO
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
A DIRECTION THAT WE NEED TO GO
IN. FOR PURPOSES OF- BE MORE
EFFECTIVE AND I AND I PUT THAT
ON THE TABLE GIVEN THAT IN SOME
PLACES IN CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENT RIVERSIDE COUNTY PRO
COUNTY. THE AFFECTION INFECTION
RATES ARE NOT GOING TO. AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GOING INTO.
A DIFFERENT PHASE OF- THE
METRICS THAT HAVE BEEN SAVED
SET BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND SO THAT MEANS THAT WE MAY
BE IN. LOCKDOWN MODE- FOR
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME AND
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE BUT THAT
MEANS THAT OUR CHILDREN WILL
REMAIN. IN THIS DISTANCE
LEARNING. SITUATION YET
CONNECTIVITY REMAINS A PROBLEM
SPEED REMAINS A PROBLEM. AND
ULTIMATELY- CONTINUING TO SEE A
GAP. IN THE LEARNING CAPACITIES
OF OUR CHILDREN AND SO. I'M
WONDERING IF YOU HAVE SOME
EXAMPLES WHETHER THE LEAD TO
THE CHATTANOOGA. EXAMPLE AND IF
SO IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT AS A
PUBLIC POLICY REFORM. AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT PUSHING- YOU KNOW
LEGISLATION TO. BE MORE
INTENTIONAL WITH OUR EFFORTS. A
QUESTION FOR YOU MATTER
PRESIDENT OR SUPERINTENDENT OF
INSTRUCTION IF I AM SCREEN
ALMOST. AND THEN MAYBE SUPPORT
THEIR MOBILE. YEAH RIGHT AFTER.
I THERE ARE A LOT OF USEFUL
EFFORTS THERE ON IF I CHANNEL
JUST READ. I THINK HUNDRED
SPOTS ON STREET LAMP POLES ALSO
THAT THEY ARE FREE BROADBAND TO
NEIGHBORHOODS YOU KNOW SEPARATE
HAS WORKED IN THAT WAY. EARLIER
HEROES AT COULD TO. THAT KIND
OF- ACCESS IN MANY COMMUNITIES
THERE'S A REPORT THAT CAME OUT
JUST TODAY IT WAS PUBLISHED BY
A GROUP CALLED CHIEFS FOR
CHANGE THEY ARE HEADS OF URBAN
SCHOOLS SYSTEMS AND STATES-
WITH- WHOLE SLEW OF EXAMPLES OF
WAYS BY WHICH CITIES HAVE-
TAKEN THE BULL BY THE HORNS AS
A WORK AND CREATED INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES TO BE SURE THAT.
HIGH SPEED INTERNET IS MORE
WIDELY AVAILABLE- TYPICALLY AT
NO CHARGE WORK VERY LITTLE
CHARGE TO- RESIDENTS SO THERE
IS THERE IS A SET OF-
STRATEGIES AND I CAN BE SURE
ABOUT THAT REPORT GET SOME
GUIDANCE TO THE- COMMITTEE IF
IT'S NOT READILY AVAILABLE. AND
HERE THERE WILL BE CONTINUING-
FEDERAL FUNDING- I AM QUITE
SURE THERE'S A LOT GOING ON
HELL RIGHT NOW THAT WILL
PROVIDE SOME CHRISTIAN FOR SOME
OF THOSE KINDS OF INNOVATIONS
BOTH AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND AT
THE STATE LEVEL. JUST DON'T
TURN IT BACK YOU TO OUR CARLY
HAMMOND I WOULD JUST UP WHERE
YOU WERE YOU LEFT OFF WHO
ESTIMATE AMERICA YET WE HAVE
SEEN. PLEASE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ANY CAL. OKAY LEAD TO BE CREATE.
UP WITH ALL SEEN DISTRICTS
MOVEMENT TO. THE WORK OF BECOME
INTERNET SIR BUT- IT USED.
ATIONS BECKHAM'S BAKER ALLOWS.
THE ABILITY ACTION BECOME THEIR
OWN AYE IT HE- MAY HEAR THE
FROM PRETTY IN COUNTY BUT KNOW
THAT OTHER CAN. LITERALLY HAVE
BEEN IN THE TECHNOLOGY BECOME
THEIR OWN I P. THEY CURRENT GET
WITH THE NEEDED. FROM
TRADITIONAL I'D MANY OF WHOM
WEREN'T WILLING TO MAKE IN.
BECAUSE THE POPULATION JUST
WHAT A GREAT ENOUGH FOR THE
PROFIT GET THE GET A POINT. UP
WE'VE ALSO. THAT ANY CITY FOR
CARE THEY'VE ME GETTING DEVICE
FOR THAT. WORK WITH WITH APPLE
YOU CAME UP WITH A WAY TO GET A
LITTLE DEVICE THAT ALREADY A IN
A WE UP ON THAT IN WE WERE ABLE
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH APPLE T.
MOBILE. AND THEY CREATED A
INTERNET ENABLE I. THAT WOULD
LOW COST THAT WOULD. WORK THE
OPERATE SYSTEM THAT SCHOOL THIS
AND CAL. WILL BE. IT BECAME IN
COURT BECAUSE THAT YOU KNOW THE
BIGGEST IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE FOR NOW. IF THEY CANNOT GET
SUPPLY BACK ENOUGH ALL SUPPLY
COME BACK. SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
STILL WAITING TO GET DEVICES
EIGHTY THAT MADE COME IN UNTIL
AS LATE AS DECEMBER AND SO THE
OFFER THAT. AND THAT I APPLE
MADE WITH MOBILE GAVE US IN OUR
TO STAY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE
HAVE TO PULL THEM. WE SET UP
GOT YOU'VE GOT MY FROM THE
LETTER LAW COMMITTEE FONG
THERE'S NOT MUCH SUPPLY
AVAILABLE UNTIL APPLE IN T.
MOBILE CAME TOGETHER IN A WAY
THAT THAT MAY. BE SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN USE ACROSS ANY
PLATFORM ANY OPERATING SYSTEM
THAT MEANT UP TO ANOTHER
MILLION OR SO DEVICES YEAH I
STATUS FIGURE OUT WAYS TO. THE
SOURCE MATERIAL- NUMERI
NINETEEN OUR OFFICE MANY OF YOU
BETTER DO THE TASK FORCE SHE
LITERALLY HAD FIGURED OUT A WAY
TO GET MANUFACTURERS TO HOLD ON
TO DEVICES FOR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SO WE'VE
SEEN INNOVATION- IN OAKLAND AND
SAN FRANCISCO- THEY PULL. IT
OUT WE GET MORE DEVICE IS
STUDENTS IN SAN FRANCISCO THERE
EVEN. THE REX ANYWAY THAT YOU
CAN GET AT KNOW ACT THE INNER
SOME STRUCK PRO. TO EXPAND IT
LEARNING UP SEE CANTIK COUNTY
HAS CLEAN DATA MAKE A- AND TO
SCHOOL THERE. AND IT IS. THAT
WE SEE INTO. ONE THING THAT
WILL BE. I IT IS LEGISLATURE
MAY TAKE UP IS. NOT PERMITTING
HOW DO WE GET CONSIST COM. TO
ALLOW FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT NEEDED CALIFORNIA TO GET
UNDER WAY WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE A
FEW OF PROJECTS THAT. ARE
INTENDED TO BE HELPFUL BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN I'LL BE HONEST WITH
HIM BLOCK. EVEN BY BY CALTRANS
AND WE USE THE TASK FORCE TO
ESTABLISH RELATIONSHIPS WITH
CALTRANS THE STATE. HEY LET'S
REMOVE THE BARRIERS SO THAT WE
CAN YOU KNOW GET YOU KNOW GET
ONCE AND GET THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE. TO SUPPORT WHATEVER
THAT PROJECT WAS AS WELL AS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO. WE THINK
WE'RE GONNA SEE MORE MORE
CITIES. MUNICIPALITIES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GETTING INVOLVED IN
THE DIRECT PROVISION- OF
BROADBAND BECAUSE OF. THE
BARRIERS THAT HAVE EXISTED WITH
SOME OF THE TRADITIONAL ICE
PCHS. WE'RE NOT WILLING- COULD
BRING- THE RESOURCES AT TO THE
AREA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I DO DO TO HIGHLIGHT THAT- WE
HAVE A LOT URBAN MEMBERS HERE
SUBURBAN MEMBERS BUT- I GUESS
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF. FOLKS OUT
THERE WERE SOME RURAL AREAS IN
THIS THIS ISSUE IS KIND OF
DIFFERENT IN A RURAL AREA WHERE
YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE ACCESS AT
ALL- EVEN IF YOU CAN'T PAY. YOU
MIGHT NOT HAVE IT SO THIS ISSUE
EXPANDS THAT DYNAMIC AS WELL-
MR KILEY. THANK YOU I HAVE A-
QUESTIONS FOR SUPERINTENDENT-
BERMAN I FIRST WANT TO- COMMEND
YOU ON THE WORK YOU'VE DONE.
WITHOUT REACH TO THE I. S.
P.'S- IN ORDER TO EXPAND
ACCESS- I THINK THAT'S MADE A-
BIG DIFFERENCE FOR A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES SO I WANTED
TO GIVE YOU CREDIT FOR THAT. HI
THIS IS. INNOVATION COMPETITION
YOU MENTIONED ALSO SOUNDS
INTERESTING THAT. PERHAPS IT'LL
SERVE AS A REMINDER THAT-
INNOVATION AND COMPETITION AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION OUR VIRTUES TO
BE ENCOURAGED. AND NOT VICE IS
TO BE STAMPED OUT AS- THAT'S
KIND OF IN THE BENT OF OUR
STATES- POLITICAL LEADERSHIP
BUT I WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO ASK YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE THE-
LACTAID. STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION YOUR-
CALIFORNIA'S- TOP EDUCATION.
LEADER OTHER THAN PERHAPS THE
GOVERNOR. AND SO I'M GONNA ASK
YOU IS AS YOU WORK DILIGENTLY-
ON THESE ISSUES. TO EXPAND
BROADBAND ACCESS. I DO ALSO
AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENT THAT.
ME AND MISTER O'DONNELL APPEAR
TO SHARE- THAT WE NEED TO
RETURN TO CLASSROOM. BASED
INSTRUCTION AS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. YOU IF I MAY KILEY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION AND
I'LL GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO
ANSWER MAYBE IN A VERY SHORT
MAN BECAUSE- THAT REALLY IS NOT
THE FOCUS OF THIS HEARING. THE
FOCUS OF THIS HEARING IS ON
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AND I
SHARE YOUR PASSION. THAT
STUDENTS GET BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM IN A SAFE MANNER FOR-
BASED ON SCIENCE NOT JUST
POLITICAL SCIENCE BUT ACTUAL
BIOLOGICAL EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
SCIENCE- BUT I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP THE HEARING
FOCUSED ON ACCESS WE CAN HAVE
ANOTHER HEARING IN THE FUTURE.
ON THE TOPIC OF GETTING KIDS
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM.
BECAUSE I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THAT-
AND I JUST REGISTERED AS ONE
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE FOCUSING
ON THE PURPOSE OF THE HEARING I
HAVE OVER THE NEXT TO ME. SO
YOU HEARD ME THERE IT IS LET ME
JUST THAT AND THEN CLARIFY MY
QUESTION- AND I HAVE IN FACT
THAT AFTER HEARING-
SPECIFICALLY TO YOU. ON THE
ISSUE OF SCHOOL RE OPENING BUT
I'M SURE YOU WOULD AGREE THAT
THE CHALLENGES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW RELATED TO THIS
DIGITAL DIVIDE. ARE VERY MUCH
DEPENDENT UPON THE TIMELINE FOR
THE RETURN TO IN CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION SO TO SAY THAT
THAT'S NOT. RELATED TO THE
TOPIC OF THE HEARING- IS
OBVIOUSLY UNTRUE SO HI MISTER.
THURMAN JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO ANSWER. THANK YOU FOR
THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER K. THANK
YOU. FOR THE GUIDANCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHERYL DONAL. I LET LET
ME CLEAR. RELATED TO THE
CANDIDATE COMP INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US. TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO HARNESS. THE
INNOVATION. ENTREPRENEURSHIP OF
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES AND- OTHER
INNOVATORS TO THINK THROUGH A
SOLUTION. THAT HAS. YOU KNOW.
TO A PROBLEM THAT HAS JUST
REFLECT THE TWO FOR TOO LONG.
AND SO I DO WANNA BE CLEAR IT'S
NOT. IN ANY WAY SUGGESTION THAT
WE PUT. COMPETITION IN THE
EDUCATION THAT'S NOT A- THAT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT I SUBSCRIBE
TO I THINK EVERY STUDENT. THAT
YOU SAID TO KILEY IN THE
SCHOLARSHIP. EQUITY ISSUES
EVERY STUDENT DESERVES A HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION REGARDLESS OF
THEIR DIFFICULT. AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE IN THIS PLACE IN THE
FIRST PLACE IS THAT WE'VE SEEN.
LIMITED INVESTMENT IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND URBAN
AREAS AND RURAL COMMUNITIES BUT
THE INNOVATION. COMPETITION IS
ONE THAT SENT THE COMPANIES GET
YOUR R&D COOK IT. COME UP WITH
SOME OF THE BEST IDEAS THAT
HADN'T BEEN TRIED BEFORE. TO
HELP US ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. IT
MEANS THAT OUR STUDENTS AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND OTHER
GREAT INSTITUTION. IN THE STATE
IN THE NATION HAVE OPPORTUNITY.
TO COME UP WITH IN A NEW WAY TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS. THE
BROADBAND GAP INTO TRACKS HOW
WE CREATE ON. SOURCES OF
SUPPORT FOR PUTIN TO NEED. A
WILL BE ANNOUNCING MORE IN THAT
IN THAT WAY AGAIN I WANT TO.
THANK DR GARY MICHELSON USED A
BACON SB. INVESTMENT HERE AS
WELL AS GENENTECH AND OTHERS
WHO ARE INVESTING IN THIS GRANT
NEW- INNOVATION. A COMPETITION.
THAT WE'RE ABOUT THE ROLLOUT.
AS IT RELATES TO THE OPENING OF
SCHOOLS I THINK THAT AS A
GENERAL KNOWLEDGE THAT IN THE
BEGINNING WE ALL AGREE. THAT
ULTIMATELY THE BEST PLACE FOR
OUR STUDENTS IS TO BE IN SCHOOL
BUT WHEN WE CAN GET THERE. WHEN
WE CAN GET THERE WHEN THAT
FAITH ENOUGH. FOR THEM TO DO
SO. WE ARE SEEING SO MANY
EXAMPLES OF PLACES WHERE
THERE'S TOO MANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE SAFETY. FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR EDUCATORS AND
OUR FAMILIES. AND WE HAVE TO
PROCEED CAUTIOUSLY AND THAT
MEANS. THAT FOR NOW. FOR MANY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. DEFENSE
LEARN. IS OUR BEST OPTION. AND
SO I WOULD YOU SEE ASSEMBLY
CALLED CATCHING ON THE EQUITY
THAT WOULD GIVE I THINK WE HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IS EQUITY.
WE HAVE TO. IT EVEN THOUGH. THE
PAN. WE WERE SEEN DISPLAY. FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR TO THE INCOME.
TO THIS IN URBAN AREAS AND
RURAL AREAS. WHERE STUDENTS CAN
HAVE AN- TO THE HEIGHTS.
INTERNET WE- DIFFERENT. WERE
DISTRICTS HAPPEN. THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS. KEEP YOUR APPETITE
STANDARD TESTS ONE QUIT THAT
DOESN'T ALWAYS. BECAUSE ARE
DOING THEIR BEST JUST THE CALL
TOGETHER WHAT THEY CAN GET. WE
NEED A WHOLE DID REFORM WE MAY.
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE ARE TOP
ABOUT. SCIENCE BEING AVAILABLE
FOR EVERYONE OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FROM PRESCHOOL TO
TWELFTH GRADE SO WE'RE
PREPARING THE WORKFORCE OF
TOMORROW. IS THE BIGGEST EQUITY
ISSUE OF OUR TIME WE DO HAVE TO
WORK TO OFFSET LEARNING GAPS.
AND HAVING ACCESS TO COMPUTERS
IS A TOOL FOR DOING THAT IT
DOESN'T REPLACE WHAT A GREAT
PIECE YOU CAN DO. BUT WE'RE IN
A TIME WHERE WE NEED THE TOOLS
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR TEACHERS
CAN BE CONNECTED. TO OUR KIDS
AND TO THAT END WE'RE EXCITED
TO WORK WITH- THESE TWO
COMMITTEES- AND THE AND THE
LEGISLATORS ON THE- COMMITTEE-
TO LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS- FOR
CRAFTING- OUR DIGITAL DIVIDE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I CAN
CERTAINLY SUBSCRIBE TO A LOT OF
THE AND I APPRECIATE THE PAST
AND- I JUST TO BE THAT YOU CAN
YOU YOU ARE WILLING STATE ON A-
THAT THE ONLY REASON. SCHOOL
SHOULD REMAIN CLOSE RIGHT NOW-
IS FOR SAFETY REASONS RELATED
TO COVER. NINETEEN WELL SIXTY
IS THE HIGHEST ORDER AT THIS
TIME- I DON'T KNOW HOW. TO
SPEAK TO IT I DON'T WANT TO
POLITICIZE THIS ISSUE THIS IS
ABOUT STATE FIRST. AND FOREMOST
YOU HER CONDUCT LIMITER
CUNNINGHAM AND- BE SEEN SO MANY
EXAMPLES OF WHAT SCHOOLS ARE.
OPEN TO SERVE. AND IT HAS
RESULTED IN AND REAL HARM AND
I'LL JUST SAY THAT WITHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS LITERALLY.
ORGANIZED MEETINGS BETWEEN
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT AND
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICERS. TO HELP
US FIGURE OUT HOW TO TRACK THE
DATA. ABOUT RATE OF INFECTION
TO MAKE SMART STATE AGENCY
ABOUT WHEN SCHOOLS CAN OPEN
THERE ARE MORE QUESTIONS RIGHT
NOW THAN ANSWERS. BUT WHAT IS
CLEAR THAT WE CAN DO MORE WE
STAND TOGETHER ON BEHALF
HORRIFICALLY INCIDENTS IN. THE
STATE PARAMOUNT- IT WILL
CONTINUE TO PUSH THAT UNTIL
IT'S SAFE FOR OUR SCHOOLS TO
REOPEN. GREAT SO FOR THOSE WHO
SAY THAT EVEN SCHOOLS THAT CAN
SAFELY OPEN MAYBE SHOULDN'T
BECAUSE IT'S UNFAIR FOR THEM TO
HAVE A HEAD START. YOU WOULD.
DISAVOW THAT LINE OF REASONING.
NOT SURE ELSE TO PUT IT OTHER
THAN THE FAKE IS PARA THAT IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE MANY
SCHOOLS THAT ARE EXPERIMENTING
WITH OPENING I THINK THEY'VE
BEEN VERY. SOME OF BEING
CREATIVE. WITH TRYING TO FIND
HYRID- THAT MIGHT WORK OUT BUT
THERE ARE STILL QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW. GREAT THE TRANSMISSION CAN
OCCUR- THE NEW DATA THAT SAYS
THAT KOBE COULD BE WITH US WELL
BEYOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THERE'S NEW DATA THAT TALKS
ABOUT- YOU KNOW HERE FOR
TRANSMISSION RATE AND SHARING
THE SAME INTERNET. YOU HAVE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT YOUR
BILL TRANSIENT. AND THINK THAT
WE JUST DO NOT KNOW AND CLEARLY
LOTS OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. HAS TO BE AVAILABLE
I THINK THIS IS THE TIME FOR GO
SLOW AND STEADY. AND BE FOCUSED
ON FINANCE IN THE SAFETY AND OF
COURSE WE ALL WANT TO DO ALL
THAT WE CAN TO GET OUR- OUR
STUDENTS BACK TO SCHOOL TO AS
POSSIBLE. BUT WE JUST CANNOT
SACRIFICE. IN THE MEDIA. THANK
YOU. MR SANTIAGO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THIS KIND OF A
QUESTION TO THE SUPERINTENDENT
AND ALSO TO- DR GARLAND ON
HAMMOND TO THE LARGEST CREE AND
SOME OF THIS MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
BE ANSWERED TODAY BUT I WANTED
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION AS
WE MOVE FORWARD- A IN THE KIND
AND THE WHOLE BIT CODED WORLD
OF EDUCATION. TO THE DO YOU
COULD MAYBE MAKE SOME COMMENT
ANSWER WOULD BE APPRECIATED BUT
WOULD UNDERSTAND- FOR THE
TALENTS OF THESE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I THINK WE'LL TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS AND I AND I THINK
WE'VE ALL I FEEL THAT THAT THE
DISPARITIES BETWEEN THOSE WHO
HAVE AND THOSE WHO DOES WHO
DON'T HAVE. ARE MORE EVIDENT
THAN THAN EVER BEFORE TODAY
WITH THE BILL'S INVITED
DISTANCE LEARNING IT IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE BEEN
HARDER HIT BOTH THE IN COVERT
INFECTIONS- DECLINING INCOME
AND NOW EDUCATION. WE TALK
ABOUT THE SPACES THE AREA OF
SPACE FOR KIDS TO LEARN- BUT IS
THERE IN BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE'VE NOT TALKED
ABOUT THAT PARTICULARLY
SURROUND HOW TO BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE EDUCATION AS OF
AS IT RELATES TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IS
PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE- A
ENGLISH LEARNER. AND A LOT OF
THAT HAS TO DO WITH- THE
LITERACY- THE DIGITAL LITERACY
LIKE I TAKE MYSELF BACK TO
BEING A KID- MY PARENTS WERE
UNDOCUMENTED AND DIDN'T HAVE
LANGUAGE- PROFICIENCY IN
ENGLISH. THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS WHO WE ARE WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO REACH YOU DON'T HAVE.
TABLETS ARE WHO DON'T HAVE
DIGITAL CONNECTION ARE GONNA
FALL INTO CATEGORIES. LIKE
THAT. NOT EXCLUSIVELY THERE ARE
OTHER COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
ABOVE THE FOR THE COMMUNITY
THAT I LARGELY REPRESENT.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE IN
AN AFFLUENT COMMUNITY A NEARBY
CAR PROFESSIONAL- THERE'S A
DIFFERENT SORT OF CONVERSATION
AS IT RELATES TO DISTANCE
LEARNING BUT IF YOU'RE
REPRESENT THE COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT. IT'S WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE THE PICTURES THE
KIDS ARE SITTING ON AN IPHONE
OR A LIFELINE PHONE OUTSIDE TO
TALK ABOUT- BECAUSE I MAY BE
THE ONLY INTERNET CONNECTION IN
THE ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD TO SOME
DEGREE AND STILL NOT. EQUITABLE
WHEN IT COMES TO SPEEDS. LET
ALONE TECHNOLOGY LEVEL LITERACY
LEVEL ON EDUCATION. AND I THINK
I'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION WITH
EDUCATION LEADERS AND- AROUND
THIS ISSUE. HAS THERE BEEN
GIVEN THE ROLE BOB IS A BIGGER
MEET MEET SOME SORT OF EQUITY
AS A COME THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
AND LEARNING. YOU HAVE DOT TAKE
NOT WE'VE GOT THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE IS SOME. DIGITAL
pMOUNTAINS OF GAPS AND VALLEYS
WHEN IT COMES TO. WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES. THAT MAY NOT HAVE
THAT- LET ALONE TRYING TO TEACH
A KID. NOW GONE. IT WILL
RECEIVE THE FOOD LINES AND
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WE WORK WITH EVERY WEEK- WHERE
PARENTS ARE SITTING IN FOOD
LINES AND THEY OFTENTIMES WILL
BRING THEIR EDUCATION PACKAGES
AND SAY WHAT WHAT THE WHAT IS
THIS. I CAN'T TRANSLATE I
CAN'T. CAN'T DO ANYTHING WITH
IT LET ALONE IF YOU HAVEN'T.
LET ALONE IF YOU HAD ALL THE
EQUIPMENT AT HOME WHAT WOULD
YOU DO WITH IT ANYWAY. IT'S OF
IT HAS TO BE SOME THOUGHT. DONE
BEYOND JUST CONNECTING BECAUSE
IT WOULD BE INADEQUATE TO
THINK. THAT THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE DISTANCE LEARNING. IS
JUST ABOUT CONNECTION TABLETS.
THERE'S SOME THOUGHT TO BE
GIVEN. NOW IN THE FUTURE ABOUT
LITERACY AROUND PARENTS. AND
WHAT I WOULD CAN HOPEFULLY THE
CARD HOLDER. APPROACH TO HOW
THIS IS REALLY GONNA WORK.
OTHERWISE WE WILL BE LEAVING A
GENERATION OF. KIDS BEHIND-
INCLUDED IN THAT CONVERSATION
HAS TO BE CONVERSATION OF
FAIRNESS TO TEACHERS- OR THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY AT LARGE
BECAUSE IF. IF YOUR TEACHER
EXPECTED TEACHER TODAY WHAT
WOULD YOU DO WITH YOUR KIDS
YEAH. MADE LIKE MANY OF US WHO
HAVE TO WORK FROM HOME THE-
COULD YOU IMAGINE ON ON ON AND
ON. I NEED LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE JOB AND HAVING TO DECIDE
WHETHER YOUR KIDS GOING TO GET
AN EDUCATION THAT DAY OR YOU'RE
GOING TO GO TO OR YOU'RE GOING
TO GO TO WORK AND THIS IDEA
THAT YOU PUT A KID IN FRONT OF
A COMPUTER AND THEY'RE JUST
GONNA LEARN JUST DOESN'T REALLY
MEET THE DEMAND OF THE DAY AND
WHAT REALLY IS PRESENT. I GOT
TWO KIDS A FOUR YEAR OLD AND A
SEVEN YEAR OLD. THE SEVEN YEAR
OLD HAS A BETTER TIME STANDING
IN FRONT OF A STANFORD COMPUTER
BUT THERE ARE MULTIPLE GLITCHES
AND I'VE GOT THE FASTEST
INTERCEDING INTERNET SPEED IN
THAT AREA. AND THEY STILL BUMP
OFF WHEN IT'S MORE THAN. WHAT
IT'S TWO KIDS BUT IF I GET ON
SOMETHING A BOMB CITING A
RESTART COMPUTERS GOT TO GET
GOING THERE'S A LOT OF. STUFF
THERE THAT I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
WOULD CONSIDER MYSELF SOMEWHAT.
SOPHISTICATED WHEN IT COMES TO
TECHNOLOGY AND I STILL STRUGGLE
WITH THE COMPUTER TO GET BACK
ON IN THAT LINK ZOOMS NOT
CONNECTING AND THERE'S- ALL
THESE DIFFERENT CHAT ROOMS YOU
GOT TO GET INTO IT YOU GOTTA
GET A SEPARATE CHAT ROOM AFTER
YOU DO READING AND- AND I
FORGOT WHAT THE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING START TESTING- ROOM
THAT HE GOT. HE HAS TO GET IN
TO GET TESTED AFTER DOES WORK
I'VE GOT TO SNAP A PICTURE OF
THIS THING AND I GOT TO SEND IT
BACK TO THE TEACHERS GOTTA GET
GRADED. IT'S GOING TO COME BACK
IN THIS HOMEWORK IN THE
AFTERNOON. SO COULD YOU IMAGINE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT STRUGGLING
COMMUNITIES. THAT HAVE TO MAKE
THE DECISION. THEY EITHER WORK.
OR HAVE YOU CAN GET EDUCATE.
WELL IT IN EVEN THE ASSUMPTION
THAT IT THAT IT THAT IT'S
WORKING TO A LARGE DEGREE. I
THINK WE HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT. BOTH WITH TEACHERS WHO
ARE EXPECTED TO TEACH. OUR THE
SCHOOL DAY AND BOTH MY PARENTS.
ARE IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
I TALK ABOUT IT SO THE REASON I
SAY THAT IS BECAUSE- I KNOW I'M
LONG WINDED BUT A VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT BECAUSE
WHEN YEARS THAT I REPRESENT.
THE YEARS THAT I REPRESENT AND
I'LL SPEAK TO MY- I KNOW THE
OTHERS HAVE THE SAME. SIMILAR
SITUATION BUT I CAN'T SPEAK
YOUR DISTRICTS OF SPEAK FOR THE
ONE I REPRESENT- ARE
EXPERIENCING THIS. AND IT'S NOT
JUST THE ONE OFFERS NOT JUST
TWO PEOPLE TALKING TO ME IT'S-
OVER AND OVER AND- OVER AND-
OVER. AND EVEN MY NEIGHBORS
RECENTLY- AFTER ALMOST SIX
MONTHS OR FIVE MONTHS THE
PANDEMIC WERE ABLE TO. HUSTLE
ENOUGH MONEY TO GET THE
INTERNET. SERVICE AND OVER AND
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO. HOW
TO GET NOW TABLETS AND IPHONES
AND DO HOMEWORK WITH THE KIDS.
SO AT SOME POINT TIME GETTING
KIND OF REINVENT THE WAY THE
EDUCATION IS BEING DONE-
WHETHER IT'S DONE AT ALL YOU
KNOW I KNOW I. WHETHER IT'S
DONE DIFFERENTLY WHETHER IT'S
DONE SHORTER A SHORTER DAYS.
I'M CERTAINLY NOT TRYING TO GET
IN BETWEEN. ANY ANY AGREEMENTS
THE LOCAL DISTRICTS HAVE MADE
WITH ITS WORKFORCE BY THINK
IT'S TIME TO REIMAGINE FOR
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AND
THINK ABOUT WHAT THE QUOTE
UNQUOTE DAY AFTER LOOKS LIKE.
THE DAY AFTER COOPER WE'RE
GOING BE BROUGH TO BE SENT
AROUND. NO THAT. WHAT HAVING
GOOD KNOWLEDGE POTENTIALLY AND
I HOPE NOT I HOPE THAT I'M
WRONG. THE GENERATION THE KIDS
GOT LEFT BEHIND BECAUSE WE
COULDN'T TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
SERIOUS PROBLEMS AND IDENTIFY
THEM EARLY AND START WORKING ON
IT FOR THAT. DAY AFTER. AND
THAT DATE IS HAPPENING. I DO
WANNA THROW THAT OUT THERE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A VERY
SERIOUS CONVERSATION THE- TO
CONTINUE HAVE I KNOW WE'RE ON
THE SAME PAGE WALL ROLLING IN
THE SAME DIRECTION BUT FOR THE
SAKE OF. FOR THE FOR THE SAKE
OF REPRESENTED JUST THE
DISTRICTS IN THE REGION THAT I
REPRESENT. THIS HAS TO BE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AS I HEAR EVERY
DAY FROM PARENTS. THERE'S THAT
LANGUAGE BARRIER. THERE'S THAT
PRESSURE TO GO TO WORK. AND
THERE'S KIDS AT HOME. AND IN
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
THAT I REPRESENT IT. THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. SOMETIMES IF YOU
SEND ME EMAIL THE NIGHT BEFORE
THAT CONSTITUTES. THE STATE OF
YOUR PRESENT THAT DAY. LET ME
THAT THIS IS NOT JUST TO
PRESENT RIGHT HAS NOT. KID
RECEIVE AN EDUCATION IF YOU
TURN IN THE HOMEWORK THAT WAS A
SIGN FOR THREE DAYS. THAT
CONSTITUTES THE STUDENT BEING
IN CLASS FOR THREE DAYS. SO
CERTAINLY IS GONNA BE BETTER
METRICS TO BETTER MEASUREMENTS
AND WASTE ACTUALLY REALLY DIG
INTO WHAT'S GOING ON AND EVEN
IF WE CAN'T ADDRESS ANOTHER
HUGE BARRIERS. GOT IT AT LEAST
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL.
QUESTION YOU TAKE A LOT OF PAIN
HE STARTED WITH ACCESS. THIS IS
YOUR RIGHT THIS IS MORE THAN AN
ACCESS ISSUE. WE HAVE TO GET
PROVIDE LITERACY AND TRAINING.
FOR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. AND
FOR EDUCATORS- RIGHT NOW SOME
OF OUR PARTNERS APPLE AND
OTHERS. ARE HELPING US TO
LAUNCH SOME TRAINING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
EDUCATORS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY- ARE ABLE TO USE THE
TECHNOLOGY- IT SERVES AS AN
ACTIVE ISSUE- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WITH. YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
COME UP WITH GREAT WAYS TO. TO
WORK ON THE DIGITAL LITERACY
THAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
PARTICULARLY FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS. I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE STANDARD
YOU KNOW COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. SUPERINTENDENT
CRYSTAL MONCEAU. AND NAPA
COUNTY. SUPERINTENDENT DR
BARBARA NEMCO. OUT THERE
WORKING WITH SOME TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAMS THAT REALLY WORK YOUR
SUPPORT RECOGNITION LEARNERS.
AROUND LITERACY BUT ARE ARE
ALSO BUILDING. DIGITAL LITERACY
AND SO. YOU KNOW WE WANT TO GO
FOR. WITH THE MEMBERS OF THESE
TWO COMMITTEES IN A WAY WHERE
WE AT THE TASK FORCE AND THE-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE WORKING ON A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY. TO ADDRESS
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. ACCESS TO
DEVICES- ACCESS INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR CONNECTIVITY. TRAINING AND
SUPPORT. ON HOW TO DO THESE
DEVICES SETTING GOOD STANDARDS.
FOR PROMOTING DIGITAL LITERACY.
WE WANT ADDRESSED THE CASH THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE'RE ALL ON
JUNE TOGETHER IT WENT IN OUR
HOMES USING. GIVES IT WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS. WE ALL GET
KICKED OFF AND SOMETIMES I IS
PEACH HALVES TAX. WHERE YOU GET
KICKED OFF AT THE WHICH THE CAP.
IT THAT COULD ACCEPT. FOR IN
THE TWO FOR WILL BE TAKEN AT
ISSUE A- IN MANY WAYS THE IT
PROVIDES UP. FROM OF OUR
FAMILIES. THEY HIT. THAT YEAH
WE WERE. WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT NOW TO ROLL OUT A NEW
WAY TO DO FOR. ENGAGED TO MAKE
SURE THAT FAMILIES ARE MORE AND
MORE CONNECTED IF YOU POINT
OUT. MAY YOUR FAMILIES ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THE WORK WITH A
SINGLE. RECORD STORIES ARE
EQUITY POOR HAVE TO HOLD US
ABOUT. MEMBERS WHO ONLY HAVE A
SINGLE CELL PHONE IF THERE ALL
TRYING USE. THAT FOR THE
HOMEWORK THE- WERE. IN
COMMUNICATE. AND WE THAT.
FAMILY PROGRAM IS THE WAY THEY
SURE THE FAMILIES A WAY TO BE
CONNECTED THE SCHOOL. IS
LIAISON SOMEONE CAN CALL.
THAT'S WHAT WE ASK YOU TO
HIGHEST. SHOULD BE KEPT PEOPLE
TO. THE INTERNET COME TO YOU
WHEN THEY A CROP. YOU GOTTA
SIGN A LEASE WHO ANSWERED CALL
IF SOMEONE WHO WAS. IN WHO CAN.
AND SO ALL ECSTASY. THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
MEMBERS THESE TWO COMMITTEE TO
BUILD A ROPE. AND WAY. TO
ADDRESS QUOTE THE DIGITAL TO.
MORE QUICK. BUILDING CAMPUS.
CHOI IMPERFECTION THE- ON THE
USE OF IT INCREASING DIGITAL
WITH. STANDARDS THIS OF. IS ALL
COMPLETETHE OF OUR- NOT YOUR
POINT. TO WHAT EVERYONE BEGIN
TO SET. THAT CAN IS US THINK.
ABOUT HOW WE MEASURE. LOOKING
AT THE- WAYS. TO ABOUT HOW WE
MEASURE LEARN WE TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR A LONG TIME IF NOT ALL
YOU ALWAYS. NOT THAT YOU KNOW
WHICH- CAN. THAT GET THE PART
AT. OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE. ON THE
TAKE. YOU BEING GAY INSTEAD.
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS WITH
DIGITAL WITH. SO AND THEY HAVE
THIS MARKET SKILLS HELP THEM
THE JOBS OF TWO. THAT THEY CAN
IN A BLANK ALL OF THINGS ARE
ARE REALLY PART OF A- CAR. THAT
I BELIEVE EDUCATORS ACROSS THE
WILL BE. ABOUT HOW DO YOU START
TO LEARN. IN A DIFFERENT WAY
GIVE THE CIRCLE. THAT WERE IN
AND AGAIN. EVERYONE AT THE CAL
COURT IN OF IT IN THE AND THE
PATH OF COURSE TO THE- DANCE
READY. TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
THE MEMBERS OF THE TWO CAN. ON
HOW THE BILL THAT WILL.
POIGNANT QUOTE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THANK YOU. THERE ARE
INSTANCES WHERE IT DOES WORK
PERFECTLY. BUT I DON'T THINK WE
CAN CLAIM THIS IS BEEN A GRAND
SUCCESS THIS HAPPENED IN A VERY
RAPID FASHION. LOGISTICS
ASSOCIATED WERE WERE HERCULEAN
AND I THINK WE'RE DOING THE
BEST WE CAN TO TRY AND MAKE IT
WORK. BUT NOT NECESSARILY
ALWAYS MAKING WORK. IT WORK AND
I THINK OF ANYONE THINK SITTING
A CHILD IN FRONT OF ANY AGE
QUITE FRANKLY. IN FRONT OF A
SCREEN FOR SIX AND A HALF HOURS
A DAY AS A FACT OF I DON'T
THINK THAT'S AFFECTED. MY TO BE
EFFECTIVE EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE
FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF LESSONS
MAYBE. CERTAIN TAX AFFECT
ACTIVITIES BUT JUST JUST TO
HAVING A CHILD STARE AT A
SCREEN IT'S PROBABLY NOT
HEALTHY. PHYSICALLY OR
MENTALLY. EMOTIONALLY BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S TERRIBLY
AFFECTED EITHER I KNOW SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE KIDS ON
ALL DAY AND I JUST. I DON'T I
DON'T SEE HOW ANYONE CAN THINK
THAT'S TERRIBLY EFFECTIVE.
THERE ARE TIMES I NEED TO BE
OFF SCREEN AND YOU KNOW
MASTERING THE CONTENT ON THEIR
OWN. WITHOUT NECESSARILY
SCREEN. INTERACTION NINE TIMES
A NEED TO BE ON- BUT WITH THAT
LET'S MOVE ON A PANEL NUMBER
TWO- AGAIN- PANEL NUMBER TWO
WILL BE ADDRESSING INTERNET
ACCESS AND THE IMPACT ON
STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS. A
REMINDER THAT WILL BE HOLDING
OUR QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END OF
THE DAY AGAIN THIS IS THE
IMPACT OF STUDENTS- ED
EDUCATORS I HAVE A LOT OF
TEACHER FRIENDS I'M A TEACHER
MYSELF I HAVE NOT TALKED.
DISTANCE LEARNING AND THEY HAVE
CALLED ME A COUPLE TIMES I'VE
HELD OFF BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
THAT TASK MASTERED. OTHERS ARE
BETTER THAN I. I SAW A LITTLE
BIT AND FALL USUALLY THIS YEAR
I'VE TAKEN A BIT OF A BREAK
BECAUSE- I MIGHT NOT BE THE
BEST ONE BEHIND THAT SCREEN. I
DON'T HAVE ALL THOSE- YOU KNOW
THE TECHNICAL STUFF MASTERED.
BUT IT'S A CHALLENGE FOR
TEACHERS TO OF PEOPLE SHOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE HOW CHALLENGING
THIS HAS BEEN. FOR TEACHERS TO
NINETY I KNOW YOU SAID THAT YES
YES. YES I JUST I JUST. I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT. LEAD TO
TOTALLY CHANGE- THE WAY THEY
DELIVER CONTENT AND THE WAITER
DAY WORKED- SO- THIS IS BEEN AN
INTERESTING VENTURE FOR ALL AND
I. I KNOW TEACHERS. WHO ARE
TRYING EVERY DAY TO MAKE THIS
BETTER- SO WE'LL GO TO AGAIN-
THE INTERNET ACCESS AND THE
IMPACT ON STUDENTS AND
EDUCATORS. I WILL BE TAKING
QUESTIONS AT THE END AGAIN OUR
FIRST BIG ROLE SPEAKER. IS
MICHEAL ROMERO HE'S THE LOCAL
DISTRICTS SOUTH SUPERINTENDENT.
FROM THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. WHO IS JOINING
US VIA REMOTE VIDEO FROM LOS
ANGELES TODAY AGAIN- MICHAEL
ROMERO YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. THEY YES THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL
CHAIRMAN SO. CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI MY
NAME IS MICHAEL ROMERO AND I'M
THE LOCAL DISTRICTS SOUTH
SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AS YOU KNOW LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED IS THE NATION'S
SECOND LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND 80% OF OUR ALMOST SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE
FROM FAMILIES LIVING IN POVERTY.
OVER SEVENTY THOUSAND OR 15% OF
OUR STUDENTS HAVE A DISABILITY.
AND APPROXIMATELY 20% OF ALL
STUDENTS ARE ENGLISH LEARNERS.
IN ADDITION MORE THAN NINETEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS AND
MORE THAN EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED LIVED IN FOSTER CARE.
WHEN SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
CLOSED IN MARCH ONE QUESTION
ROSE TO THE TOP. HOW TO PROVIDE
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE
INTERNET FOR STUDENTS WHOSE
FAMILIES COULD NOT AFFORD IT OR
DID NOT OTHERWISE HAVE ACCESS
TO IT. AT THAT TIME
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED HOUSEHOLDS
LACKED ACCESS TO STABLE
CONNECTIVITY. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED ANSWERED THAT QUESTION
IN MARCH BY CREATING A FIRST OF
ITS KIND PARTNERSHIP WITH WERE
WITH VERIZON TO PROVIDE
UNLIMITED INTERNET ACCESS AT NO
COST TO STUDENTS WHOSE FAMILIES
COULD NOT OTHERWISE AFFORD IT.
IN MAY WE MODIFIED OUR ORIGINAL
AGREEMENT WITH VERIZON TO ALLOW
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA TO PIGGY BACK ON THE
AGREEMENT. SO THEY COULD
PROVIDE INTERNET ACCESS TO
THEIR STUDENTS. THE RISE AND
FURTHER DEVELOPED AND ROLLED
OUT ITS DISTANCE LEARNING
PROGRAM ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT
IS NOW AVAILABLE TO MORE THAN
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION STUDENTS
AND FORTY STATES INCLUDING THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA. THE NEW
SCHOOL YEAR IS WELL UNDERWAY
AND ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
CONTINUES TO PROVE TO BE A
NECESSITY NOT A LUXURY.
ALLOWING STUDENTS TO CONTINUE
INSTRUCTION. STAY SOCIALLY
CONNECTED AND COMPLETE DAILY
WORK ASSIGNMENTS. ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN GIVEN A
DEVICE. INTERNET AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS AS WELL
AS SUPPORT TO REPAIR OR REPLACE
DEVICES AS NEEDED. HOT SPOTS
WHICH CAN CONNECT AS MANY AS
FIVE DEVICES AT A TIME OR
PROVIDED TO FAMILIES WITHOUT
ADEQUATE BAND WITH TO FULFILL
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS. WHO DO
NOT HAVE INTERNET CONNECTIVITY
AT HOME. LOS ANGELES UNIFIED'S
ALL HANDS ON DECK APPROACH TO
SUPPORTING STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS.
IS REFLECTED IN OUR BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS BY TEMPORARILY
GRANTING CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
THE FLEXIBILITY TO PERFORM
DUTIES IN ASSIGNMENTS OUTSIDE
THEIR CURRENT JOB DESCRIPTION.
THOSE UNABLE TO WORK IN THEIR
USUAL POSITIONS. WHILE SCHOOL
FACILITIES ARE CLOSED WILL HELP
STUDENTS ACCESS TECHNOLOGY. FOR
ONLINE LEARNING AND RECEIVE
TRAINING ON TOPICS SUCH AS ROOM
IN CUSTOMER SERVICE. FOR
EXAMPLE BUS DRIVERS ROUTE
TECHNOLOGY CALLS THROUGH OUR
HELP DESK HOTLINE. AND
TRANSPORT DEVICES TO STUDENTS.
WELL CAMPUS SEEDS AND SCHOOL
SUPERVISION AIDES ARE HELPING
TO DISTRIBUTE IN COLLECTIVE
ICE'S AND INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS. OUR SCHOOL
PRINCIPALS ARE REACHING OUT TO
STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS AND ANY
STUDENT OR FAMILY MEMBER WHO
NEED SUPPORT CAN CALL ONE OF
OUR HOTLINES OR REACH OUT TO
THEIR TEACHER OR PRINCIPAL FOR
SOME. WHILE WE PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION VIA DISTANCE
LEARNING TEACHERS WERE GIVEN
THE OPTION TO TEACH FROM HOME
OR FROM THEIR CLASSROOMS. WE
HAVE SEVERAL THOUSAND TEACHERS
OPTING TO TEACH FROM THEIR
SCHOOL SITES IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS. ALL STAFF
PARTICULARLY TEACHERS HAVE ALSO
BEEN EQUIPPED WITH DEVICES AND
ACCESS TO INTERNET WE NEEDED.
THE CHALLENGE FOR ANY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS HOW TO ADDRESS THE
LONG TERM COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THE MAINTENANCE AND REPLACEMENT
OF DEVICES ONCE THEY EXCEED
THEIR LIFESPAN AS WELL AS THE
ONGOING COST OF CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE. UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET. TODAY LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED HAS SPENT OVER ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. TO PAY
FOR THE DEVICES AND HOT SPOTS.
NOT INCLUDED IN THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AS THE COST OF
FUNDING OUR HELP DESK HOTLINE
FOR FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS. TO
ENSURE DEVICES ARE OPERATIONAL
AND STUDENTS ABLE TO LOG IN AND
SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE LEARNING
PLATFORMS. IN CONCLUSION THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO TOOLS
SCENTIAL FOR SUCCESSFUL
DISTANCE LEARNING PROGRAMS WILL
REQUIRE SUPPORT FROM PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS AND
INVESTMENT FROM THE LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS. WE ASK
FOR A LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE
SOCIAL SOLUTION TO MAINTAIN
THAT CONNECTION. A STUDENT IN
EVERY CALIFORNIA SCHOOL SHOULD
BE GIVEN THE SAME BASIC
EQUIPMENT JUST AS EVERY STUDENT
IS ENTITLED TO WALK THROUGH A
CLASSROOM DOOR AND HAVE A
TEXTBOOK. TWEET QUIP EVERY
STUDENT ACROSS THE STATE WITH A
DEVICE AND INTERNET THE ANNUAL
COST WOULD BE ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
TO SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
I URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENTS DIGITAL
DIVIDE TASK FORCE. TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES FOR A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE SO THAT
SCHOOLS CAN GET ON WITH THE
BUSINESS OF TEACHING AND
LEARNING. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS NO ONE SINGLE ANSWER
OR SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. DUE TO THE
COMPLEX NATURE OF INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY AND IT'S FUNDING
MECHANISMS. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT A SUCCESSFUL SOLUTION MUST
INCLUDE ACTIVE PARTICIPATION
AND COMMITMENT FROM LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER ON EXISTING AND NEW
EFFORTS TO COME UP WITH A
SUSTAINABLE PLAN TO MAKE
CONNECTIVITY FREE AND
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERY STUDENT AND
FAMILY ACROSS THE STATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SUPERINTENDENT
ROMERO OUR OUR NEXT SPEAKER
WILL BE- ANGELES DE GAULLE
PRESIDENT OF THE MERITORIOUS OF
HIGH TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER FROM
AMERICA'S VILLE JOINT UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT. MYSTIKAL
IS IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM INSIDE THE CAPITOL TODAY
YOU MAY RECEIVE ALREADY. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS ANGELA
STABLE. FOR ME TEACHING IS NOT
MERELY A JOB IT IS A PASSION
ONE THAT I SHARE WITH OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATORS ACROSS
THE STATE. I'M IN MY TWENTY
THIRD YEAR OF MARRIAGE HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE I TEACH ENGLISH.
COACH OUR CHAMPIONSHIP ACTIVITY
KATHLYN TEAM AND SERVICE CO
CHAIRPERSON OF THE ENGLISH
DEPARTMENT. I SERVICE PRESIDENT
OF LOW TEACHERS. THE MERRY'S
WILL UNIFY TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WHERE I AM ALSO ON THE
BARGAINING TEAM. ADDITIONALLY
I'VE BEEN WITH THE
INSTRUCTIONAL LEADERSHIP COURSE
SINCE ITS INCEPTION. GIVEN
THESE VERY ROLES I HAVE A
UNIQUE MULTI FACETED
PERSPECTIVE ON THE ISSUES OF
STUDENT INTERNET ACCESS. MY
STUDENTS AND I HAIL FROM YUBA
COUNTY WITH A POPULATION OF
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. WITH A MEDIAN ANNUAL
HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS SLIGHTLY
LESS THAN FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHICH IS ABOUT NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS BEHIND THE
STATE AVERAGE. AND AT LEAST 80%
OF OUR RESIDENTS LIVE BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE. MARYSVILLE JOINT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IS HOME
TO APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
AMAZING STUDENTS. NEARLY 22% OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND OVER 80%
OF OUR CHILDREN ARE SOCIAL
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED AND
OVER 12% OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. OUR DISTRICT RUNS
FROM ELEVATION OF SOME FIVE
THOUSAND FEET DOWN TO THE
VALLEY FLOOR. AND SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS RIDE THE BUS OVER AN
HOUR ONE WAY. OUR LARGEST
ETHNIC GROUPS ARE HISPANIC
LATINO AT APPROXIMATELY 43% OF
OUR STUDENT POPULATION. AND
WHITE AT APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
SIX PERCENT. HOWEVER THAT
VARIES WIDELY FROM SITE TO SITE.
IF YOU BRING UP INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY OF MY STUDENTS
THEY WILL TELL YOU THE STRUGGLE
IS REAL. AND IF YOU ASK
TEACHERS IN MY DISTRICT THEY
WILL ECHO THE SENTIMENT. ONE OF
THE MANY REASONS FOR THIS IS
THE FACT THAT MY STUDENTS FALL
INTO ONE OF THREE DISTINCTLY
DIFFERENT GROUPS. THOSE THAT
HAVE FULL INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY. THOSE THAT HAVE
PROBLEMATIC OR MINIMAL INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY. AND THOSE WHO
LACK THE INTERNET COMPLETELY. A
NUMBER OF OUR TEACHERS ALSO
EXPERIENCE A COMPLETE ABSENCE
OF OR POOR INTERNET SERVICE AT
HOME. ADDITIONALLY THE TIME
REQUIRED TO PREP FOR AND
PROVIDE ALL ASPECTS OF DISTANCE
LEARNING. INCLUDING ONLINE
ENGAGEMENT STRATEGIES IN A
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING. IS
EXPONENTIALLY GREATER THAN WHAT
IS NECESSARY FOR OUR REGULAR
CLASSES. FOR EXAMPLE OUR
STUDENTS VERY LEVELS OF
CONNECTIVITY MAKE IT
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT TO
GAUGE HOW LONG IT WILL TAKE
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE LESSONS OR
ASSIGNMENTS. ALTHOUGH MY
STUDENTS ARE RESILIENT THEIR
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY ISSUES
ARE IMPEDING THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCESS AND PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
DISTANCE LEARNING. LEARNING
THAT I IN NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
OTHERS ARE TIRELESSLY TRYING TO
PROVIDE FOR THEM. RECENTLY ONE
OF MY STUDENTS ASK FOR AN
EXTENSION ON AN ASSIGNMENT. SHE
EXPLAINED IN A LENGTHY ON
PUNCTUATED A MOTIONAL EMAIL
THAT HER INTERNET DIED. AFTER
AN APPEARANCE BY THE BLUE
CIRCLE OF DEATH AS SHE TRIED TO
SENATOR SIMON ONLINE AND THEN
IT WAS GONE. AS SHE EXPLAINED.
GONE STEEG JUST GONE GONE LIKE
HOMEMADE COOKIES LEFT ON THE
COUNTER. AFTER WE WORKED FOR
OVER AN HOUR TO UNSUCCESSFULLY
FINE- ASSIGNMENT SHE DEJECTEDLY
MATTERED THAT SHE WOULD DO THE
ASSIGNMENT AGAIN. WHICH I DID
NOT REQUIRE HER TO DO.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH THIS
SITUATION IS NOT AN ANOMALY.
ONE OF THE MORE TRYING ASPECTS
OF OUR DISTANCE LEARNING HAS
INVOLVED VIDEO CONFERENCING I
HAVE STUDENTS WHO SPEND MORE
TIME TRYING TO JOIN OR STAY IN
HIS ROOM SESSION THEN THEY
ACTUALLY SPEND IN THAT SESSION.
IN MY EMAIL YOU CAN FIND
VARIATIONS OF SORRY ABOUT THE
ZOOM BUT MY INTERNET HATES ME.
IT IS NOT UNUSUAL FOR SOME OF
MY STUDENTS TO HAVE TO RE ENTER
SESSION MULTIPLE TIMES. MISSING
OUT ON VALUABLE LEARNING TIME
IN THE PROCESS. UNFORTUNATELY
ZOOM SITUATION ISN'T RESERVED
JUST FOR STUDENTS. TWO WEEKS
AGO I WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
SENTENCE IN A RIVETING CLASS
DISCUSSION AND THE SCHOOL Y.
FIVE JUST QUIT. I WAS FINALLY
ABLE TO RECONNECT WITH MY CLASS
ON THE RESUME. JUST AS MY VICE
PRINCIPAL WALKED IN AND ASKED
IF I WAS OK. ONE OF MY STUDENTS
HAD ACTUALLY CALLED THE SCHOOL
CONCERNED ABOUT ME. WE LOST
APPROXIMATELY TEN MINUTES OF
PRECIOUS CLASS TIME AND
STUDENTS ARE FREQUENTLY LOSING
TEN MINUTES OF MULTIPLE
CLASSROOMS OR WHOLE CLASS
PERIODS OR EVEN WHOLE DAYS OF
INSTRUCTION DO A POOR INTERNET
CONNECTION. OR WORSE MISSING
OUT ON DISTANCE LEARNING
ENTIRELY DUE TO NO INTERNET AT
ALL. AND PROMISES TO REMEDY THE
SITUATION IN TWO MONTHS OR TWO
YEARS OR MORE OUR FRANKLY
UNACCEPTABLE. SOME MAY THINK
BUT WHAT ABOUT ALL THE HOT
SPOTS GIVEN TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
MY DISTRICT RECEIVED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY OF THOSE HOT
SPOTS AND PURCHASED ANOTHER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE IN A FULL
PRESS EFFORT TO HELP OUR
STUDENTS. AS MY FOOT HILL
STUDENTS HAVE EXPLAINED TO ME.
I'M ON MY THIRD HOT SPOT AND
KEEPING MY FINGERS CROSSED IT
DOES THE TRICK. OR I'M WAITING
ON A LIST FOR THE RIGHT HOT
SPOT. OUR FOOT HILLS ARE
COVERED BY CELL TOWERS FROM
THREE MAJOR TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES. SO IT'S LIKE A
TWISTED GAME OF HOT AND COLD
WHEN OUR STUDENTS TRY TO OBTIN
INTERNET SERVICE. AND WHEN IT'S
DETERMINED THAT THEIR HOUSES TO
COLD IN RELATION TO A CELL
TOWER. THERE THEN FORCED PURSUE
SATELLITE POINT TO POINT FOR
INTERNET. FOR SOME OF MY
STUDENTS THEIR SATELLITE LINE
RUNS FROM THE TOP OF THE TREE
TO THEIR HOME. I ALSO HAVE
STUDENTS WHO COULD WIN THE
LOTTERY TODAY AND NOT BE ABLE
TO GET INTERNET ACCESS TOMORROW
BECAUSE IT SIMPLY DOESN'T EXIST
WHERE THEY LIVE. THESE CAN
ACTIVITY ISSUES RESULT IN
TROUBLING EQUITY ISSUES AND
THESE EQUITY ISSUES ARE FELT
EVEN MORE PROFOUNDLY ARE
VULNERABLE SPECIAL EDUCATION.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNER FOSTER
YOUTH AND HOMELESS STUDENT
POPULATION. ALL OF WHICH FLIES
IN THE FACE OF WHAT WE KNOW
SHOULD BE TRUE AND WHAT WE
DESPERATELY WANT TO BE TRUE.
THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION. I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT THE HOME OF THE WORLD'S
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY AS WELL
AS THREE OF THE FIVE TECH
GIANTS. ALONG WITH NEARLY
NINETY INTERNET PROVIDERS CAN
BRING RELIABLE HIGH SPEED
INTERNET ONCE AND FOR ALL TO
ALL OF MY STUDENTS. AND ALL OF
THE OVER SIX MILLION STUDENTS
IN THIS GOLDEN STATE.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ZIP CODE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR SPIEGEL
VERY GOOD JOB- WILL NOW PROCEED
TO- ERIN APTI REPRESENTING THE
EQUITY COALITION MISHAP D. AS
IN THE VIDEO CONCERT OR IN
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM INSIDE
THE CAPITOL- MISHAPS YOU MAY
PROCEED ONE READY. HELLO MY
NAME IS ERIN ATTY I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE VIEWS OF
THE ALTHEA FAST EQUITY
COALITION I WORK A PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IS LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME TODAY TO TALK ABOUT OUR WORK
ON THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
INEQUITIES IN ACCESS TO
INTERNET SERVICE AND TECHNOLOGY
EXISTED FOR CHILDREN IN POVERTY
AND CHILDREN OF COLOR LONG
BEFORE BECAUSE I THINK. AT THE
START OF THIS CRISIS ONE IN
FIVE. SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN LACK
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AT HOME.
WE APPLAUD THE ADMINISTRATION
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE AND
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN'S.
DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK FORCE FOR
WORKING TOWARD SUSTAINABLE SO.
TO ADDRESS AN ACT. WE BELIEVE
THAT BUILDING A DIGITAL
INTEREST AND CLOSING THE DOOR
IS A STATE OR- AND NOT JUST AN
IMPERATIVE FOR SCHOOL. HOW A
DEVICE IN A RELIABLE INTERNET
CONNECTION IS NOT FUNDAMENTAL
FOR EVERY STUDENT TO RECEIVE A
QUALITY PUBLIC EDUCATION THAT
IS THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE MADE IT
CLEAR IN THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THE DAILY AS MUST PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH ACCESS TO DEVICES
AND CONNECTIVITY WHEN
DELIVERING DISTANCE LEARNING.
IN ADDITION TO TRYING THIS
YEAR'S FUNDING TO UNIVERSAL
STUDENT HAVE TO PASS TO A
LAPTOP AND THE INTERNET. FTA
TWENTY THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
FRANCE LAST MONTH. ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT ACCESS TO
DEVICES AND CONNECTIVITY IS NOT
PERMANENT I'M GOING TO STUDY.
FOR ALL STUDENTS BY MAKING THEM
A PART OF THE DEFINITION OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS. IN OUR
EDUCATION BECAUSE- THIS CHANGE
INTERFAX IN IMPORTANT WAYS TO
THE LANDMARK WILLIAM SETTLEMENT
LEGISLATION. THAT AMONG OTHER
THINGS THAT THE MINIMUM
STANDARDS THAT ALL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO
TEXTBOOKS. AND INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS TO USE IN CLASS AND
TO TAKE HOME. THE WILLIAMS
VERSUS CALIFORNIA CASE WAS
FILED JUST OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO BY THE ACLU PUBLIC
ADVOCATES ANOTHER. CHALLENGING
TO SEPARATE AND UNEQUAL
CONDITIONS THAT EXISTED IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. INCLUDING
INADEQUATE ACCESS TO TEXTBOOKS
FOR SO MANY LOW INCOME. BLACK
LAND NEXT AN ENGLISH LEARNERS.
TODAY THE DEMANDS OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THE EVER INCREASING
USE OF DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY ONLY
UNDERSCORE THE WISDOM OF THE
LEGISLATURE UPDATE TO THE
DEFINITION OF INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS. TO INCLUDE LAPTOPS
AND INTERNET ACCESS. THIS THAT
THE HAS THE FOLLOWING IMPORTANT
AND IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON THE
WILLIAMS ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
SUFFICIENT STRUCTURAL MATERIALS.
ONE ALL DISTRICTS EXCUSE ME ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MUST THE FACT
AND PUBLICLY REPORTING CORRECT
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIAL
INSUFFICIENCIES. INCLUDING OUR
LACK OF ACCESS TO DEVICES AND
CONNECTIVITY BY THE EIGHTH WEEK
OF SCHOOL. CHINESE THE GRANT
TENANTS WILL SURVEY ALL SCHOOLS
ON THE WILLIAMS INSPECTION LAST.
CURRENTLY ABOUT ONE QUARTER
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE AND I IN.
AND BOOK AND STUFF MATERIALS
INCLUDING DIGITAL ACCESS. THAT
ARE NOT CORRECTED WITHIN THE
FIRST TWO MONTHS OF THE YEAR SO
THAT THESE MATERIALS TO BE
PURCHASED FOR STUDENTS BY THE
STATE ON THE DISTRICTS ACCOUNT.
THREE WILLIAMS COMPLAINTS
REGARDING INSUFFICIENT
STRUCTURAL MATERIALS NOW
INCLUDE LAPTOPS AND
CONNECTIVITY. AND LASTLY ELLIE
IS OVER FOR AN INSUFFICIENCY OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS.
INCLUDING DEVICES THE
CONNECTIVITY. IN NOVEMBER
SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT ALL USING
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION BE
AWARE UP AND WORK TO IMPLEMENT
THESE PROVISIONS IMMEDIATELY.
RIGHT RECENT EFFORTS WE KNOW
THE PHYSICAL PROCESS.
ANECDOTALLY WE HONOR EQUITY I
HEARING FOR THE CENTRAL HAS
SOME OF THE GREATEST NEED. SOME
DISTRICTS ARE OFFERING WIFI IN
THE DISTRICT PARKING LOT FOR
STUDENTS WHO LACK AN ACTIVITY.
SOME FAMILIES ARE SENDING THEIR
CHILDREN TO VISIT RELATIVES IN
MEXICO AFTER STABLE INTERNET
NECESSARY FOR INSTRUCTION. AND
MANY STUDENTS ARE RESORTING TO
MOBILE PHONES HOT SPOT. WHICH
LACK ACCESS TO CAPACITY TO RUN
VIDEO AND OTHER INSTRUCTIONAL
SUPPORT. OR THEY ARE USING
THEIR CELL PHONES ACCESS
CLASSES BECAUSE THEY LACK
ACCESS TO A DEVICE. HERE IN
SACRAMENTO STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
LIVING IN MOTELS HI THERE WIFI
TURNED OFF REMOTE OFF DOCTOR IN
THE DAY. TO DISSUADE THEM FROM
DOING DISTANCE LEARNING ON SITE.
IF CHALLENGES ARE COMPOUNDED
FOR STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
NEEDS SUCH AS STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND FOSTER YOU. YEAH CRITICAL
LISTENING HEARD OF POLICYMAKERS
TO TAKE A MULTI FACETED
APPROACH TO ADDRESS THESE
CRITICAL CONCERNS AND PROVIDES
THE FOLLOWING RECOMMENDATIONS.
SHANKLIN MONITORING OF DIGITAL
ACCESS DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES
MUST EXPAND A WILLIAMS
PROFICIENCY HEARINGS AND
INSPECTIONS TO CHECK FOR ACCESS
TO DEVICES INFECTIVITY.
RESTAURANTS GIVE ME A SEVERANCE
MUST CONSIDER THAT EVEN WHEN
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO A
DEVICE IN THE HOT SPOT THEY MAY
LACK THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT
NEEDED TO INITIATE OR SUSTAIN
ACCESS. WE RECOMMEND OF THE
STATE ABOUT THE STANDARD SET OF
QUESTIONS. FOR LDS PAST UNIONS
AND FAMILIES AND FOR COUNTY
STAFF SCHOOLS O DETERMINE THE
BLT IS PROVIDING. ACCESS TO
DEVICES ON A ONE TO ONE BASIS.
CONSISTENT CONNECTIVITY WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE REGULARLY
CHECKING IN WITH STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES. TO A FASTER ACCESS.
TECHNOLOGIES FOR STUDENTS AND
PARENTS INCLUDING A STUDENTS
HOME LANGUAGE. AND SUPPORT TO
ADDRESS LEARNING THE BASIC
NEEDS SUCH AS PROVIDING
HEADPHONES. STOP CANCEL OUT
EXCESSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL NOISE.
IF YOU PART OF THE PROTOCOL FOR
ABSENT STUDENTS RE ENGAGEMENT
REQUIRED BY THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL SHOULD INCLUDE ASSESSING
INTERNET ACCESS STRENGTH AND
RELIABILITY OF CONNECTION AND
ADDRESSING BARRIERS AND
DEFICIENCIES. WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THE DISTRICTS HAVE A CLEAR
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS LOST
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME DUE TO
INADEQUATE INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY. THIS COULD
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE A REQUIRED
STATE POLICY OF RECORDING AND
POSTING LAUGHTER. FINALLY GIVEN
THE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS. THE
FAMILIES OF ENGLISH LEARNERS
FACE WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
ELOISE TO USE MULTI. LINGUAL
TECHNOLOGY BUT A LOT OF
LEGISLATORS TO TRANSLATE
INFORMATION TO MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. COMMUNICATING WITH
FAMILIES AND DIGITAL FOR. TODAY
HAVING A DEVICE AND ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET AS A FUNDAMENTAL
TO LEARNING AS THE TOP WHAT WAS
IN THE NINETEENTH CENTURY. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO CLOSE THE CONNECTIVITY
GAP ONCE AND FOR ALL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO OUR TO ALL OF OUR
THREE PRISONERS NOW ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISS SMITH. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WILL BE BRIEF I
JUST LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT I
THINK WE WOULD BE REMISS IF WE
DIDN'T ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
OUR EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONALS
WHO ARE PART OF THIS LAST PANEL
IN THE LEADERSHIP THEY AND
OTHER LEADERS AND OUR TEACHERS
ACROSS THE STATE- HAVE SHOWN
AND DEMONSTRATED DURING THIS
CRISIS ALL OF OUR TEACHERS ALL
OF OUR ADMINISTRATORS HAVE
STEPPED UP BEEN CREATIVE
ADDRESS THIS MOMENT TRIED TO
MEET THE CHALLENGES OF THIS
MOMENT IN EVERY WAY POSSIBLE ON
BEHALF OF OUR STUDENTS AND-
THEY DESERVE THAT RECOGNITION
STATEWIDE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER. SMITH VERY VERY TRUE
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU
SIMILAR MEMBERS WITH BRINGING
THAT UP THOSE ABSOLUTELY UP
SPOT ON REAL QUICK LIKE WHAT
ARE SOME OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DURING TO SUPPORT DISTANCE
LEARNING NEEDS OF MIGRANT
STUDENTS AND HAVE ANY MIGRANT
STUDENT PROGRAMS BEEN ABLE TO
TRANSITION SUCCESSFULLY TO
DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL. WHAT
WAS THAT PER PARTICULAR. DOES
ANYONE WANT TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION ON. LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
A. SHE SHE MAY BE SPEAKING BUT
WE CANNOT HEAR HER. APOLOGIES I
THOUGHT. OF IT WE ARE FACTORED
IN ACTIVITIES YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION YES I AM THE
WE HAVE A GREAT EXAMPLE OUT OF
MENDOTA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHERE TEACHERS RECOGNIZE THAT
PRIORITIZING RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING AND COMMUNICATION
PARTICULARLY FOR NEWCOMER
MARKET STUDENTS IS ESSENTIAL
FOR THE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
TO BE SUCCESSFUL DIGITAL
LEARNING. FUTURE TO MADONNA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT MET
WITH NEWCOMER IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES AT
THE START OF THE SCHOOL YEAR
WITHIN THE VERY FIRST THREE
WEEKS OF SCHOOL TO ESTABLISH
OPEN LINES OF COMMUNICATION.
SHOULD YOUR NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO
PROVIDE TECHNOLOGY TRAINING
INCLUDING. TROUBLESHOOTING ON.
OR I'M A MENTAL IS THE
CALIFORNIA AT A WEALTHY BRAND
FUNDED READY WAS IS WORKING
SPECIFIC WITH NEW CAR MARKET
FAMILIES HE SAID STUDENTS
IMPAIR A PRIEST THERE HAS CALL
AND THAT HAS TO BE WITH
FAMILIES AND MEET THEM WHERE
THEY AT BUT IT'S REALLY THAT
YOU OUR NEEDS IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO ASSIST THEM WITH
NAVIGATING THIS COMPLICATED
ONLINE ORDER FORMS AS THEY CAN
BEFORE IT PARTICULARLY. FOR NEW.
THEY YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER. THIS PERSON YET I DO
HAVE A QUESTION AND YOU KNOW
THE CHAIRMAN OF- COMMUNICATIONS
BROUGHT UP SOME OF THE PERSONAL
HARDSHIPS THAT HE'S
EXPERIENCED- THE ISSUE OF-
PARENTS AND THE TECHNOLOGY.
TRANSLATION TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE HAPPENING I'M WONDERING IF
ANY OF THE FOLKS THAT PROVIDED
TESTIMONY- CAN I SHARE ANY
THOUGHTS ANNIE- EXPERIENCES
THAT THEY'VE- SEEN WITH SOME OF
THE- PARENTS- THERE ARE WORKING
WITH THE STUDENTS FROM HOME-
ARE HOW THEY'RE ENGAGING THEM
YOU KNOW WE HAVE. MEMBERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY THAT- I'VE NEVER
HAD THE TECHNOLOGY- THAT THIS
IS VERY NEW AND THEY'RE HAVING
TO ALSO LEARN AS THEY GO WITH
THEIR STUDENTS NOT TO MENTION
THE- LANGUAGE- A BARRIER IN
SOME INSTANCES AS WELL SO I'M
WONDERING IF WHETHER. SOMEONE
FROM THE VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR THE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION OR FOR THAT MTTER
AT THE EQUITY COALITION WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME INPUT
ON- SOME EXPERIENCES AND OR
BEST PRACTICE MODELS THAT ARE
HAPPENING ALONG THE WAY- AS
WE'RE DEALING WITH IS
TECHNOLOGY DIGITAL DIVIDE.
ISSUE THANK YOU. READ A SUPER
TENDER AMERICA. GOOD HAND UP
OVER HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT THE CALL. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION YES- SO
THE COMMENTS ABOUT THIS NOT
BEING PERFECT AND IT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING AND ESPECIALLY. FOR
OUR FAMILIES THAT OUR MOST
IMPOVERISHED ABSOLUTELY-
THERE'S BEEN SOME REAL
CHALLENGES WITH THAT- LAST
SEMESTER MARCH WHEN WE CLOSE
SCHOOLS THROUGH JUNE THERE'S A
LOT OF PRACTICING A LOT OF.
PLANNING FAST ACTING FAST AND
FIXING FIXING FAST. AND HOW WE
UNIFIED THE SUMMER WE OPENED UP
SUMMER SCHOOL FOR ALL STUDENTS-
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER IN MY
LOCAL DISTRICT A THIRD OF OUR
FAMILIES AND STUDENTS TOOK US
UP ON THAT ON THAT- OPTION. IT
WAS ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
CONNECT WITHFAMILIES AND NOT
TO HAVE TON HALL MEETINGS AND
TUTORIAL SESSIONS AND JOB AIDS.
SO THE LEARNING FROM LAST
SEMESTER THIS SUMMER PEROTIS A
PREPAREDNESS TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY TWO WEEKS PRIOR TO
THE START OF THE SCHOOL YEAR.
WE STARTED AUGUST EIGHTEENTH SO
WHAT WE DID ACROSS THE DISTRICT
AND ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS WE HAD
SYSTEMATIC TOWN HALL MEETINGS.
WE HAD JOB AIDS AT A DIFFERENT
LEVEL. WE HAD HELP HELP LINES.
AT A DIFFERENT LEVEL. STILL
PROBABLY EVEN TO THE STATE NOT
ENOUGH WE CAN GET BETTER WE
HAVE TO GET BETTER- TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS. BUT WE FELT THAT
THAT. THE WORK THAT WE DID IN
PREPARING OUR PARENTS. WITH Q.
R. CODES AND- THE HELP DESK
AND- THE ALMOST LIKE A DRUMBEAT
OF CORRESPONDENCE TO PARENTS
VIA EMAIL CONNECTED MESSAGES.
TEXTING EVEN U. S. MAIL LETTERS.
HELP THOSE QUITE A BIT IN A IN
A FAIRLY SMOOTH OPENING. BUT IT
DIDN'T MEAN ALL KIDS WERE
CONNECTED WE STILL- EVEN TILL
THIS DAY- THERE OR OR SELECTED
THEIR HOMELESS. IDENTIFIED
HOMELESS STUDENTS IN EACH OF
OUR SCHOOLS SMALL NUMBERS THAT
WE STILL HAVEN'T CONNECTED
WITH- WE BELIEVE AT THIS POINT
THAT THEY HAVE THE FAMILIES
PROBABLY MOVED OUT OF THE AREA-
WE EVEN TO THE- TO THE QUESTION
PRIOR ABOUT MATT MIGRANT YOUTH
AND FAMILIES AND HOMELESS AND
FOSTER YOUTH. WE WORK BUT WAS
LIKE A BEELINE WE KNEW THAT
WHEN WE OPEN SCHOOL AUGUST
EIGHTEENTH. THAT THE FAMILIES
THAT WOULD MOST STRUGGLE TO
STILL CONNECT WOULD BE A
HOMELESS OR FOSTER YOUTH.
EARNER UARDIAN OF THE MIGRANT-
ARE MIGRANT FAMILIES- IN OUR
MOST IMPOVERISHED FAMILIES SO
WHAT WE DID. THEY ALL GONNA U.
S. MAIL LETTER SAYING.
TECHSTERS COLAS GO TO THIS
WEBSITE. WE FOLLOWED UP WITH
EMAILS WE FOLLOWED UP WITH TEXT
MESSAGES AND THEN WHEN WE FELT
IT WAS SAFE JUST RECENTLY WE
STARTED KNOCKING ON DOORS. SO
WE DID IDENTIFY QUITE A FEW
KIDS BUT IT'S NOT PERFECT AND
WE STILL HAVE SOME HOMELESS
FAMILIES THAT WERE CONCERNED WE
JUST HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
REACH- IT'S WE'RE CONTINUOUSLY
IT'S ALMOST A DAILY WEEKLY
IMPROVEMENTS AND TRYING TO GET
BETTER- TO CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO'S
COMMENTS- WHAT WE CAN DO WITH
PARENT. TRAININGS AND WORKSHOPS.
WE CAN GET BETTER AND WE HAVE
TO GET BETTER FAST AND
PERSONALIZING AND ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR MOST IMPOVERISHED
PARENTS AND PARENTS. OF KIDS-
YOU KNOW A SECOND LANGUAGE
LEARNERS- SO THAT'S ALWAYS
WEIRD WE'RE TRYING TO GET
BETTER WERE MVING QUICKLY- TO
THE BEST OF OUR ABILITIES BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK IN FRONT
OF US ARE STILL IT'S NOT
PERFECT AND IT'S NOT BUTTONED
UP IN SOME AREAS. EVEN WHEN I
SHARED THE L. A. UNIFIED WERE
VERY PROBLEM WELL OUR PRINTS
ARE PRINCIPALS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS OR
HER ROLE LIKE. IN HOW WE
DISTRIBUTED DEVICES TO ALMOST
1100% OF OUR KIDS WAS LITERALLY
LIKE NINETY NINE POINT NINE
INCLUDING THE HOT SPOT. BUT
STILL DALY FAMILIES STILL
STRUGGLE THINGS GO WRONG WITH
THE HOT SPOT WE GOT TO REPLACE
THEY GOT TO BRING IT IN. IT'S
NOT AS SMOOTH AS WE WOULD LIKE
IT'S STILL- BUT THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU A SUPER
GENERAL FOR THAT RESPONSE AND
WE SHOULD I SHOULD KNOW THAT.
ALONG WITH ALL THE LOGISTICS
ASSOCIATED WITH GOING A
DISTANCE LEARNING IN A VERY
RAPID FASHION BACK IN MARCH. LA
UNIFIED OPEN PROBABLY. PROBABLY
ONE OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST
ESSENTIALLY SOUP KITCHENS AND
THEY FED THE COMMUNITY. NOT
JUST STUDENTS. AND DID THAT
AND- IN A VERY EXPEDITIOUS AND
EFFICIENT. AND FAIR FASHION SO
CONGRATULATIONS TO. TO LA
UNIFIED- IT WITH THAT I MISS
COOK SILVA. I THANK YOU FOR THE
PANELISTS I DO WANT TO READ
SOMETHING IT IS OF MY FRIENDS
TECH A FACEBOOK MESSAGE SHE'S
BEEN A TEACHER AND FULLER TEN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR.
MANY MANY YEARS AND- AS I NOTED
THAT THE FULLER TO ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND OTHERS AN
ORANGE COUNTY STARTED A HYBRID
MODEL- JUST YESTERDAY SO. SHE'S
CALLING- YESTERDAY HER FIRST
DAY OF SCHOOL BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH SHE'S BEEN DISTANCE
LEARNING. AS OF YESTERDAY THEY
STARTED BRINGING SOME STUDENTS
IN THE CLASS AND THEN THEY
STILL HAVE THEIR- STUDENTS WHO
ARE DOING DISTANCE LEARNING SO.
IT'S ABOUT THREE PARAGRAPHS BUT
BUT I THINK IT PAINS OF THE
PICTURE. OF WHAT A CHALLENGE IT
IS BUT ALSO OF WHAT GREAT
EDUCATORS WE HAVE OUT THERE WHO
ARE. IN ESSENCE LEARNING ALONG
WITH THE STUDENTS AND HAVING TO
MAKE ACCOMMODATIONS AND WHAT
THE CHALLENGES AND SOME OF THE
PARENTS HAVE SEEN THAT
THEMSELVES AS THEY SIT NEXT TO
THEIR STUDENTS. AT HOME DOING
REMOTE LEARNING. SO SHE'S THE
FIRST DAY OF SCHOOL UPDATE WE
HAVE TO TOTALLY OVER PLAN TO
KEEP THIS GOING I CREATE AN
ENTIRE SLIDE DECK WITH
EVERYTHING I NEED THE LINK. SO
I DON'T HAVE TO GO LOOKING I
READ IT ALL THE ONES I HAD
WORKED FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
AND OF COURSE I HAD ONCE LIKE
MISSING. THE RECESSED COUNTDOWN
CLOCK NO WORRIES I FOUND IT
EASILY. I HAVE A STUDENT THAT
KEEPS A TALLY MARK OF ALL MY
DAILY MISTAKES SO GETTING
TEACHERS ARE LEARNING AND
THINGS ARE GOING. TO GO WRONG.
SO WE ALL GET A GOOD OUT OF IT.
I HAVE TWO COMPUTERS AN IPAD
AND A BIG SCREEN TV I ALSO HAVE
A BLUETOOTH MICROPHONE THAT
CONNECTS TO MY RUMORS AND BLAST
OUT TO MIKE IN CLASS KIDS. I
NEED TO FIGURE OUT THE SOUND
THING WHEN I PLAY VIDEO IF I GO
THROUGH THE COMPUTER IT IS TOO
QUIET FOR THE CLASS AND IF I GO
THROUGH THE TV. IT IS TOO QUIET
FOR MY ZIMMER'S. HI I KNOW
THERE IS A SINGLE SOLUTION
THOUGH ARTEX SUPERHERO WEST
CRESOL CAME OUT CRUISING
THROUGH NOT ONCE BUT TWICE
PERFECT TIMING. WE ALSO HAD A
VISITOR AND THE KIDS IN THE
CLASSROOM WERE SO EXCITED I
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GIVE
EQUAL ATTENTION TO THIS RUMORS
AND THE IN CLASS KIDS. ARE
EIGHT P. OWNS THE BOOK I WAS
TRYING TO SHOW BY VIDEO SO I'M
GOING TO READ IT ALIVE TODAY
HER RATE SHISA ELEMENTARY
CLASSROOM TEACHER WITH K.
THROUGH THREE. I LIKE THAT
BETTER ANY NOW I HAVE TO
CONSTANTLY REMIND US ALL OF US
OF THE SIX FOOT RULE MYSELF
INCLUDED I REALLY JUST WANT TO
HUG THEM ALL AS ONE OF MY
LITTLE DARLING SAID AT ONE
POINT PARAPHRASE. IT DOESN'T
MATTER IT'S JUST NICE TO BE
TOGETHER AGAIN. SHE IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT AS LONG AS
WE ARE TOGETHER WE WILL MAKE.
IT WORK AFTER SCHOOL WE HAD OUR
FIRST SPEECH AND DEBATE
TOURNAMENT TOO WHICH HAD ME
WORKING UNTIL AFTER SEVEN PM. I
MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE HAD AN
ADULT BEVERAGE AFTER ALL OF
THAT AND PASSED OUT BEFORE NINE
PM LET'S SEE WHAT DAY TWO
BRINGS BUT AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE- TEACHERS
PARENTS. AND THE STUDENTS WHO
WERE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AND
WE'RE LEARNING FROM ALL OF EACH
ALL OF US THANK YOU. MR
SANTIAGO. THANK YOU AND TAKING
THE SCRIPT SO THAT THE GUY WAS
HEART WARMING TO SEE THE OTHER
SIDE OF IT AND NO DOUBT NO
DOUBT THAT WE KNOW THE TEACHERS
ARE HAVING A HARD TIME JUST
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE. I DON'T
THINK THERE'S A- AS A PERSON
THE ROOM WHO WOULDN'T SAY THAT
WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER BUT-
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO.
RAISE BACK UP THE ISSUE THAT I
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER BECAUSE
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT. SOME%
OF THE COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT-
IN THE BEEN WRITTEN ABOUT OVER
AND OVER WITH EMILY. L. A. U.
S. T. AREA WE HAVE THE LOWEST-
SOME OF THOSE CONNECTION RATES
WE ALSO HAVE TO ADMIT WHETHER
RELEASED THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
BUT SOME OF THE MOST- A LOWER
INCOME FOLKS WHAT WITHIN THE
AREAS OF NOT BEING CONNECTED.
IN SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WHEN
IT COMES TO ENGLISH- IS A
SECOND LANGUAGE- IN THE ABILITY
TO HAVE. A SPACE- TO DO THE
WORK- THIS TOO REQUIRES- IN
SEOUL. I GUESS MY QUESTION
BECOMES. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING TO. CREATE THOSE
PASSED BY TEAM FOR THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS. THAT ARE
WOEFULLY BEHIND. AND NEED THAT
SORT OF HELP BECAUSE- I. I
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE. BUT WHEN WE
TALKED OUR CONSTITUENTS- THE
GOOD WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE
HASN'T ARRIVED ALL THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SOME OF THE
NEIGHBORS I REPRESENT ARE SOME
OF THOSE THAT ARE LEFT BEHIND-
AND I'D LIKE TO MAYBE PULL THAT
YOU'RE NOT ANSWER NOW BUT I
WANT TO POSE THAT QUESTION
THANK WHICH AND I POSED THE
PAST THAT WE KNOW ALL THESE
THINGS ARE OUT THERE. WHAT SORT
OF INVESTMENTS. ARE GONNA BE
DONE IMMEDIATELY WITHIN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS. BECAUSE IT'S
ALMOST EIGHT MONTHS LATER- AND-
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE
BEGINNING BUT EIGHT MONTHS
LATER WE KNOW AND. I MEAN I I'M
WERE COMMITTEE HEARINGS I
HAVEN'T FILLED FROM BEING A
MORE TEMPERED MY LANGUAGE AND I
AND I UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES
BEFORE US AB BUT WHEN WE TALK
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND WE
CAN'T WAIT ANOTHER DAY. I TELL
THESE BEGIN TO CUT BILL THAT
SORT OF SENSE OF URGENCY AND I
KNOW IT'S THERE I KNOW IT'S
THERE WE WANT TO PARTNER WITH
YOU. SO ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT WE CAN. WE CAN WORK ON
THAT TO GET THOSE AREAS
ADAPTIVE YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FOR EXAMPLE THE PAPER- ONE OF
PRIME. HELLO SORRY MY MASK IT'S
GOOD STUFF ANYMORE A PRIVATE
PAPERS WITH. OUR REGION THE
ONLY TIME. WHEN EVER. A STORY
ARISES ABOUT THE- THE INCOME
INEQUALITIES IN. AS EARLY AND
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE US AS IT
RELATES TO EDUCATION. MOST OF
THE COUPLE KISSED. ON THE SIDE.
FIVE MONTHS LATER. HOW REGULAR
STRIKE AT THIS. WITH THAT SORT.
WITH THAT SORT OF URGENCY.
D.
EASE I THINK YOU'RE MUTED SURE
THERE WE GO YOU'RE ON YOUR ON
THE GO FOR SURE. YES THANK YOU
ARE CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO. NO APPS
ABSOLUTELY. WE HAVE TO MOVE
QUICK AND IT HAS TO BE URGENT-
OUR SUPERINTENDENT AUSTIN
BEAUTY AND HER DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT MEGAN REILLY
HAVE CALLED A TASK FORCE IT'S A
SEXUALLY- A STRATEGIC PLAN THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE MOVING QUICKLY ON IT TO
GO TO THE NEXT STEPS ABOUT
BEING EVEN MORE PRECISE OVER
COMMUNICATING THE RESOURCES BUT
BEING MORE PRECISE KNOWING LIKE
THE BACK OF OUR HANDS WHICH OF
THE FAMILY STILL STRUGGLE
BECAUSE AS I MENTIONED WE'VE
WE'VE DONE A GOOD JOB OF
GETTING DEVICES AND INTERNET
AND- AND THAT BUT WE STILL KNOW
YOU KNOW DALY THAT FAMILIES AND
OUR MOST IMPOVERISHED AREAS-
STILL STRUGGLE SO. WE HAVE A-
WE DO HAVE A TIGER TEAM RIGHT
NOW IN A STRATEGIC PLAN. I WILL
SAY- IN MY IN MY COMMENTS THE
IMPORTANT OF. THE LONG TERM WE
HAVE TO RE FRESH OR DEVICES. SO
OUR KIDS SOME OF THE DEVICES
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE A ITTLE BIT
OUTDATED YEAH THEY HAVE WITH
THEIR UPDATED BUT WE- WE FILL
IN LA UNIFIED THAT WE HAVE TO
REPLENISH 20% OF OUR DEVICES
PER YEAR SO OVER THE COURSE OF
FIVE YEARS. YOU KNOW EVERY KID
HAS AN UP TO BE A DEVICE- WE
STILL HAVE TO GET A LITTLE BIT
SMARTER WIND. THE HOT SPOTS OR
BREAKING DOWN WHAT AREAS
KNOWING THAT DATA AND THEN
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT- SO
PART OF OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
RIGHT NOW WE DO HAVE. IT THE
SUPPORT. BUT WE'RE RE THINKING
HOW WE STRUCTURE IT. HOW WE
DIFFERENTIATE THAT THE SPORT
THE SUPPORT. BASED ON- THE MOST
IMPOVERISHED AREAS SO IN OTHER
WORDS WE BELIEVE IN EQUITY JUST
LIKE L. THE ALL CAPS SPIRIT.
THE COMMUNITIES AND THE
FAMILIES AND THE STUDENTS WITH
THE MOST NEEDS GET THE MOST
RECENT RESOURCES. THE FASTEST.
SO I DON. WE ARE WE'RE WE'RE
MOVING HARD ON THAT AND WE'RE
WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE STILL WORK
OUT AND IN FRONT OF IT AND
WE'RE MOVING AS FAST AS WE CAN
WE'RE JUST NOT THERE YET. THANK
YOU SUPERINTENDENT. ROMERO AND
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT LA
UNIFIED AND REALLY. JUST ABOUT
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT ACROSS
THE STATE FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE DONE SYSTEMS PANDEMIC
BROKE OUT. IN THE ARENA OF
LIMITED RESOURCES. YOU'RE
FEEDING PEOPLE. YOUR PROVIDING
COMPUTERS YOU'RE PROVIDING
INSTRUCTION. YOU'RE DOING THE
BEST YOU CAN AGAIN WITH VERY
LIMITED RESOURCES IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC SCHOOLS ARE BEING
ASKED TO DO. MORE THAN WE EVER
ASKTHEM TO DO IN SCHOOLS QUITE
FRANKLY ARE ASKED TO DO TOO
MUCH WITH THE LIMITED RESOURCES
THEY HAVE SO IT'S TIME FOR THE
STATE. IN THIS ROOM INCLUDED A
STEP UP TO THE PLATE GIVE YOU
THE RESOURCES YOUNEED. TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITY PEOPLE THE
WAY PEOPLE WANT YOU TO SERVE
THE COMMUNITY- WHICH IS- YOU
KNOW. A MUCH MORE EXPANSIVE
VERSION OF SERVING THE
COMMUNITY THEN WE HAD EVEN
TWENTY YEARS AGO SO IF WE'RE
GOING TO REQUEST SAID OF YOU.
WE SHOULD PROVIDE YOU THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT. IN A VERY
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT SO WITH
THAT I THANK THE PANEL FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION PANEL
NUMBER TWO RUNNING ON A PANEL
NUMBER THREE. WHICH IS A MISTER
SANTIAGO IS GOING TO INTRODUCE
THAT PANEL. IF IT'S OKAY WITH
THE COMMITTEE MISTY SITTING
DOWN MOST OF TIME. THANK THANK
YOU MR- BUT I CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS WORK
OUT WITH YOU- OVER THE NEXT
YEAR HOW LONG IT TAKES THE
BRING IT COULD BE SOME IS
COMMUNITY HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND. I LIKE THE ONE I
REPRESENT. OUR FIRST- THANK.
OUR PANEL BE ABLE TALK ABOUT
DIMINISHES IN INDUSTRY AND
LOCAL AND- ENTITIES- THAT THE
AND WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO HELP
STUDENTS IN GETTING INTERNET
ACCESS. I WAS JUST REMINDER HOW
THAT WILL BE HOLDING QUESTIONS
UNTIL THE END OF THE PANEL JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE EXPEDITE.
OTHER PRESENTATIONS A WILL WILL
CONTINUE TO ASK. OTHER
PRESENTERS TO STAY THEIR TIME-
ALLOCATED AS BRIEFED BEFORE-
BEFORE A- AND BRIEF IN
PREPARATION OF THE. THE HEARING
OUR FIRST US SPEAKER IS- MISTER
CARLSON WITH CTIA THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY WILL BE JOINING US BY
PHONE- YOU MAY BEGIN AND
WELCOME. I GOT YOUR DONALD AND
MEMBERS OF A BOOK COMMITTEE
CARLTON OPPORTUNITY I A- THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY- WE ARE
DEFINITELY LIVING AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIME SINCE WE'VE
BEEN HEARING ALL- ALL DAY- THE
PANDEMIC OF PROMPTED SUDDEN AND
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN HOW WE
LIVE WORK AND EDUCATE OUR KIDS.
AND WE BELIEVE AMERICANS
WIRELESS NETWORKS HAVE RISEN TO
THE CHALLENGE- HAILING RECORD
SEARCHES THE MOBILE VOICE AND
DATA TRAFFIC DRIVEN BY COBIT.
THE SUCCESSES NO ACTION OUR
NETWORKS MET THE CHALLENGES
THANKS TO THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THE INDUSTRY AND BETH
ANNUALLY TO BUILD SOME OF THE
WORLD'S MOST BILLION THAT WORKS
WITH BOTH A LONG STANDING
NATIONAL REGULATORY FRAMEWORK.
THAT PROMOTES COMPETITION
INVESTMENT. LAST YEAR'S
WIRELESS INDUSTRY INVESTMENT
TOTALED TWENTY NINE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS A FOUR YEAR
HIGH. BUT WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY TO
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE TO
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
AMERICANS. LET ME SHARE WITH ME
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE CARRIED
HAVE BEEN DOING AND WORKING-
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WITH
EDUCATION. AT&T FOR EXAMPLE
DONATED ELEVEN THOUSAND
WIRELESS HOT SPOT TO THE
CORRECT BAROCLINIC SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND
THE SAN JOSE PUBLIC LIBRARY
SYSTEM. PROVIDED SCHOOL ON
WHEELS BUT CAPITA FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTION TO HELP SUPPORT
THIS IS AN ONLINE LEARNING FOR
ALMOST TWO IN LA. KEEP UP WITH
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO EQUIP BUSES WITH
WIFI DOG BED IS. BRIGHTEN YOUR
RECORDS TO PRETEND AMERIGO THEY
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR AND THE
FIRST PARTNER IN A CROSS SECTOR
PARTNERSHIPS TO EXPAND THEIR L.
A. U. S. B. AGREEMENT FOR THE
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. BY
COMMITTING UNLIMITED INTERNET
ACTIVITY FOR UP TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS. ARE THERE
ANY INNOVATIVE LEARNING TOOLS
INITIATIVE DEMONSTRATES THEIR
COMMITMENT TO REDUCING THE
BARRIERS- FORTY EIGHT TITLE ONE
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOLS
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM
REACHING MORE THAN FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND STUDENTS. MOST
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED THE
EXPANSION OF AVAILABILITY FOR
THEIR NEW FIXED WIRELESS
BROADBAND SERVICE CALLED LP
HOME INTERNET CUSTOMERS CAN
WORK STUDY OR HOMES WITH THEIR
KIDS. HE MOBILE AS YOU WOULD
YOU WOULD HEARD FROM-
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN EARLIER
PARTNERED WITH APPLE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THREE
TWO MILLION CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
BY PROVIDING SPECIAL PRICING
FOR IPAD THAN ON LIMITED DATA
PRINCE I WAS TWELVE DOLLARS PER
MONTH. A LARGE. TEN MILLION IN
SEPTEMBER BUT TO OVER FIVE
YEARS THAT A TEN POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR NATIONAL PROGRAM
FOR UNDERSERVED ELIGIBLE
STUDENT HOUSEHOLDS. WILL HELP
CLOSE THE HOMEWORK GAP BY
PROVIDING FREE HOT SPOT SIMPLY
HIGH SPEED DATA. ALONG WITH
ACCESS TO LAPTOPS AND TABLETS
TO COST. PART OF THE GLOBAL-
EARLY IN THE CONFLICT PRICES TO
DONATE NEARLY A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND HOTSPOTS IN THIRTEEN
THOUSAND TABLETS THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION FOR DISTRIBUTION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. IT WAS
RECOGNIZED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM
AS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THE CROSS
SECTOR PARTNERSHIPS. AT SCHOOLS
AROUND THE COUNTRY WERE TO
MITIGATE THE RISK OF
CORONAVIRUS WE'RE PROUD TO SEE
BY LET'S PROVIDERS QUICKLY
STEPPING UP TO MAKE SURE HOME
DOWN CHILDREN HAVE THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO PARTICIPATE AND
DISTANCE LEARNING. AND STAY
ENGAGED. COOL TEACHERS AND
PARENTS ARE WORKING HARD AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF CHALLENGES
AS WE'VE BEEN HEARING ALL THAT.
WHILE DENTISTRY CONNECTS
MILLIONS OF KIDS EVERY DAY AND
ALMOST ONE IN FIVE HOUSEHOLDS
THE ONLY INTERNET CONNECTION
THE SPARK FROM. IN JUST THE
PAST FEW WEEKS THE SCHOOLS OF
SCHOOLS OF OPEN WIRELESS
INDUSTRY GETS CONNECTED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS FOR THE FIRST TIME. WE
UNDERSTAND MANY STUDENTS ARE
RELYING ON THEIR BROADBAND
CONNECTED TO LEARN OUR TOP JOB
KEEPING THOSE THAT BRIDGE
RUNNING. IN ADDITION TO KEEPING
UP AS THE SURGING DEMANDS
DURING COVER A DISTANCE
LEARNING AND WORKING FROM HOME
AS YOU KNOW WE ARE WORKING.
WE'RE DEALING WITH ON PRESENT
AND UNPRECEDENTED WILDFIRES AND
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
AS WE SPEAK AROUND THE STATE. I
WANTED TO- REFLECT ON- A
COMMENT THAT SUPERINTENDENT
THURMOND. MADE ABOUT THE NEED
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT- CAN COME
OUT OF THIS HEARING IS TO LOOK
AT MAYBE FURTHER COLLABORATION
BETWEEN. THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AND THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY AS WE ATTEMPT TO
FURTHER BUILD OUT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING THE
FIVE G. INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS
FOCUSED DIRECTLY ON THE
CAPACITY ISSUES. THAT ARE
CREATING THE ISSUES SO- AS WE
GO FURTHER WOULD LIKE MAYBE TO
FOR THOSE CONVERSATIONS OF WHEN
WE UNFORTUNATELY. AND HAVE A AN
ISSUE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHAT
WE OFTEN DO MAYBE SOME NEW A
NONTRADITIONAL VOICES CAN BE
PART OF THAT. WHAT WE'RE
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK TO
KEEP OUR NETWORKS GOING AND WE
TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY. THANK YOU. SHARES.
THANK YOU MISSED CALLS AND NOW
WE HAVE MISS MCINTYRE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WHO IS ALSO A
JOINING US BY PHONE. WELCOME.
MAYBE THE MODERATOR COULD CHECK
AND IF YOU STILL CONNECTED
WE'RE HAVING TECHNICAL ISSUES
ON THE PHONE EARLIER I WAS
ADVISED THAT MAY STILL BE THE
CASE. HELLO HELLO WE CAN HEAR
YOU NOW. OKAY THANK YOU I'M
CAROLYN MCINTYRE IN BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
I HAVE FOR THOSE MEMBERS THAT
THAT MAY NOT BE ACTED FOR
MIGLIOR WITH OUR INDUSTRY CCPA
THE TRADE ASSOCIATION- FOR THE
CABLE INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND BOTH COMPANIES
HAVE COLLECTIVELY INVESTED OVER
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
STATE TO DEPLOY BROADBAND
NETWORKS DAM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- I JUST LIKE TO SAY
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
GIVING US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY- I WILL START MY
COMMENTS BY SIMPLY
HIGHLIGHTING. THAT EARLY ON- IT
SOON ADDS THAT PANDEMIC I'VE
HAD AND THE STATE DID NOT MUCH
OF THE COUNTRY WHEN INTO A
SHELTER IN PLACE MODE THE CABLE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
IMMEDIATELY STEPPED UP AND KEPT
THE CONNECT AMERICA PLEDGE-
THAT PLAGUED WITH DESIGNED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WERE
FAMILY THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
FACING A FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
AND WE WERE DOING BUT WE COULD
IN ORDER TO HELP KEEP YOUR
SERVICES UP AND RUNNING. BUT
TODAY'S FOCUS HAS BEEN A LOT ON
THOSE POPULATIONS THAT DON'T
HAVE CONNECTIVITY'S SO IF I
COULD SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
SERVICE OFFERINGS THAT ARE
MEMBERS AND HAVE PUT IN PLACE
AND- ORACLE AND OR HAVE
EXPANDED- IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT POPULATIONS THAT LACK
CONNECTIVITY ARE ABLE TO BE
CONNECTED. MOST OF THE CCPA
MEMBER COMPANIES OFFER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO CONNECT
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT DON'T
OTHERWISE HAVE AN INTERNET
CONNECTION WE HAVE I HAVE SOME
OF THESE PLACES ARE PROGRAMS IN
PLACE AND FOURTH LONG AT FAR
BACK AS TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
BOTH PROGRAMS RANGE IN PRICE
FROM NINE NINETY FIVE TO
SEVENTEEN NINETY NINE AND THE
GENERAL ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA.
IS THAT THERE IS A MEMBER THE
C. THAT IS THE CASE YOU'RE AND
TO CALL FOR THE FREE EVERY
LUNCH PROGRAM FOR AND THAT
THERE TYPE OF CELLS SERVICE PRO.
AT I MEN HAVE WORKED DALY. IN
THE QUEUE WITH THEIR COMMUNITY.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO IDENTIFY THE
POPULATIONS THAT WOULD QUALIFY
FOR THESE PROGRAMS BUT I WILL
LET MEANT THAT HISTORICALLY
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME CHALLENGES
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR GREATEST-
AB PARTNER. TO IDENTIFY THESE
POPULATIONS SHOULD IN FACT BE
THE SCHOOLS- PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC THAT HAD BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE IN THAT.
SCHOOLS WERE NOT ALWAYS
COMFORTABLE WORKING WITH THAT
COMPANY IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
THOSE POPULATIONS THAT WOULD
QUALIFY FOR THE PROGRAM. SINCE
THAT TIME AND THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME PRETTY AMAZING PARTNERSHIP
THE COUPLE OF EXAMPLES EXIST
ABOUT THAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ONE HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHERE
CONTACTED ENTERED INTO. AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND THE SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT-
TO PROVIDE SERVICE PADILLA TO A
SPONSORED AGREE MATT I'LL
RETURN TO THAT HERE IN A
MOMENT. AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE
WOULD BE BE AT ****
COMMUNICATIONS PARTNERSHIP IN
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO WITH THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT- HAVING WORKED WITH
THEM IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY THE
POPULATION. THAT WOULD QUALIFY
FOR THESE PROGRAMS AND TO GET
THOSE INDIVIDUALS CONNECTED- I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SPEAK A
MOMENT ABOUT WHAT WE CALL
SPONSORED PROGRAM IN GENERAL-
MORE SPECIFICALLY ABOUT A
PARTNERSHIP THAT WAS RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED BETWEEN. THE AT THE
NATIONALCABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
AND THE EDUCATION SUPERHIGHWAY-
THEY HAVE BASICALLY ENTERED
INTO AN. AGREEMENT TO SELL ITS
HEY THE KATE THREE TWELVE TO
BRIBE. INITIATIVE THAT
ADMISSION AND A PART. WITH
WILLING GETS. TO WORK WITH THE
INTERNET PROVIDERS TO IDENTIFY
THE PA. THAT DO NOT HAVE
CONNECTIVITY AND THAT THE
SCHOOL WOULD BE WILLING TO
ENTER INTO A CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENT IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE POPULATIONS RECEIVE
SERVICE- AND THERE ARE EXAMPLES
ADD SPONSORED PROGRAMS WORKING-
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY- THE
CITY OF CHICAGO ACTUALLY HAS
SUCH AN ARRANGEMENT. IN PLACE
TO PROVIDE CONNECTIVITY FOR
MANY AND THEIR- POPULATION
CAN'T SPEAK TO DIRECTLY WITH
THE QUALIFYING CRITERIA IS FOR
THAT BUT THESE ARE CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENTS THAT CAN BE ENTERED
INTO. WITH AN INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDER TO PROVIDE SERVICES
FOR THAT POPULATION THAT THE-
THE PARTNER THE CHOOSES TO
PROVIDE SERVICE FOR- SO THAT IS
AN INITIATIVE THAT WAS RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED AND WE'RE HOPING TO
HAVE BEEN VERY. POSITIVE OUT
AND- REPORTED I HERE IN THE
NEAR FUTURE THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
THAT SOME COMMUNITIES CONTINUE
TO HAVE BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE FACT
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF HOT SPOTS
THAT ARE BEING PROVIDED IN
ORDER TO FILL THIS GAP FIRST
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT HOT
SPOTS DON'T WORK IF THERE'S NO
NETWORK FOR THEM TO CONNECT TO.
THE BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT AND-
DEPLOYMENT OF BROKEBACK
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN FACT KEY I
MENTIONING BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT
BECAUSE AS HE PRETENDED THURMAN
MENTIONED EARLIER. MANY OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH DEPLOYING
BROADBAND INTERMITTENTLY ARE
RELATED TO OUR INABILITY. TO
OBTAIN PERMIT OR TO OVERCOME
CHALLENGES WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AID THAT ARE LOOKING
TO REACH THE COMPANIES TO
PROVIDE THAT SIMPLY EITHER
DELAYED PROJECT OR OTHERWISE
MAKES IMPACT PROHIBITED. SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE A DRASTIC- IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT WHEN WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN ONCE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN PLACE
TO WORK TO IDENTIFY AND CONNECT
THOSE POPULATIONS. THAT DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE CONNECTIVITY.
THAT HAPPY TO BE MARKS THE
FIFTH ABOUT ANY OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT THERE'S ANY QUESTION.
THANK YOU MS MCINTYRE NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO. WORK AND I WANT
TO INVITE I HOPE YOU STILL ON
IS THE HONORABLY SOLEIL HO WHO
SERVED HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
BUT NOW. I WILL BE PRESENTED
TODAY- AWARENESS OTHER HALF
WHICH IS THE EXECUTIVE BOARD
MEMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. AND
ALSO MONTEREY COUNTY SUPERVISOR
HE'S COULD BE JOINING US BY
PHONE AND TALKING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. ABOUT INTERNET ACCESS
AND SOME OF THE LOCAL
INITIATIVES- MISTER LEE HOW ARE
YOU ONE. THANK YOU I AM ON A
CHURCH SANTIAGO AND I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU AND CHERYL DONALD
AND ALL MY- FORMER COLLEAGUES
AND YOU MEMBERS. OF THE HOLDING
OUT MUCH NEEDED HEARING ON THE
CRITICAL. THAT MERITED BY
RELIGIOUS AND A GOVERNOR NOW
MORE THAN EVER AND I HOPE THAT
IT WILL BE A- FOR ACTION IN THE
NEXT LEGISLATIVE SESSION I WILL
HAVE TO BE AFTER THIS I'M HERE
AND SO OF THE WELL WE TO. WITH
AMERICAN LEAK WRITERS MY FATHER
PASSED AWAY. RECENTLY AND WAIT
TO ESCORT. BODY OFTEN THE
AIRPORT BACK HOME TO WATCH THE
BILL BUT I JUST TO COME THAT AS
AS YOU ALREADY KNOW THE DIGITAL
BY HAD BEFORE TOO LONG AND
FRANKLY. IT'S A NATIONAL
EMBARRASSED HERE THE TECH OF
THE WORLD OUR CANNOT BE BETTER
TELL. BUT I THOUGHT THE HARD
FOR TO GIRLS THIRTY FIVE
ADDRESS. IN MY JUST ANY SO.
CHAPTER THIS TO SO MANY OF OUR
SKINNER ACROSS STATE AND THE
NATION BUT AS YOU KNOW AND AS
THE SUPPORT MENTION IN JULY THE-
PERMITTED HAD A S. ONE POINT
TWO MIL. OR TWENTY PER OF ALL
STUDENTS WILL NOT HAVE BEEN.
AND OUR STATE TO BURKE.
THURMOND HAS CERTAINLY DONE LOT
OF HARD WORK BUT THE CHARGE THE
CHALLENGES ON WE STILL BIG THAT
SO MUCH MORE MUCH BE DONE. BUT
THE AS WE KNOW IT IS WORST FOR
COMMUNITY OF COLOR RURAL AREAS
AND THE WAY NEIGHBORS. 33% OF
WHAT HOW HAVE. COMPARED SEVENTY
EIGHT AND URBAN AREAS BUT WE
ARE KNOW THAT YOU IN PLACE LIKE
LOS. AND OAKLAND THERE BIG GUY
AMONG LOW INCOME AND ABLE TO
CALL THEIR LACK HIS. JOB
ALREADY KNEW THAT THE WAS GONNA
BE CROWD WITH THE SCHOOL YEAR
WITH MIXED. WITH ONLINE. THE
INTERNET IS NOT A LUXURY MORE
IT IS NOT A NECESSITY OF
EVERYDAY LIFE AND MUST BE USED
AS A MISTER UTILITY JUST LIKE
WATER ELECTRICITY OR GAS. WE
KNOW OUR STUDENTS WILL NEED IT
BEYOND THE PANDEMIC BUT SO WILL
THE MILLIONS OF WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR JOBS. AND
OUR JUNIOR OR ACTIVITY
TELEHEALTH MORE AND CONNECTING
WITH THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS USING
THE TECHNOLOGY SO IT'S CRITICAL
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
AGES AND ALL BACKGROUNDS AND
ALL CORNERS OF OUR STATE. BUT
THE QUESTION TODAY MUST BE
POPULOUS STATE PARTNER WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING
COUNTIES CITIES AND SCHOOL
BOARDS TO ADDRESS THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE ONCE AND FOR ALL IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE ARE YOUR
BEST PARTNERS. ALL CALIFORNIA'S
GOT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SHOULD BE
LEADING BY DEMANDING THAT ALL
PROVIDERS IN THE RESPECTIVE
COUNTIES PARTICIPATING PROGRAMS
THAT CALIFORNIA LIFELINE THAT'S
RECENTLY BEEN EXPANDED- IT IS.
CURRENTLY VOLUNTARY BILL FOR
PROVIDERS TO PARTICIPATE AND
THERE'S ALSO A NEED FOR SIMILAR
LIKE GRANT PROGRAM FOR CABLE
PROVIDERS THERE ALSO TENDS OF
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS IN EACH
OF EACH REGION IN OUR STATE WHO
QUALIFY BUT ARE NOT YET
BENEFITING. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CAN BE USING ITS RESOURCES TO
EDUCATE LOCAL RESIDENTS AND
CREATE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO GET THE WORD OUT TO ROLE
MORE RESIDENTS INTO THE-
CRITICAL PROGRAMS. WE ALSO NEED
TO REFORM EXPAND OUR EXISTING
STATE PROGRAM THAT LIKE THAT
BACK TO RESERVE FUND TO
GENERATE MORE A GENERATE MORE
CONTINUOUS FUNDING. AND EXPAND
MORE BROADBAND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
WAIT ON THE SIDELINES WHAT
PROVIDERS ARE DOING THE FIRST
RIGHT OF REFUSAL FOR STATE
MONEY TO EXPAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE KNOW THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
TWENTY SUPERINTENDED BERMAN
POINTED OUT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND TRYING TO LISTEN TO LEAD
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE MORE TRADITIONALLY
EXPEDITIOUSLY WITH PERMITTING
AND ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. IN
FACT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SHOULD
BE ENCOURAGED AND INCENTIVIZED
TO PARTNER WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CITIES AND. COUNTIES
FORMING JPA A OR SCHERING
PLOUGH COST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MUST BE IN. TO IN THE DRY SEAT.
ANTOLINI JUST A FEW WEEKS WE
HAD OUR FIRST MEETING WITH ALL
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE CITY
IS TO AND COUNTY MY- TO BE
GRANTED PARTNERSHIP TO MANAGE
THE DIGITAL. IN THE LARGEST IN
THE MONTEREY BAY READ. THERE'S
INTEREST YOUR PARTNER THAT WE
HAD NOT PREVIOUS WITNESSED BUT
THERE IS INTRA COLLABORATIVELY
ALL THIS. AS WELL. BUT TODAY I
ALSO WANT TO PUT. AT THIS BEEN
ON. THAT WE TRULY NEED A
UNIVERSAL. FIBER FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO BALLOT TO ADDRESS THE
DEADLY BY LOOKING FOR IN
CALIFORNIA IF WE ARE SERIOUS WE
NEED TO ADVANCE THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS NEEDED. TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM AND THEN ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO LEAD THE WAY
THERE'S BIPARTISAN INTEREST IN
COUNTY ALL ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING A RURAL SUBURBAN AND
URBAN AREAS. BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THE LEGAL CITIES THE RURAL
COUNTIES RT RT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS SIX INCHES ALL
GET BEHIND. SEPARATELY THE
STATE CAN ALSO SUPPORT
MUNICIPAL BOND MUSIC MUNICIPAL
BOND FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
UTILIZE AS WELL AS ANOTHER TOOL
IN OUR TOOLBOX. OUR STUDENTS
CERTAINLY DESERVE IT AND EVERY
CALIFORNIAN DESERVES TO HAVE
PORTABLE INTERNET ACCESS MOBILE
INTERNET ACCESS IN THEIR HOMES
LET'S MAKE IT HAPPEN NOW I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME-
MEMBERS AND- APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING AND THAT
IS AHEAD OF US THANKS. THE NEW
KNOW WE I'M GONNA IN SEPTEMBER
MY OWN RULE BECAUSE MEMBER OF.
HAVE TO LEAVE IT IN AND-
MISCARRIAGE YOU STILL HAVE A
CRUSH. ONE TIME I'M GOING TO DO
THIS BUT THE AND I APPRECIATE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE H
I RECALL HIM- AND AGAIN MY
CONDOLENCES TO YOUR FAMILY- SO
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS- WHAT DO
YOU THINK THE DIGITAL BY
CONTINUES TO PERSIST IN OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WHY
IS A CONTINUING HAPPENING. I
BELIEVE RUN OUT WE HAVE WELL
INTENDED STATE PROGRAMS AND
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THAT EVEN WITH
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT GENERATE A
FEW HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IT IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
THE FUNDING THAT WE HAD TO GET
TWO MONTHS AGO- IS ALREADY
DRIED UP BY THE END OF THIS
ARE. YOU DONE. I WONDER YEAR
AND- AND THEY HAVE MANY MORE
APPLICATIONS THAT THEY SIMPLY
CANNOT FUND. BUT BUT ALSO AS WE
KNOW IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT- ONE
OUT WE LOOK INTO THAT THE PC
PROGRAMS IT WAS SURPRISED TO
FIND OUT THAT- WHEN. IF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WANTED TO PARTNER.
AND UNIVERSAL BROAD. JUST LIKE
SMALL. LIKE IN MY COUNTY THE
DOLLAR SHE- IT THOUSAND READ
YOU KNOW INTERNET OR- FOR ALL
OF THE THREAT. BUT IT TOOK HIM.
YEARS TO GETTHROUGH THE- AND
THE PERMITTING. AND IT WAS ALSO
A SURPRISE AND FIND OUT THAT IF
YOU WANT TO GET SOME OF THE BIG
MONEY. THAT DAY I HAVE TEAM-
HAPPY RECLINE EXPANDING- OF
THOSE PROJECTS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN BOTH RURAL
AREAS. BEFORE WE CAN APPLY TO
GET THAT MONEY SO THERE'S A
VERY REAL- BUREAUCRATIC. AND
PERMITTING CHALLENGES THAT I
THINK WILL REALLY HELP. BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT- IF WE REALLY.
WANTED TO MAKE ACOSTA SPECIALLY
IN THE IN THE WORLD AREAS WE
NEED- A LOT MORE MONEY. TO
REALLY DO THE MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
ARE NEEDED. AND TALKING TO SOME
OF MY REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES IN THE WORLD COUNTY.
NORTON WITH A CALIFORNIA BIG
BIG BIG THIS IS ONE OF THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE. THAT THEY MAY
GET ASKED ABOUT- AND EVEN AFTER
THE RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN ASKING
FOR SO MANY YEARS NOW. THAT I
THINK THAT IF THE TIMING IS
RIGHT THE- DEPEND THAT MAKE
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED THERE. BUT
IT REALLY CALL FOR ACTION AT
THE MANY DIFFERENT WAYS AND
MANY DIFFERENT STRATEGIES. BUT
I THINK THE BIGGEST IS HAVING
THE MONEY UP FRONT IT- TO GET
THE WORK DONE AND MOVE THESE
PROJECTS. FORWARD AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. ALEJO'S
I'M GONNA CAN. TO THE PANEL AND
SIR WE'RE WE'RE VERY SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS. OFFER A- AND PRAYERS
TO YOU IN YOUR- AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE- BIGGEST.
DESPITE THE GUN DO THAT THANK
YOU I'M- ONLY THEY CAN TO TRY
TO RECOMMIT MYSELF THE WHAT
WE'RE AT- I'M GONNA MOVE ON. TO
MISTER FINLEY MR FENNEL
APOLOGIZES SUPERINTEND OF
SCHOOL FOR IMPERIAL COUNTY. I
THANK YOU MR OFTEN OFFER
JOINING US VIA REMOTE VIDEO
TESTIMONY AND IMPERIAL COUNTY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY- AND THESE
VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE DIGITAL DIVIDE BOTH
FOR OUR FAMILIES AND FOR OUR
STUDENTS. IMAGINE THE
POSSIBILITIES IF YOU WILL OF
ALL STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO USE
DIGITAL RESOURCES- ADVANCING
THEIR EDUCATION WELL BEYOND THE
SCHOOL HOURS. IMAGINE IF
TEACHERS WERE ABLE TO ASSIGN
PROJECTS THAT REQUIRE RICH
INVESTIGATION AN ONLINE
RESEARCH WITHOUT WORRY OF
STUDENTS WHO MAY BE
DISADVANTAGED DUE TO THEIR LACK
OF INTERNET CONNECTION AT HOME
IMAGINE BACKPACKS WITHOUT
TEXTBOOKS REPLACE THE DEVICES
AND THAT PROVIDE STUDENTS
ANYTIME ANYWHERE ACCESS TO NOT
ONLY INTERACTIVE BUT ADAPTIVE
CURRICULUM WELL THIS IS OUR
VISION. AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
WHICH IS REALLY BEEN MAGNIFIED-
DUE TO THE CURRENT PANDEMIC AND
THE NEED TO SUPPORT RICH ROBUST
DISTANCE LEARNING FOR ALL
STUDENTS MY NAME IS TODD FOR
NOW AND I AM VERY PROUD TO
SERVE AS COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS FOR IMPERIAL COUNTY.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
OF BRIEF BACKGROUND- TO HELP
FRAME THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
AND IMPERIAL COUNTY IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX THE INTERNET WAS
DRIVING FIBER INSTALLATIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS WE ALL
KNOW. WELL IMPERIAL COUNTY
BEING SITUATED BETWEEN PHOENIX
AND SAN DIEGO- WE WERE SEEN
COMPANIES AND CARRIERS PULL
PERMITS TO- INSTALL FIBER
REPEAT THEIR SIGNALS BUT WE SAW
VERY FEW PLANS FOR HOW THEY
WILL PUT WERE INTENDING TO
PROVIDE SERVICE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. SEEN THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND WANTING TO BE
IN CONTROL OF BOTH OUR CURRENT
AND FUTURE NEEDS WE BEGAN
DEVELOPING PLANS TO BUILD OUR
OWN. PUBLIC FIBER
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK
THROUGHOUT AND COUNTY WE BEGAN
CONNECTING SEVEN COMPREHENSIVE
HIGH SCHOOLS WITH OUR OWN SELF
PROVISION PRIVATE FIBER NETWORK
AND BEGAN DEVELOPING AND
EMERGING. AT MERGING DISTANCE
LEARNING PROGRAM. BY TWO
THOUSAND ONE WE HAD FORMED A
PUBLIC JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
THAT NOW INCLUDES AND I'M VERY
PROUD TO SAY THIS ALL SIX
SEVENTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY ALL COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND OUR HEALTHCARE
AND HOSPITAL FACILITIES. ENTER
THIS PUBLIC JPA NOW MANAGES AND
OPERATES OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILES OF OUR OWN FIBER
SERVING A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE SITES THROUGHOUT IMPERIAL
COUNTY. SO AFTER SUCCESSFULLY
BUILDING OUT THIS FIBER
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CONTROL OUR
OWN FUTURE WE SET OUR SIGHTS ON
BUILDING A COMPLIMENTARY
WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET
THE INCREASING DEMANDS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. USING THE SAME LTE
TECHNOLOGY AS COMMERCIAL
CARRIERS AND LEVERAGING OUR OWN
FIBER INFRASTRUCTURE FOR BACK
CALL WE SET OUT TO BUILD OUR
OWN SELF SELF PROVISIONED
WIRELESS SYSTEM THAT WE NOW
CALL OUR BORDER LINK AND THEY
SHOULD'VE. WE BEGAN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO DEVELOP SMALL
PROOF OF CONCEPT PILOTS WITH
SEVERAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SERVING OUR STUDENTS WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS. WE BEGAN
CONNECTING SCHOOL BUSES AND
OTHER USE CASES TO TEST OUT THE
VIABILITY AND THE IMPACT OF THE
NETWORK. IN FALL OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE BEGAN BUILDING OUT
THE L. T. ENOUGH NETWORK AND
EIGHT OF OUR MOST RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE COUNTY. AT
THAT STAGE OF OUR DEVELOPMENT
WE HAVE DEVELOPED OF IT WE HAVE
DISTRIBUTED ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
HOME UNITS TO STUDENTS WITH NO
INTERNET ACCESS AT HOME. WELL
THIS WAS SIGNIFICANT IN
ADDRESSING THE HOMEWORK GAP FOR
THOSE EIGHT HUNDRED STUDENTS WE
HAD NO IDEA THAT A PANDEMIC WAS
ON THE HORIZON AND THE NEED FOR
THE NETWORK WAS GOING TO BECOME
MISSION CRITICAL FOR OUR
SCHOOLS OVERNIGHT. IN MARCH OF
THIS YEAR WE PRIORITIZE
EXPANDING COVERAGE AND CAPACITY
OF THE NETWORK AS OF TODAY WE
HAVE MORE THAN THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS PARTICIPATING
IN DISTANCE LEARNING THROUGH
BORDER LINK ACCESS EACH DAY
WELL THIS CURRENTLY REPRESENTS
ABOUT 10% OF STUDENTS AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THESE ARE THE 10%
OF OUR STUDENTS WHO HAD LIMITED
OR NO OPTIONS PRIOR TO
BOARDING. OUR DISTRICTS ARE NOW
MOVING TO ONE TO ONE DEVICE AND
INTERNET INITIATIVES THIS YEAR
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
OUR GOAL IS HAVING EVERY
STUDENT WITH BORDER LINK ACCESS
BY THE END OF THE YEAR. IT'S
IMPORTANT ALSO TO DRAW A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN GENERAL
INTERNET ACCESS AND BORDER LINK
SERVICE BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
BORDER LINK SERVICES ACTUALLY
AN EXTENSION OF THE SCHOOL
NETWORK INTO THE HOME OR
WHEREVER THE STUDENT IS.
SCHOOLS CAN PROVISION CONTENT
FILTERING- AND OTHER SERVICES
JUST AS IF THE STUDENT WERE
SITTING IN THE CLASSROOM
CONNECTED TO THE SCHOOL
NETWORK. MODELING PUTS THE
CLASSROOM CONNECTION IN THE
HANDS OF STUDENTS THUS
EXTENDING LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AND CLOSING THE
HALLMARK OUT. I'D LIKE TO SHARE
ONE EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS WORK IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR ALL F US. BUT
HE SAID LOOKING DONNA IS A
SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN MONEY SELL AS A
PARTICIPANT IN THE COW WORKS
PROGRAM AT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. AND SHE'S ENROLLED IN
THE NURSING PROGRAM. WHERE WELL
MY CELL AND HER TWO GIRLS LIVE
IN AN AREA OF OUR COUNTY WITH
NO INTERNET SERVICE. THE RIGOR
AND DEMANDS OF THE NURSING
PROGRAM REQUIRED MAHDI SALEH TO
STAY AT THE COLLEGE INTO THE
LATE EVENINGS IN ORDER TO HAVE
THE INTERNET ACCESS THAT SHE
NEEDED TO COMPLETE HER STUDIES.
THIS CAME AT THE COST OF TIME
WITH HER STUDENTS ARE WITH HER
GIRLS AS WELL AS PLACE
TREMENDOUS STRESS ON THE AND
HARDSHIP ON OUR FAMILY.
ACCORDING TO OUR ACCORDINGLY
HER GIRLS EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND
THE HOMEWORK GAP FOR THEIR OWN
SCHOOL. BORDER LINK ACCESS
IMMEDIATELY CHANGED HER
SITUATION AND THAT OF HER
DAUGHTERS. I'D LIKE TO QUOTE
SOMETHING MUDDY SELA SAID AS
SHE TEARED UP IN AN INTERVIEW
SHE SAID AND I QUOTE. INTERNET
IS NOT A LUXURY BUT IT IS A
NECESSITY. I'M THRILLED TO
SHARE WITH YOU ALL TODAY THAT
MONEY SALAS GRADUATING THIS
DECEMBER- WITH A NURSING
DEGREE. AND IS CURRENTLY
PREPARING FOR THE BOARD EXAM TO
BECOME A REGISTERED NURSE.
MUDDY SELA HER CHILDREN AND SO
MANY OTHER FAMILIES ARE WHY
THIS WORK IS SO INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. AND I CHOSE HER
STORY TO SHARE WITH YOU BECAUSE
HER STORY HIGHLIGHTS THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT SOLVING THE
HOMEWORK GAP FOR OUR STUDENTS.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT SUPPORTING OUR
FAMILIES AND PREPARING OUR
WORKFORCE FOR THE FUTURE. AS WE
LOOK TOWARD SOLVING THE GAPS IN
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE ROLE THAT OUR PUBLIC
AGENCIES. AND SPECIFICALLY
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION CAN
PLAY IN BUILDING. MAINTAINING
AND PROVIDING INTERNET SERVICE
IN OUR STATE. THE EXPERTISE THE
CAPACITY AND THE ABILITY TO GET
IT DONE HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED
NOT JUST IN IMPERIAL COUNTY BUT
IN COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY DIVERSE
STATE I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU
THAT BUT AND WE HAVE MANY
CHALLENGES IN ORDER TO SOLVE
THE HOMEWORK OUT FOR MORE THAN
SIX MILLION STUDENTS. BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO RECOGNIZE IT WILL
TAKE A RANGE OF APPROACHES TO
MEET THAT CHALLENGE. AND SO I
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER. TO CLOSE THE
GAP AND ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER FOR
LIBRARY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TAKING UP IF YOU DO THIS. AND
AS SCHEDULED- WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE NOW- WITH THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. AND I'M GONNA ASK IF
THERE'S ANY. AND MISTER PHILLY
STILL THERE BUT WILL HAVE A
QUESTION ANSWER RIGHT AFTER.
APOLOGIZE ALMOST SKIPPED IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I SEE MISTER KALRA
HAS A FIRST. MIKE UP THANK-
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SURE.
AND I YOU KNOW I JUST WANNA
MAKE A COMMENT REGARDING AND
SURVIVES A LITTLE MADE
REFERENCE YOU KNOW BEING IN SAN
JOSE AND OF THE COUPLE'S LOGAN
VALLEY AND IS WHAT WE CALL
OURSELVES BUT- THE REALITY IS
THAT. THE REALITY IS VERY
DIFFERENT IN THE IMAGE EVEN WE
SEE SOME OF THE- COMMERCIALS ON
TV ABOUT INTERNET ACCESS FOR
LOW INCOME AND IT'S A FAMILY OF
FOUR RUNS NICE KITCHEN TABLE.
YEAH YOU KNOW I WANT TO PUT IT
IN A REAL CLEAR PICTURE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON WE HAVE. CENSUS
TRACTS IN. MY DISTRICT WILL
HAVE 2530% OR MORE HOUSEHOLDS
WITHOUT INTERNET CONNECTION.
DOES THAT OVERLAYS VERY
CLEARLY. BUT SOME OF THE ZIP
CODES THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
INCIDENCE OF COVERT INFECTIONS
AND DEATHS IN THE BAY AREA. IN
FOR THE WEALTHIEST PLACES IN
THE NATION THIS IS HAPPENING.
WE ARE FAMILIES LIVING THREE
FOUR FAMILIES IN THE HOUSEHOLD
OF FAMILIES IN THE GARAGE THE
OF HOMELESS FAMILIES LIVING. IN
CARS. I'D I'D I JUST MENTION
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
EVERYONE I THINK CHAU DONNA PUT
IT VERY WELL. EVERYONE'S DOING
MORE THAN THEY'VE EVER BEEN
ASKED TO DO- BUT WE STILL HAVE.
SO MANY GAPS THAT NEED TO BE
FILLED PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE
WAY OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM IS SET
UP. WE HAVE SOME MEANS WE HAVE
OVER SIXTEEN DISTRICTS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. ALONE UNDER THE
UMBRELLA. OF THE OFFICE OF.
EDUCATION WHICH IS TRYING TO
KIND OF. KEEP EVERYTHING- OF
THE TOTAL HE SAID WHICH ISN'T
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO DO- AND
ALTHOUGH WE ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE. OF OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR PARTNERS AND YOU KNOW
EIGHTEEN TO FOR EXAMPLE DID
DONATE HOTSPOT DEVICES. THEY'RE
STILL COST TWENTY DOLLARS A
MONTH FOR SERVICE. THAT FALLS
ON. THE BOARD EDUCATION
DISTRICTS THE PARTNERS THE
FAMILY SOMEONE'S GOING TO PAY
FOR THAT. AND IF YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE CHILDREN LIVING IN THE
HOUSEHOLD. THAT WOULD NEED
MULTIPLE HOTSPOTS YOU CAN SEE
THE PICTURE THAT'S BEEN PAINTED
RIGHT NOW- IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO. I
MENTION THIS BECAUSE- I THINK
WE ALL BASED UPON THE
PRESENTATION WE'VE HEARD FROM
ALL THREE. OF OUR OUR PANELS-
THAT THE SITUATION IS VERY DIRE
WE KNOW. TO SOME EXTENT OF THE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE BUT
THE SCALE OF WHAT HAS TO BE
DONE IS A NORMA'S. ENDED CHAU
DONALD POINT EARLIER WE'RE THE
ONES I GOTTA FIND A WAY. TO FIX
IT THE BEST THAT WE CAN- BUT
THE ANSWERS THE DISTRICTS THE
YOU KNOW I KNOW CERTAINLY OUR
OFFICE EDUCATION IS. ANOTHER
DESPERATELY ASKING FOR HELP AND
I KNOW ALL OF US HERE COMMITTED
TO TRY TO GET THAT HELP. BUT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THE SCALE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS BEYOND ANYTHING THAT ANY OF
US TO FACE JUST LIKE SO MANY
OTHER THINGS HAPPENING DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. BUT IT GOES
BEYOND THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT TO CREATE THESE AFTER
WE HAVE TO CREATE THIS ACCESS
FAR BEYOND. OF WHAT WHEN WERE A
PATHOGENIC WHENEVER WITH THAT
MAY BE OF THE BECAUSE AGAIN
EVEN IN SILICON VALLEY I HAVE
FAR TOO MANY CHILDREN. THAT
HAVE NO OR VERY LITTLE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE- OF THE
PUTTING TOO MUCH ON THE SCHOOL
TO TRY TO FIX THESE GAPS ARE
NOT THE FAULT OF THE SCHOOL SO
ANYWAY THAT'S THE ONLY MY
CLOSING. STATEMENT AS WELL
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD JUST
THINK YOU LISTEN TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT- FOLKS KNOW THAT WHETHER
IT'S A RULE. OR IN THE HEART OF
SILICON VALLEY THESE PROBLEMS
ARE DIRE AND WE REALLY NEED TO
DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN AND
THE WEEKS AND MONTHS. AHEAD
JUST TAKE A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE HERE WOULD.
ENCOURAGED BECAUSE- NOT FOR
PROFIT SO I WOULD I WOULD URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE. TO TALK. A THE
TO IMPORT ISSUES THIS SILENT.
BUT AT THE POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE AND I DON'T LIKE THE
TIME AND TO SAY I THINK THE
RESPONSE OF THE BEARS ON ALL OF
US NOT JUST THOSE WHO YOU WILL
MENTION. THIS IS A JOINT EFFORT
WERE LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES WITH
THE STATE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS TO CHIP IN WITH A
SERVICE PROVIDERS NEED TO CHIP
AND WHAT WERE OR WERE WERE IN A
PANDEMIC THIS HAPPENS ONCE. AND
HUNDREDS OF THE HUNDREDS OF
YEARS ONCE AND THEN GENERATIONS
OF THIS IS THE KIND OF STUFF
THAT LANDS IN HISTORY BOOKS.
AND HUNDREDS F YEARS FROM NOW
THE READ ABOUT BECAUSE OF. IT
IT. IS UNIMAGINABLE AND WE
DON'T KNOW THE DEPTH OF WHAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH. THIS
RESPONSIBILITY BEARS ON
EVERYONE. TO ACHIEVE SOME SORT
OF EQUITY AS A CONSTANT
LEARNING AND THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION FOR THE CHILDREN OF
OUR LOT OF OUR TIME. MR GARCIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD TO
SEE YOU MISTER FOR NOW FROM
IMPERIAL COUNTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR PROVIDING SOME
TESTIMONY TODAY AND ALSO TO THE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO SPOKE
EARLIER I WANTED TO TOUCH A
LITTLE BIT ON AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WHICH WAS AUTHORED BY MYSELF
AND NUMBER OF OTHER YOU KNOW
POLITICS INCLUDING- MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU'VE JUST
STEPPED OUT AND- AND A HANDFUL
OF OTHER FOLKS- WERE OF GOING
TO ATTEMPT TO MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION COMING IN JANUARY
AND WE'RE GOING TO. LEAN
HEAVILY ON THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE INTO MANY OF OUR
OTHER COLLEAGUES- WHO
PARTICIPATED IN BOTH WORK
GROUPS LAST YEAR I'M GOING TO
ASK ON THE THREE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THAT EFFORT
AND THEN ASK OUR ESTEEMED
FORMER COLLEAGUE NOW
SUPERVISOR- FROM THE MONTEREY
AREA SOME QUESTIONS AS WELL
BUT- MISS MCINTYRE AND MISTER
FOR NOW. AND THEN MISTER LANE
HOPE YOU KNOW WHAT- WHAT THREE
AREAS WOULD YOU SAY IF WE COULD
IMPROVE ON AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE WOULD YOU FOCUS ON- TODAY
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WERE FACED WITH AS IT RELATES
TO THIS PANDA THE DISK LEARNING
CIRCUMSTANCES PERHAPS THE
FUNDING ASPECTS OF IT- I'D LOVE
TO HEAR FROM YOU ALL IF YOU
HAVE TO FOCUS ON THREE
PARTICULAR AREAS- WHAT WOULD
THEY BE AND- I GUESS I'LL START
WITH EVEN- THE PERSON WHO SPOKE
FIRST AT STEVE CARLSON WILL GO
DOWN TO. CAROLINE MISTER FOR
NOW AND THEN WE'LL WE'LL CLOSE
WITH MR. LEVEL THAT'S OKAY WITH
FAIR. YEAH GOING COURAGE IT
WOULD BE TO KEEP COMMENTS BRIEF.
THREE POINT. AND I THINK MISTER
R. CARLSON HAD THE LEAGUE'S OF
ME MIGHT HAVE TO SKIP HIM IF
WILL WITH THIS CAROLINE
MCENTIRE THANK YOU.
CONSERVATIVE I THINK YOU A
FAMILY MEMBER CAROLYN MCINTYRE
I'M ASSUMING THAT YOU CAN HEAR
ME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION- THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND PROGRAM-
IS BEING FULLY IMPLEMENTED BY
THE COMMISSION WEEK FACT THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
OUT OF RESOURCES HERE'S THEM SO
CLEARLY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY WILL BE A NEED TO HAVE
WILL BE ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
HOWEVER WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
POLICYMAKERS TO CONSIDER
IDENTIFYING A LONG TERM FUNDING
SOURCES THAT WOULD SUPPORT NOT
JUST BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT BUT
BROADBAND ADOPTION AND DIGITAL
LITERACY WOULD BE THE NEXT TWO
CATEGORIES I WOULD. MOVE TO AND
IN THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
IN FINDING THE PROGRAM LONG
TERM CARE WITH THEIR CHARGE IS
IN THE BEST INTERESTS TO HAVE
AS A CALIFORNIANS THE AND WILL
ULTIMATELY GET THE JOB DONE AND
THEN MY THIRD ISSUE I WOULD
INCLUDE IN THAT IS THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE NUMBER FARMS
RELATED TO- THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING WITH REGARDS TO
PERMITTING PROJECTS ARE TAKING
A VERY LONG TIME TO BE
APPROVED- AT THE AT VARIOUS
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AND THAT
CLEARLY THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE DONE TO EXPEDITE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I BELIEVE
THIS MISS A LITTLE WHO ASK FOR
SOME COMMENTS RECOMMEND GARCIA.
CORRECT MR LEVEL YOU STILL ON.
ALL BECAUSE I CAN'T SEE OF ALL.
THAT. KEEP IN MIND AS A DELAY
SO WE'RE GONNA WAIT A COUPLE
SECONDS EVERY TIME I ASK
SOMEBODY SOMETHING MR LEE HOW
ARE YOU STILL ON. I'M GONNA
ASSUME NOT IF YOU HAVE AS A
COME ON THAT A LOT OF AN
ALASKAN AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
SERVE YOUR QUESTION FROM THIS I
DON'T KNOW YEAH. WANT TO GET
THAT MAYBE SURE THREE AREAS
THAT HE WOULD- SUGGEST US
MOVING FORWARD AS IMPROVEMENTS
TO THAT- EFFORT SEVERAL YEARS
AGO. MR FENNEL. HI YEAH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN AWHILE SINCE I'VE
READ THE BILL LANGUAGE I THINK
WHAT I WOULD WANT TO DO FOR YOU
IS ACTUALLY TAKE SOME TIME WITH
IT MEET WITH MY TEAM AND THEN
GIVE USE THAT FEEDBACK-
DIRECTLY- BUT I WILL SAY JUST
IN GENERAL AS WE LOOK FOR
REFORM AND SOLUTIONS TO WHERE
WE HOW WE MOVE FOWARD WITH
ENSURING THAT THAT WE GET TO
THAT GOAL OF EVERYONE HAVING
ADEQUATE ACCESS AND TO
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH DIGITAL
ACCESS AT HOME ESPECIALLY. THAT
THAT WE LOOK AT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE AS I MENTIONED IN MY
COMMENTS IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
LOT OF APPROACHES MANY
DIFFERENT APPROACHES WE ARE
VERY DIVERSE STATE AND SO
MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T LOOK
TO TRADITIONAL WAYS AND METHODS
OF SOLVING THIS SOLUTION BUT
THAT WE REALLY- OPEN BE OPEN TO
LOOKING AT- NONTRADITIONAL WAYS
OF SOLVING THESE ISSUES AND FOR
US THE SECRET SAUCE FOR US WAS
MAKING SURE THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER WITH OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES ASSET MAP WHO HAS WHAT
WHO CAN BRING WHAT TO THE TABLE
AND THEN WORK TOGETHER IT'S
THIS IT'S THE PARTNERSHIP. THAT
ACTUALLY MAKES THIS WORK SO-
AND THAT WOULD BE MY INITIAL-
OFF THE CUFF COMMENT JUST ONE
FOLLOW UP WORK FOR MR FENNELL
THE GIVEN THAT YOU'RE LEADING
THE CHARGE FORTY- COUNTY SCHOOL.
AND YOU. THAT THE SCHOOL. MAYBE
EVEN THE LOCAL. IN OUR REGION.
I PUT AWAY A VITAL ROLE TO
REALLY. TAE THE LEAD ON SOME
OF THE INTEREST INVESTMENTS OUT
THERE ELABORATION WITH IN SOME
CASES THE ISPS OR FOR THAT
MATTER IN SOME INSTANCES- FOR
THEM DIRECTLY- LEADING THE
CHARGE- AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER. AS THE INDEPENDENT AS
EFFORT. WITHOUT THE ISPS AFTER.
WITHOUT THE RIGHT. AT WHAT
ABSOLUTELY AS I MENTIONED IT'S
GONNA TAKE A MULTIPLE- IS IT
GONNA TAKE MY MULTITUDE OF
APPROACHES TO IT I THINK YOU
KNOW WE LEARNED FROM OTHERS
THAT LED BEFORE US SO YOU KNOW
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH KINGS
COUNTY AS ONE EXAMPLE WE ARE
NOW- TRYING TO HELP AND ASSIST
OTHER COUNTIES WERE WORKING
WITH COLUSA COUNTY NOW- SO YOU%
KNOW OUR SOLUTION IS OUR
SOLUTION FOR IMPERIAL COUNTY-
BUT THERE ARE LESSONS LEARNED
AND BRIGHT SPOTS WITHIN IT THAT
CAN BE SHARED WITH OTHERS-
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE TO
REPLICATE OUR MODELS SUCH AS AN
COLUSA. WE ARE HELPING THEM DO
THAT- IT MAY NOT BE THE RIGHT
SOLUTION FOR SOME OTHER COUNTY
IN CALIFORNIA BUT- WE DO NEED
TO STAY FOCUSED ON THE GOAL NOT
THE MATH THE TRADITIONAL
METHODS AND MEANS TO GET THERE.
THANK YOU. SURE ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF. I'VE I THINK THAT'S IN AND-
IF THAT'S THE CASE I'M GONNA BE
BRIEF ON MY COMMENTS OTHER THAN
I THINK ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE STILL IN THE ROOM-
THOSE WHO'VE LEFT THEIR OR
COMING BACK UP FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY TO ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND ONE THAT- THE
MERITS THIS AND MUCH MORE
ATTENTION WE PLAN TO CONTINUE
THIS- A AND- ONE THING THAT'S
VERY CLEAR OUT OF THIS IS THAT
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT HAVING SOME
POSITIVE. IMPACT IN THIS AND IT
WILL BE CARRIED IDEAS- MOVING
FORWARD IN THE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ENDEAVORS ALTHOUGH
HEARING COMMITTEE TO DISCUSS
SPECIFIC LEGISLATION
DISPERSANTS DISCUSSED SPECIFIC
ISSUES THAT CAN TURN INTO THAT
SORT OF ADVOCACY IN CHANGES
THAT WE NEED TO GET- TO THE
BRIDGE- THAT DIGITAL DIVIDE IN
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE WHO ARE LEFT BEHIND LIKE.
THE VERY MANY HORRIFIED FOR
HERE TODAY I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE TODAY-
THE STATUS BECAUSE IT'S NOT
GONNA BE ACCEPTABLE AND OUT
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SERVED AND IT
IS ADEQUATE- ADEQUATE- DIGITAL
CAPABILITY TABLET EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES- FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT
RULE OR BE IT. URBAN FOR
THANKING MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND I WANT TO TURN OVER
TO QUESTIONS ANY QUESTIONS. ANY
COMMENTS THAT MAY BE MADE BY
THE PUBLIC I WILL FIRST START
WITH THOSE IN THE GALLERY-
BECAUSE WE MAY HAVE MANY. IT'S
GONE A LITTLE BIT LONGER AND
FOR THE- MAY HAVE LOST TO BE.
I'M ENCOURAGE ALL CALM TO STAY
A ONE MAY. I WOULD A COUNTER
HERE. YOU MAY GO LONGER THAN
ONE MINUTE BUT I WILL CUT YOU
OFF AFTER TWO- BUT WINNING
COURAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN PARTICIPATE. ONE
MINUTE COMMENT IT WILL START
WITH THE POP. UP AND I CAN ONLY
NAME ORGANIZATION AND ONE
MINUTE PLEASE THAT WOULD BE THE
ENCOURAGEMENT. I MAY BUT IN
BECAUSE I CAN HEAR PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THE. THE TECHNICAL
GAPS I CAN HEAR YOU. CAN I CAN
I ASK YOU MORE TIME AND I HATE
TO DO THIS CAN YOU START ALL
BECAUSE WE CANNOT HEAR YOU. AND
THAT THAT'S BECAUSE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. THE TECHNICALLY SHOULD
I APOLOGIZE. WE SURE WE'RE
ASKING FOR THE DEVOTE THE
DECORUM OF THE HOUSE TO STAND
AND AS WE CAN SEE. ALL ALL. OF
OUR INTENT IS TO GET THE MIKE
WORK. WE WILL ADHERE TO THE OF
THE HOUSE THINKING. AND WE WILL
BE RESPECTFUL TO THE SPEAKER
WHO IS ON THE MIKE NOW THE SAME
WAY WE WOULD WISH OTHERS TO BE
RESPECTFUL OVER SPEAKING
THINKING. THANK YOU KILEY- TEAR
SANTIAGO TERREL DONALD THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR CONVENING THIS
HEARING ALEX TAURUS WITH
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF LIGHTSPEED SYSTEMS VERY
HAPPY TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY. MAJOR FOCUS OF LIGHT
SPEEDS ADMISSION IS MENTAL
HEALTH IN ONLINE SAFETY SO AS
WE'VE HEARD TODAY IS ABSOLUTELY
PARAMOUNT TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY BUT-
THERE'S ALSO THE NEXT QUESTION
AS WE ARE RELEGATED TO THE
THERAPIST AND LEARNING. HOW DO
WE ENSURE MENTAL HEALTH HOW DO
WE ENSURE ONLINE SAFETY SO THAT
IS A BIG PILLAR A BIG FOCUS OF
LIGHTS BE THE MISSION AND AS A
STATE FACILITATES CONVERSATIONS
ON DISTANCE LERNING THROUGH
THESE TASK FORCES THROUGH THESE
WORKING GROUPS- WE THINK THAT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
WE- CONTINUE. TO HAVE- WHILE
ALSO FOCUSING PROTECTING
PRESERVING STUDENT PRIVACY
HELPING THEM STAY SAFE- AND
HEALTHY DURING THIS TRANSITION.
AGAIN SO MANY DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF THIS- DIGITAL
LITERACY LINGUISTIC GAPS WHAT
PIECES DO WOULD ADDRESS WITHIN
THE CONNECTIVITY CONVERSATION
SO- WE'RE PRETTY SURE THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING AS A AS
A STAKEHOLDER ALONG SIDE THE
LEGISLATURE. ALONGSIDE CD WE
KNOW SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN HAS
MADE MENTAL HEALTH A HUGE
PRIORITY ESPECIALLY IN THIS
TIME OF THIS IN FLORENCE SO
AGAIN CONTINUE TO. OF HOW
DISCOVERS WITH FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH WITH YOU ALL THANK
YOU SO. MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
THIS IS FAMILIAR TO ME. I COME
INTO THIS BUILDING OFTEN. MY
NAME IS ANDREA HEDSTROM. TWO OF
MY CHILDREN ARE HERE WITH ME
TODAY. AND I'M MARRIED TO A
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER. A PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER WHO AGREES WITH
KEVIN KILEY AND KNOWS THAT THE
BEST THING FOR THE STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA IS TO GET BACK TO IN
PERSON EDUCATION AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. PLEASE STOP USING THE
WORD PANDEMIC. THE CDC NOW
CALLS THIS AN OUTBREAK THERE IS
NO PANDEMIC. THE VIRUS WITH A
SURVIVAL RATE OF OVER 99% IS
NOT A PANDEMIC. CHILDREN DO NOT
DIE FROM THIS VIRUS AND THEY
CAN SAFELY GO BACK TO IN PERSON
SCHOOL THE VERY PREMISE OF THIS
HEARING IS FLAWED. MORE THAN
EVER CHILDREN NEED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO IN PERSON SCHOOL AS
KEVIN KILEY SAID THIS LOCKDOWN
IS BY ITS VERY NATURE
INHERENTLY INEQUITABLE.
CHILDREN WHO WERE ALREADY
SUFFERING IN CALIFORNIA ARE
SUFFERING EVEN MORE NOW THIS
LOCKDOWN IS SIMPLY EXACERBATING
THE INEQUALITY AMONG PEOPLE
MORE THAN EVER. SCHOOL IS WHERE
CHILDREN MANY CHILDREN HAVE
ACCESS TO ANY KIND OF STABILITY
IN THEIR LIVES WHAT SO EVER
FROM THEIR MEALS TO A
CONSPIRACY CONSISTENT PERSON
LIKE A TEACHER THE PRESENCE OF
ADULTS MANY TUITION BASED
SCHOOLS HAVE MANAGED TO FIND
THEIR WAY TO BE OPEN FOR IN
PERSON CHILDREN FOR THE TUITION
BASED PLAYERS. PLAYERS WHILE
THE POOR A OF THE- FALL FURTHER
BEHIND. LINDA HAMMOND DARLING
HAS IDENTIFIED THE REAL
PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA WHEN SHE
SAID THAT WE DON'T EVEN HAVE
ELECTRICITY THANK YOU TO
ADEQUATELY MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA YOU FOR YOUR TIME
WHEN WILL YOU LOOK AT THE REAL.
IN THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THAT'S TWO MINUTES AND WILL
CONTINUE. WITH THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE PHONE. N. O. S. THE
SERGEANTS IF THERE'S ANYBODY
WHO IS PRESENT ARE IN THE
GALLERY BEN SARGENT L. WE WILL
CONTINUE AND BE RESPECTFUL TO
THOSE WHO ARE NOW ON THE PHONE.
I WILL. AGAIN MA'AM I WILL ASK
YOU BE RESPECTFUL OF THOSE WHO
WERE GOING TO SPEAK BE
RESPECTFUL OF THE NEXT SPEAKER.
I WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE WHO
ARE ON THE PHONE. FOR ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND OUR
FIRST LINE WILL COME FROM FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
FIFTY NINE. SHARE A BACHELOR'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS WITH. HI THIS IS
SERRA BOXES OF PABLO
REPRESENTING TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND AMAZING HARD WORKING
AND INNOVATIVE SCHOOL BUSINESS
LEADERS WHO HAVE NOT STOPPED
WORKING SINCE MARCH THIRTEENTH
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE DEVELOP A STRONG
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP WITH
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
SCHOOLS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DEFINE AND BUILD THE
CONNECTIVITY INFRASTRUCTURE
PRIORITIZING A RURAL AND LOW
INCOME. WE NEED THE STATE FOR
SUPPORT STATE FOR BONDS AND
INVESTMENT YOUR SUPPORT
TECHNOLOGY EQUIPMENT INCLUDING
DEVICES AND HOT SPOTS TO HAVE
SHORTER LIFESPAN BUILDING
UPGRADES AND MOST OF OUR SCHOOL
SITES NEED TO BE MODERNIZED IN
ORDER TO TRANSMIT WITH RELIABLE
WIFI FIRST IN CLASS AND HOT
SPOT PURPOSES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ONGOING SUPPORT
TO INSURE THAT EVERY STUDENT
EVERY TEACHER AN EDUCATOR HAS A
TECHNOLOGY SKILLS AND DEVICES
THAT WE WHETHER THE COVE IN
NINETEEN CHALLENGES. ONE THING
THAT HAS NOT BEEN ADDRESSED IS
THE CONTINUED IMPACT THE POWER
OUTAGES AND WILDFIRES ARE
CAUSING TO OUR STUDENTS AND
EDUCATION COMMUNITY WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH FOR
OFFERING AB THIRTEEN. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN AND FOUNDER DOT
FOR OFFERING SB EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR TWO BILLS THAT DID NOT
MAKE IT OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE
BUT BETTER STILL NEED TO BE
PART OF THE CONVERSATION AND TO
ANSWER ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
THIRTY BUCKS QUESTION LINDSAY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
TULARE COUNTY WAS RECOGNIZED BY
THE NEW YORK TIMES IS ONE OF
OUR BRIGHT BOB. FOR THEIR
AMAZING ABILITY TO TURN
DISTANCE LEARNING WITHOUT A
HICCUP FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS
THEIR TEACHERS AND STUDENTS
HAVE HAD DEVICES AND
COLLECTIVITY AND THEY MAILED
THEIR STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL
SUPPLIES JUST CONTINUE TO
SUPPORTING GAUGE MEANT. THIRTY
SECONDS SO MUCH FOR THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU AND I'M
GONNA STOP THAT I DID NOT HEAR
YOU HAD TO YOUR THEN WANT SPEAK
MISTER COLLEY HAS MADE ME A-
THAT. AND SHE MAY HAVE THE MIKE
NOW. IF YOU'RE NOT READY WITH
THE STATEMENT I CAN ALSO WAIT.
AGAIN I WILL- WE CAN ALSO WAY
IS YOUR PROGRESS BUT I NEED TO
MOVE ON TO NEXT WEEK. ANY TIME
BEGINS.
COOL BEING CLOSE IS NOT
GOOD. I IF YOU WOULD IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL TO
THE SPEAKER I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT. PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL OF
THE SPEAKER. MY NAME IS AUDREY
COOL BEING CLOSE IS NOT GOOD
FOR CHILDREN AND TEENAGER THAT
IS WHERE WE HAVE ALL OUR
FRIENDS OUR ACTIVITIES AND OUR
SUPPORT PEOPLE LIKE TEACHERS
STAYING HOME ON SAM SCHOOL IS
NOT THE ANSWER. A LOT OF
PARENTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
STRUGGLING IN CALIFORNIA AND IN
A LOT OF FAMILIES BOTH PARENTS
WORK. SO THERE'S NO ONE TO STAY
HOME WITH THE CHILDREN WHO DO
NOT HAVE OLDER SIBLINGS. I HAVE
A THREE YEAR OLD BROTHER AND IF.
THE LOCKDOWN CONTINUES HE WILL
NEVER GO TO SCHOOL. AND HE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE FRIENDS. HE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO LEARN HOW
TO GET ALONG WITH OTHER
CHILDREN HIS OWN AGE. AND WE
ARE LUCKY CHILDREN WE HAVE AN
ANCHOR FILLED WITH ANIMALS AND
FUNDING FOR US TO DO. BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN
APARTMENTS OR THE CHILDREN WHO
LIVE IN HOTELS AND WHO ARE
HOMELESS. OR WHAT ABOUT THE
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES WHO
NEED SPECIAL ED TEACHERS. THERE
IS A BETTER WAY TO DO THIS
THING KEEPING THE SCHOOLS
CLOSING KEEPING US ON THE
COMPUTER ALL DAY. THE ANSWER IS
NOT. GETTING FASTER INTERNET TO
EVERYONE THIS LOCKDOWN IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. CHILDREN ARE
NOT AT HIGH RISK FOR THE VIRUS
OF HELP BUT GETS ADMITTED
SCHOOL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT WILL GO
BACK TO THE PHONE. AND WILL
TAKE THE NEXT CALLER AGAIN
WE'RE STRONGLY ENCOURAGING A
MINUTE COMMENT. AND YOUR FINAL
COME FROM. I'M SORRY NEXT ONE
WILL BE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MISTER. HELLO MY NAME
IS LARRY ORTEGA I'M WITH
COMMUNITY UNION I'VE BEEN IN
THE DIGITAL AT A MINUTE DIGITAL
ADVOCATE FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
THREE HAVING BROUGHT AWARENESS.
ON BROADBAND BANDAGES TO OVER
THIRTY MILLION HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES OVER THE LAST
DECADE WE DO NOT APPRECIATE THE
NARRATIVE THAT THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE IS COME UPON US LIKE
SOME SU NOMINEE OR TSUNAMI OR
HURRICANE. WHAT'S MISTER THAT
THE INDUSTRY PLANNED BY
DECIDING. TO CUT OFF BROWN AND
BLACK CHILDREN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FROM OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDED BY HIGH SPEED INTERNET
AS DR GALPERIN FROM USC
REPORTED TO PEOPLE TWENTY
TWENTY. WHERE HE SHOWED THE
DIGITAL REDLINING THAT WAS
EXACTED ON THE COMMUNITIES OF
SOUTH LA EAST LA THROUGH THE
MONEY IN INTO POMONA. THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
THE HOT THE HOT AND HUNDRED
MILLION VETERANS CASF IN THE
BUILDINGS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED BY THE BOND. NEED TO
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF HOW DO WE
GET TO ENFORCEMENT. RUNNING
INDUSTRY PROMISES THAT WERE
MADE DURING THE MEGA MERGERS OF
COMCAST. CHARTER VERIZON AT&T
ETCETERA AND HOW DO WE GET THE
CPC TO BE ABLE TO ENFORCE THESE
MEGA MERGER PROMISES THAT SAID
THEY WERE GOING TO CONNECT
EVERYBODY. DOES WITH THE
PROMISES AND THAT'S THE
COMMUNITY DID A COMMUNITY
BOUGHT OFF. ON THE IDEA THAT
EVERYBODY'S GETTING BE
CONNECTED BUT THAT'S NOT EVEN
PART OF THE DISCUSSION HERE I
DON'T KNOW HOW THAT'S BEING
MISSED HERE. WE NEED TO GO BACK
IN HISTORY OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS AND FIND OUT. WHERE THE
PROMISES HOW MUCH OF THE FIBER
SHOULD HAVE BEEN LAID WHY DID
THE INDUSTRY DO WITH MONEY THAT
THEY THAT THEY TRY. THE LAN
LINE CONSUMERS OVER CHARS AND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND NOW
WHERE WAS TWENTY DOLLARS IN TWO
THOUSAND TODAY A LAND LINE IS
SIXTY BUCKS A MONTH. WHERE IT
HAPPENED ALL THAT MONEY WHERE
THAT MONEY GO SOME OF THE MONEY
AND CASF AND IT WOULD BE
POISONOUS BONNIE'S TO BE FOUND
OUT ABOUT HOW DO WE GET TO THE
OUT. TO THE CRUX OF WHERE WE
GONNA DO ABOUT ENFORCING
INDUSTRY TO DELIVER. IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT WHEN IT TO CONTINUE
THAT'S TWO MINUTES OF THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- PRESENTATION THANK.
YOU WE'RE GONNA NEXT BIGGER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THE
NEXT ONE WILL COME FROM LINE
TO. EIGHT TO MINUTES START LINE
OF OPEN. ENCOURAGING ONE MINUTE
THANK. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO AND
NUMBERS MY NAME IS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WHICH REPRESENTS A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND.
FIFTEEN KATE AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE STATE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING A JOINT HEARING TO
ADDRESS THE SIX THREE MILLION
PORTANTINO ISSUE. ENSURING THAT
EVERY STUDENT IN THE STATE OF.
HAS THE AFFECT HIGH SPEED AND-
RELIABLE TECHNOLOGY CRITICAL AT
AS WE STRIVE TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH A HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION.
AND A DISTANCE LEARNING OR
HYBRID LEARNING ENVIRONMENT ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT IN THIS CONVERSATION
AND SUPERINTENDENT TERM
IMPROPER STOP AND CHAIRMAN OF
DONALD CHAIRMAN- SANTIAGO DID
AS WELL IS THE NEED TO PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
EDUCATORS THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE
THE HIGHEST QUALITY INSTRUCTION
POSSIBLE. IN A DISTANCE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT AS YOU
CONTINUE YOUR DELIBERATIONS ON
THIS ISSUE WE RECOMMEND THAT
YOU INCORPORATE- BELIEVES FOR
ROBUST PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR EDUCATORS INTO THOSE
DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU THINK
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THIS YEAR HE IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO DEVELOP A- COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE STRATEGY AND TO
ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
THIS VERY CRITICAL ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
BIGGER. AND THEN ACT FINE LOOK
FROM FOUR ONE FOUR ALAINA TIMES.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE MEMBERS
MONEY THEM NOW. MILITARY THAT
MEASURE THE WATERS COUNTY OP
CASE. MICHAEL THURSDAY SCHOOL
THIS IN GERMANY CHILDREN
INCLUDING LEARN. I CAN CONCERNS
REGARDING CONNECTED THE ACT AND
WALKED INTO TOWN DISTRICT
ALLOWED ME. LAKE ULTRA TRAILER
EDUCATION FOUNDATION. HAS
PROVIDED ONE YEAR OF SERVICE
AUTHORED BY THE DIDN'T DROP L.
A. COUNTY. HELLO ALTHOUGH.
NOTHING SUPPORTED THE LA BOARD
OF THIS YEAR WHAT IS TO BE THE
BY TWELVE FIVE DOLLARS A- ONE
THOUSAND OF. AND TRY TWO
THOUSAND HELP. NEED TO THE L.
A. TIMES TO. ONE SHOW BY
PROVIDING SERVICE THAT DECEMBER.
THIRTIETH TWENTY BOB. FOR THE
CARE. CAN REALLY FUN DEADLINE.
EXTENSION THE DEADLINE WILL BE
BACK HELPFUL. AUTHENTICATION OF
THE TO PREPARE HEALTH BUT THERE
IS FOR. BY DECEMBER. TWENTY
REQUIREMENT TOP THAT HUNDRED.
AN ANNUAL STERN DEVICE
CONNECTED YOU TYPE OUT OF.
HEALTH WE ARE WE ALSO THAT DOWN
ON GOING YOU THE HOME ACT TO
THE FUTURE WE THANK YOU CAN YOU
PROJECT IN THE THIS IS A AND
THE FOR TALKING TO APART. THE
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU WE
GO ON TO THE NEXT WEEK OR
PREFERRED TO COMMENTS. AND THE
NEXT ONE WILL COME FROM TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU TIMES ARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KEVIN CONNOLLY AND I AM
A TRUSTEE ON THE MOUNTAIN.
MOUNTAIN VIEW WHISMAN SCHOOL
BOARD I'M ALSO A CO FOUNDER OF
THE DIGITAL EQUITY CAN
COALITION AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. I'M IN MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN MOUNTAIN VIEW
CALIFORNIA THE HEART OF SILICON
VALLEY 5210% OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE STILL STRUGGLING WITH
INTERNET ACCESS. WE PUT IN OVER
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
TO PURCHASE A CHROMEBOOK FOR
EVERY SINGLE STUDENT. AND WE'VE
BEEN GETTING HOT DR STUDENTS AS
WELL. BUT WE ALSO GOT OUR
FAMILY TO SIGN UP. FOR THE LOW
COST PROGRAM THROUGH INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS LIKE THE
XFINITY ESSENTIAL PROGRAM AN
ACTIVE AGENCIES. WHICH ARE TEN
DOLLARS A MONTH. THIRD PROGRAM
AT TWENTY FIVE MEGABIT PER
SECOND ARE NOT ENOUGH. TO
ACTUALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF A
HOUSEHOLD WHERE MULTIPLE
CHILDREN ARE TRYING TO ACCESS
THE BURNING. AND WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED IS THAT INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER COMPANIES WHEN
PEOPLE CALL IN FOR THE LINE FOR
THE FULL COST PROGRAM. ARE
SELLING OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES I PERSONALLY WITH THEM.
THAT IS RECEIVING PREMIUM LUNCH
THIS IS A FAMILY LIVING BELOW
THE- LINE THERE GETTING FOOD AT
OUR LOCAL PANTRIES TO BE ABLE
TO. GET BY RIGHT NOW AND
THEY'RE PAYING A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
INTERNET ACCESS BECAUSE THEY
WERE. TOLD BY COMCAST. XFINITY
ESSENTIAL PROGRAM. THIS IS NOT
OKAY WE NEED TO HAVE REGULATION
OF INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
IF THEY ACCEPT EIGHT DOLLARS
AND BENEFIT FROM STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO CAPITA OR
THROTTLE SPEEDS FOR OUR
STUDENTS. OR ANY FAMILY THE
INTERNET IS LIKE WATER RIGHT
NOW IT SHOULD BE A PUBLIC
UTILITY AND I APPRECIATE. THAT
HEARING BECAUSE WE NEED THE
STATE TO TAKE ACTION. TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS. THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR COMING WITH ON
THE NEXT. THANKS I WILL COME
FROM THAT TO LINE OF THE LINE
TWO. THANK YOU TIME. THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE MOMENT TODAY
NAME IS SMITH I LOW IN PHILLY
VALLEY. MY CHILD IS ON AND I P.
AND- MAYBE CALL FIVE OR OF
SERVICE THAT ARE OUTLINED WHICH
MEANS 75% OF THE SERVICES ARE
ONLY PROVIDED IN PERSON. IF
LEARNING IS NOT ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS AND
CREATING A GREATER DIVIDE IN
HER EDUCATION. THE LACK OF ONE
ON ONE IN PERSON KEYCHAIN AND
SERVICES. TO ENSURE HER
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS IS NOT
BEING MET WE HAVE A VERY
UNSTABLE INTERNET WHERE WE LIVE
WHICH IS MAKING ITS OWN VERY
DIFFICULT AND FRUSTRATING.
BEING A SINGLE PARENT WORKING
FULL TIME ISN'T ECONOMIC
STRUGGLE CURRENTLY HAVING TO DO
SCHOOL AT THE SAME TIME. HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN WORKING TO
PROVIDE FOR HER AND FILLING IN
THE GAPS OF EDUCATION RIGHT NOW
AN EXTREMELY STRESSFUL CORRECT.
IN ADDITION TO IN. PERSON IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT. HE HUNDRED AND
PER P. TO ADDRESS THE CHILD
ABUSE. THAT IS ON THE RIGHT NOW
AND CURRENTLY THE REPORTED
CASES ARE BEING SEVERE AS THEY
ARE BEING REPORTED IN THE
HOSPITAL VERSUS THE CLASSROOM
AHEAD OF TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. ON WE'RE MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT PERSON. THE NEXT FINAL
COME FROM FORTY TO FORTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU FOR
START TIME. THEY HAVE A MINUTE.
ONE FORTY TWO. HELLO HELLO YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU THAT WAS NUMBER
FORTY. HI OKAY THE BARN CARE
YEARS MY NAME'S MELISSA I'M
CALLING FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I AM AT. I INVOLVED
PARENTS AND NOW AT TWENTY FOUR
HOUR HOME SCHOOL TEACHER FOR MY
CHILDREN- I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
HOW MANY LEGISLATORS ARE LEFT
IN THE GALLERY AND HOW MANY ARE
ACTUALLY LOOKING TO OUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN
KILEY FOR SPEAKING AND SINGING.
TO BE THE ONLY ONE THAT HAS
SOME LOGIC. I AM REALLY
APPALLED AS THE- ALL HAVE LIKED
TO HAVE BEEN TAKEN AWAY AND NOW
IN CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA THIRTY WITH THE
GOVERNING FROM A PERSON ONE
AFTER THAT MEDICAL FREEDOM
RIGHT THE GOING AFTER. CHILDREN
BETTER BEEN MEDIC DAMAGE BY
BACKING. AND NOW THEY'RE DOING
MAKE AT THE BY NOT ALLOWED OUR
GO TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHICH WE
SHOULD PROTECT FOR I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW WHEN PARENTS ARE GOING
TO START GETTING AN INCOME FOR
TAKING THE ROLE ON OF THE
TEACHER. SAID WE ARE NOT ABLE
TO GO TO WORK FOR THAT EXTRA
INCOME AS WE ARE DOING
DIFFICULT WORK I DO APPRECIATE
THE HARD WORK THAT THE TEACHERS
ARE DOING AND A LOT OF THEM
HAVE GONE ABOVE. AND BEYOND TO
IN ON TO SOMETHING THAT THEY
WERE NOT TRAINED FOR. THAT THIS
IS NOT OKAY AT SCHOOL DUE TO BE
OPENED FOR SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
PAYING FOR THEY NEED TO BE OPEN
AND IT SHOULD BE UP TO THE
PARENTS WHETHER. WE SEND OUR
KIDS TO SCHOOL ORNOT DON'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TO SEND
THEIR KIDS SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO AND DOES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND- WE IF YOU'RE
COME TO PAY. IT WILL REACHED
THE IN THE THANK YOU NEXT US.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT QUESTION
WILL COME FROM LINE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LAW IS OPEN FIFTY EIGHT
THANK YOU TIMES. HONORABLE
CHAIRMEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PETE
ORTIZ. I'M INTERESTED PERCENT
CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION. I WANT TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT MY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER US KALRA FOR
PRIORITIZING THE INEQUITY IN
ACCESS TO INTERNET AND DIGITAL
RESOURCES. IN OUR STATE THERE'S
NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT THIS
IS ONE OF THE MAJOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES OF MY
GENERATION. SANTA CLARA COUNTY
WORKING THAT LITTLE DATE S. B.
IN CAPS. PREVENTING STUDENTS
FROM BEING ABLE TO ACCESS AND
PARTICIPATE IN LIVE SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION. STREAMING AND
VIDEO CONFERENCING SERVICES
GENERALLY REQUIRE FOUR G.
INTERNET. OF BETWEEN FIVE
MEGABYTES PER SECOND TWENTY
FIVE MEGABYTES PER SECOND. IN
ADDITION THE BROADBENT
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA FOUND
THAT STUDENTS USE AT LEAST
FIFTY GIGABYTES OF DATA EVERY
TWO WEEKS WHEN ENGAGED IN
DIFFERENT LEARNING. WHAT I'M
GONNA PROVIDE SERVICE PROVIDERS
HAVE IMPROVED THE OFFERS DURING
THE PANDEMIC THE MAJORITY OF
MULLIN MADE CAUGHT OFFERS DO
NOT PROVIDE ADEQUATE INTERNET
SPEEDS FOR SYNCHRONOUS.
INSTRUCTION IN MANY CAPS OR
THROTTLE ONCE THE USER REACHES
TWENTY TWO GIGABYTES ATTENDED
TO BY THE DATA. I PIECE TO
ACCEPT STATE DOLLARS AND
BENEFIT FROM STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO CAP DATA OR THROTTLE
BE. THERE BUT- VENUE OUR
STUDENTS FROM ACCESSING.
DISTANCE LEARNING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BE SURE TO CALM AND
WE GO TO THE NEXT BEAKER. THE
NEXT FINAL COMPROMISE SIX
SIXTEEN NEARLY IS OPEN. AND
WITH. COMMENTED DORA GEAR BROWN
TO SCHOOL DISTURBING APRIL
BALLOT MORE ONE OF THE FATHERS
NOW TO UP MORE THIRD THIRD IN
PALM SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
SERVES COMPLETELY FROM THE.
NUMBERS ON YOU KNOW THAT CALM
AND STRUGGLED UP OUT GAME TO
THE MILLENNIAL UP WITH IN OUR
CAR BUT THE PROS ASK YOUR GET
THE FUNDING I'M NOT GONNA STORE
WILL A NON ARE NOT NOT BRITNEY
GRANT JOHN THERE'S BEEN PARENT
GOING THROUGH WITH THAT BUT
YOU'RE BOTH CALM IN MY READ.
IMPERIAL VALLEY POLICY WITH
UNIQUE CHAO AND- MR BORDER A
NEXUS THE NOT COMMUNITY
INVOLVED OPEN 9% OF STUDENTS
LATINO NEARLY 85% OR SOCIO NOT
WITH IF THERE ARE ANY LEARNERS
I WOULD FALL BELOW MEETINGS NOT
FOUNDERS OF LOOKING TO DOUBLE
EIGHTEEN OF BEING A STRONG
THING FOR ON THE THAT ARE OLDER
LARGE AS I'LL UP FOR HARPER WE
ARE THIS YOU DESTROY. STRUGGLE
TO KEEP IN MIND OR THEIR TO
COPE WITH WITH THE BEATLES OF
US ABOUT TODAY LABOR BARRIERS
HOMELESSNESS AND LETTERS AFTER
THREE DORSET'S CARE NONE OF
THAT THE RAISING GRUNGE AND
MANY TIMES IT'S OF ALL THOSE
THAT I MENTIONED MANY MORE THAT
COULD NOT THE STRUGGLE TO BE
IMPROVED VALLEY NOW UNLIKE
OTHER DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE IN OUR STATE AND JUST
LIKE THOSE AREAS WOULD BE THERE
TO BE HEARD I'M MORE
IMPORTANTLY HELP SO I WANT TO
TAKE THE TIME TO THINK. WITH
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA FOR
DOCTOR ABOUT TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU ARE SURE BUDGET WHAT THE
CHILD AND IMPERIAL COUNTY ONE
CHALLENGE OUT OF MANY THAT ARE
NOT MAGNIFY AND I DURING THE
AND THEN MAKE WOULD EVERYONE
CALL IT THE NO THE LESS OR
CIRCUMSTANCE. THAT WILL FIND
YOUR THAT AND ALSO JURY TO
REITERATE SOME MEMBER CALL TO
CAN THE PDF FILE MEETINGS
ACCORDING ALL OF YOU FOR THIS
HEARING THAT ALL AND ALL
INSIGHT AND PERSPECTIVES OF LA
THREE OUR ULTIMATELY HOW BOTH
WE ALL WERE LAW JUST. OUR
CHILDREN FAMILY THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR COMING TO VERY OF WE
GONE THE NEXT.
REMEMBER KALRA
COMMON. THAT DESPITE BEING IN
THE SILICON VALLEY THERE'S
STILL. PRETTY LARGE AREA IN OUR
COUNTY. WORKING ACTIVITY IS
LIMITED AT BEST. I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT- IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT WHETHER THERE ARE.
OFFERED OR AYE IF HE'S LOCATED
IN AN AREA IT'S ABOUT THE COST
TO ACTUALLY RECEIVE THOSE
SERVICES. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE LOW
COST OFFICER OFFERED PROVIDED
BY IRAQIS WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT THE MAJORITY OF THESE
OFFERS ARE LIMITED TO FAMILIES.
WHO ONLY MAKE A 130% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY RATE. AND AT
THE NUMBER WHAT THAT ACTUALLY.
IS FOR A FAMILY OF TWO THAT
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR AND FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR
THAT IS ONLY FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. IF YOU DO NOT
IF YOU MAKE ANYTHING MORE THAN
THAT YOU DO NOT QUALIFY FOR THE
LOW COST OFFERS- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT. THE
COMMITTEES ARE JOINTLY HOLDING
THIS HEARING TODAY AND I. HOPE
THAT THERE WILL BE FURTHER
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CALL TO REALLY APPRECIATE
MOVE ON THE NEXT WEEK. CANNOCK
PAGE WILL COME FROM WIND THREE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU TIMES ARTS.
THANK YOU THIS IS CHERYL
DOORMAN THE BRAIN CANNOT.
MILPITAS UNIFIED SCHOOL THIS.
I'M PROUD OF THE WORK THAT I
TEACHER AND BALK RIGHT MEMBER
PARENTS AND- ARE DOING AT THE
TIME OF LEARNING. BUT THE
ELEVEN HOURS OF FOR ANY US THE
END EVERYONE. BY CAP THE TURN
AND SIXTY. WITH THE- OF OVER
THREE THOUSAND DIGITAL THE- TWO
HUNDRED HOT BY THE BY DO WE DO
NOT HAVE ONE HUNDRED PER OF OUR
IN REGULARLY. WE HAVE FAMILY
CLOSE TO PEOPLE THE RED. WERE
HOT DID CREATE BAND NEED TO
STAY ONLINE. AND CLARA COUNTY
WE HAVE ENGAGED AS A READ TO
ENSURE OUR LOW ACT. AND YET IT
IS NOT ENOUGH. EVEN WITH LOW
COST INTERNET OFFERS IN STATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS SCHOOLS ARE
SPENDING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY MONTH TO CONNECT OUR
STUDENTS. THIS ADDITIONAL
CLASSES UNSUSTAINABLE. AND I'LL
PEATED UNIFIED WE STRIVE FOR A
CULTURE WE- I AM RIGHT YOU TO
JOIN US A MEETING GOAL BY THAT
ALL FAMILY. HAVE CONNECT AS THE
BASE YOU TO. I'M MUCH THE SAME
WAY AS HEAT AND ELECTRICITY AND
WATER PROVIDE DIGNITY. AND LYFT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT TO BE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED WILL GONE OF
EXPEDIA. YOUR NECKLINE WILL BE
LINE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU
TIME STARTS. AFTERNOON HI GOOD
AFTERNOON AND IT REMEMBER IT
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA ERIC SMITH AND I'M A
THIRD GRADE TEACHER AND CANNOT
BE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AS
WELL AS- THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER. CAMPBELL UNION HIGH
DISTRICT PARENTS CANNOT CALL.
AND ALSO A CO FOUNDER OF
DIGITAL EQUITY. SO I THE
CLASSROOM TEACHER IN THE BOARD
I IN THE VERY REAL CON. OF THE
DIGIT DIVIDE IN MY OWN STUDENTS
AND IN THEIR- I. A ARE THE
LINES OF SAYS ECONOMIC STATUS
THOSE WHO HAVE ACCESS THOSE WHO
DO NOT. HAVE BEEN MENTIONED.
THE PLAN FOR BY OUR INNER
SERVICE. SIMPLY ARE NOT A FISH.
THEY DO NOT WORK I TO TELL
STUDENTS. I'M FELT I KNOW YOU
WANT TO PRODUCE. BUT YOU'RE
GOOD AND I. HEAR YOU I HEAR MY
I HAD A LOT BOX SIX TIMES JUST
TO TRY TO COME BACK AND BE ABLE
HEAR YOU. THE STUDENTS ARE
MISSING OUT ON AND- EVERYTHING
DAY. THE STUDENT IN MY CLASS
COULD NOT TO CORPORATE. DAY
SIMPLY BECAUSE HER INTERNET
WORK THE IS NOT ENOUGH. I ALSO
WORKED WITH YOU IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND THEIR STRUGGLING
GET MENTAL SERVICES AND
EDUCATION SERVICES BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF CONNECTIVITY
ESPECIALLY IN OUR MORE RURAL
AREAS HERE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. DIGITAL PROVIDED
GREATER FURTHERING THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE WHO
HAVE ACCESS AND THOSE WHO DO
NOT AND IT'S SIMPLY NOT OK. AS
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS NEEDS TO
BE AN ISSUE JUST LIKE WATER
ELECTRICITY INTERNET IS NOT
ONLY FOR LEARNING. FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING BUT- IN A COMMUNITY.
ALL OF OUR RESOURCES ARE ON MY
AT THE POINT AND WE NEED. A
PATH YOU CAN AND- FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. TO BE ABLE TO.
THE TYPE OF LIGHT AND WE- THAT
THEY DESERVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS VERY OF.
WE GO TO THE NEXT SPEAKER. YEAH
IT WILL FROM MY SEVENTY TWO.
SEVENTY TWO YEAR LINE OF THE-
THANK YOU TIME STARTS BUT AFTER.
IT COULD NOT KEN LEWIS OUR
FEEDBACK WHICH ARE KALORAMA THE
CALIFORNIA RESURGENT. NETWORK
HI CAPACITY NETWORK DESIGNED TO
MEET THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF OVER
TWENTY MILLION USERS INCLUDING
VAST MAJORITY OF KEEP YOUR
TWENTY STUDENTS. I'M GIVEN CALL.
I WOULD HAVE LIKE THAT CURRENT
BENCH ARE COMPANIES BROWN ARE
NOT ADEQUATE AS MEDICARE DATE
PANDEMIC HAS REALLY HIGH. THAT
BROADBAND STANDARDS NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT ALL HOW COULD
ARE. BY THE DATE ORDER. AND
THAT AND THAT TIME OPINION YOU
COULD IN THE- I WAS SO SUCH WE
ENCOURAGE TO THAT MAGICAL THING
WHICH ARE ESPECIALLY ESSENTIAL
BURKE AND IN THE- BUT ALSO
BRING UP THAT NO TO REACH BLOCK
MILE YEAH LOOK LOOK IMPROVING
THAT AMOUNT THE STRUCTURE IN
THE STATE. AND THERE'S A NEED
FOR A AB OF THE COULD. LAW
AROUND FEDERAL E. RATE IN TERMS
OF THE FIVE WHICH IS THEM TO.
GOAL THEIR LIVES PROPERTY LINE
AND PUTTING IN MORE MONEY IT BY.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING
READ. WITH THE ORIGINAL FORWARD
THROUGH THE NEXT UNDERSTAND
SESSION THANK YOU. UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE IN THE
HEART OF SILICON VALLEY. MOPPED
UP ON MEMBER OF THE DIGITAL
EQUITY COALITION WHICH WAS
FOUNDED BY A GROUP OF EDUCATORS
WHO CURRENTLY SERVE ON SCHOOL
BOARDS. WE'RE GONNA PORTION
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES WEREN'T ABLE TO
CONNECT HIGH SPEED INTERNET
EVEN HERE IN THE HEART OF THE
SILICON VALLEY. I'M THANKFUL
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
COMMUNITY GROUPS ARE HIDDEN
COUNTY TURNED BACK IN OUR SHORT
TERM APPROACH THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. IN THE PURCHASING OF
HOT SPOT HOT BUTTON DEVICES.
YEAH THAT'S NOT NOT- WE ALSO
WORRY THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE SAME CONVERSATION AGAIN IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. UNLESS WE
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE LACK
OF LONG TERM INFRASTRUCTURE.
ARTICLE DISTRICT WITH THIS
ISSUE HEAD ON BUT WE TRULY
LACKED THE FUNDING TO ADDRESS.
THE LONG TERM. WE NEED THERE
COULD BE A PUBLIC UTILITY. IN
ADDITION ADDRESS LUBRICATION
LONG TERM INFRASTRUCTURE ARE.
HOPE COULDN'T. PUT IN MEASURES
IN PLACE TO PROTECT THEM NOW.
THAT MEANS MAKING SURE THE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
LOOKED AT EIGHT DOLLARS AND
THEN CONCERT OFFICIALS. SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED TO COPY THE
THROTTLE. AT THE END OF TO THAT
AFTER. THAT SERVICE PROVIDERS
AT MINIMUM IN AFFORDABLE OFFER
TO OUR- BUT THE- MEDIAN INCOME.
AND CUSTOMER SERVICE THAT THE
TOP UP ON CAER. THAT PUSHES.
CAN CHOOSE BETWEEN FOOD AND
OCCUPIED INTERNET. WE REALLY WE
TRULY AFTER TO PLEASE PLEASE
CALIFORNIA FOR. AND MAKE THE A
LONG TERM AND- PLAN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL WITH
THE VERY MUCH APPRECIATED WE
MOVE ON TO NEXT WEEK. GIVE AND
I COULD COME FROM LINE TO SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN YEAR LINE OF THE-
THEY YOU TIME STARTED. HI MY
NAME APPOINTED WOULD YOU. OF
BOARD FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN DAY A FOUR THREE TWO BLACK
EIGHT YEAR. AND PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA LATINO BOARD THE OF.
AND ALL UPTOWN OF CO FOUNDER
THE DJ EQUITY CAN OCCUR CAL. I
WANTED. THAT WE CANNOT ALLOW
OUR OUR FAMILY THE CO CARE OF
COLOR THE FURTHER INPUT BEHIND
IN MOVE ON AND STRUCK. BECAUSE
OF OUR IN A TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL. AND ARE A LINE OF ON
HIGHEST. I HAVE BEEN HOW BEEN
HELPED BUT THEIR WHOLE AND
BLOOD BEEN THE BIG BY THE HAVE
NOT BEEN ENOUGH OUR IT TIMES HI
BROADBAND IS THAT. RIGHT IT IS
THIS HUMAN. IT IS A RIGHT AND
ALL OF OUR QUEUE DESERVE RIGHT
HAVE BOTH FAMILIES NORTH ACTIVE
ALL THE NEXT PUBLIC UTILITIES
THEY NEED TO BE HOW TO LIVE A
LIFE. A FULLY BOARD THE- SO
PLEASE LET ALLOW BUT MAKE SURE
THAT WE OUR P. WHO. THE TO NOT
ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT FROM ARE
AT THE START AND PROVIDE THE
BOMB HOW CAPITA. AND PREVENTING
A STUDENTS WITH ACTED TO
LEARNING WE ALSO MAKE SURE HAVE
MAKE SURE THE WE DON'T ALLOW
SCHOOL. LOCAL TO GO BUT OUR OWN.
TO PAY MILLIONS OF THE FOR HOW
SPOT IN THE BY WHERE DOES WHAT
WE NEED TO BECOME THAT THE
STATE EXCHEQUER UP. SO PLEASE
LET ME THAT THE THAT THE LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY ALL
APPROACH TO WE TAKE THE TO
ADDRESS INDIVIDUAL BY. OFFICE
DATEABLE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE CALM
TO MOVE ON XP. AND TACKLE THIS
ISSUE THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION
BEGINS NEXT YEAR. NOTHING WELL
FEW THINGS ARE AS IN PART RIGHT
NOW IS TACKLING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE FOR OUR SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITY HAVE BEEN. UNDER
REPRESENTED THE LEFT BEHIND-
AND THE ABILITY TO CONNECT IN
THE DELETED HAVE INSTRUCTION.
AND EVERYONE PARTICIPATING BOTH
ON THE PANELS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I KNOW AND ARE JOINED
TOGETHER IN THE EFFORT. I TO
MAKE SURE WE TACKLE THIS ISSUE
THE BILL PROVIDING INSURANCE
COMMUNITIES. I GET THE GET THE
ADEQUATE- CONNECTION THE
TECHNOLOGY AT HOME. AND THE
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE FOR THE
NO GENERATIONAL BUT BEHIND.
THANK YOU ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE PARTICIPATED DAY
EVERYBODY PARTICIPATE A PAL AND
ALL OUR STAFF. AND PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE WHO WAITED TO BE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PARTICIPATION. IT MADE THE-
THE HEARING- ONE THAT IS
PRODUCTIVE. AND SUCCESSFUL
THANK YOU.